So, herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 31.
Über Trolle, die Empöreria und schlechte Laune in Lawinen.
Und wir haben da auch einen Experten-Gest dazu. Da begrüßen wir ganz herzlich im Studio den Linus.
Hallo.
Und wie immer müssen wir erst mal mit den Hausmeister-Themen anfangen. Stichwort, die lame excuse für die lange Pause seit der letzten Sendung.
Also ich möchte zu Protokoll geben, dass es vollständig Franks Schuld ist. Er hat hier einfach ausgesessen.
Das kann ich so nicht bestätigen. Fefe ist eigentlich dauernd irgendwo am Arsch der Heide und bekommt sie mit dem Internet und dem Remote-Senden so überhaupt gar nicht hin.
Na ja, Moment, also senden kann ich schon, aber das ist ja mal diese Apple-Gegenstelle, die dann irgendwie nicht zufrieden ist.
Ich glaube, das Kernproblem ist eigentlich, dass Internet so eine Technologie ist, die Fefe noch nicht reimplementiert hat.
Na ja, ist auf der Liste. Eigentlich geht es ja darum, dass wir hier Able-ismos vermeiden wollten.
Stimmt, das ist ganz wichtig. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt auch mal eine Reihe um unsere Privilegien checken.
Meine sind noch da.
Sieht gut aus, alles da.
Ja, hier auch.
Gut, alles prima. Ja, dann fangen wir mal an. Warum ist es da draußen jetzt eigentlich so ungemütlich? Da draußen sind lauter Leute mit schlechter Laune, die irgendwie den ganzen Tag ihr Missfallen ausdrücken und rumpöbeln und nicht in der Lage sind, ihre Begeisterung auszudrücken, obwohl na ja, doch manchmal schon.
Ich hab da die Theorie, dass die schon ihre Begeisterung ausdrücken, aber dass du das nicht mitkriegst, weil du so ein Modell hast, die Welt zu sehen, wo die Begeisterung schon eingepreist ist. Du hältst dich ja, wenn du jetzt das Feedback zu irgendwas machst, ich hab zwar einen Mac, aber du musst den nicht ausdrücken. Genau, das ist vollkommen, das ist genau so.
Dass ich davon diese Leute finde, die da total verblendet durch die Welt laufen.
Hey, die 100.000 Aussagen, oh ist das alles toll mit meinem Apple, die siehst du gar nicht mehr, weil du die für normal hältst. Aber die drei Leute, die sagen, Apple ist scheiße, die nimmst du wahr. Das ist auch mit dem Rezipienten zu tun. Aber weil wir das nicht so genau wissen und eine Theorie haben, haben wir extra einen Experten eingeladen, der uns das nachher ausführlich...
Also jedenfalls, was wir beobachten können, ist, dass wir eigentlich, wenn wir so ins Inhalt gucken, die Debatten oder die Diskussionen sich eigentlich nur so zwischen hypen. Nämlich irgendwie super toll, alles ganz prima, diese Sähen müssen wir unbedingt alle ganz toll finden und bashen für so. Also es ist halt scheiße, geht gar nicht, kann man nicht benutzen und so weiter.
Die Konstruktivität fehlt.
Genau, es gibt halt keine so richtigen Debatten mehr.
Nur noch Hysterie. Auch ein bisschen angefächert durchaus von kommerziellen Interessen. Die Produkte. Heute machst du ja keine Werbung mehr, sondern du machst virale Werbung. Es gibt schon handfeste Interessen dahinter, dass es nicht nur irgendwie auch so funktioniert, sondern Hype.
Ja, aber vielleicht, also wenn man sich so Twitter anguckt, dann ist es häufiger so, dass diese Versuche halt so eine Werbe, Viralismen loszutreten, ja immer häufiger auffallen, weil sie nicht mehr so, also wo sie nicht so ganz echt von Herzen kommen und eigentlich nur Erfolg haben, wenn das Produkt nur ganz am Rande vorkommt. Also wenn es dann halt ein cooles, hübsches Video ist oder so oder herzerwärmend oder so, wo dann halt am Schluss nochmal eine kurze Werbebotschaft eingeblendet wird oder so, weil das tolerieren die Leute dann aber so richtige, wie es früher gab, so diese Marken-Hypes, gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr so richtig.
Ne, gerade heute scrollte wieder einer an mir vorbei, ging um irgendeine Müsli-Werbung oder so, wo sie da eine gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe gezeigt haben in ihrem Werbefilm und dafür Flak gekriegt haben, wo man ja auch mal nicht weiß, ist das jetzt echt oder nicht, aber nehmen wir mal an, es gab echt einen Ärger und dann haben sie einen zweiten Werbespot gemacht, wo sie das verarbeitet haben in eine neue Werbebotschaft. Also es gibt schon immer noch...
Hä, was denn, wie denn?
Sie haben zwei Künstler angestellt, die haben die bösen Einsendungen ausgedruckt und daraus so ein Wort Love gebaut.
Das finde ich eigentlich eine ganz gute Reaktion.
Ja, ist es auch, aber es ist halt ein Werbe, es ist immer noch Werbung für die Firma.
Ja, okay.
Also das ist ganz klar ein Versuch, viral zu sein.
Das ist ja interessant, das heißt, dass politischen Debatten in ihrer Identitätsstiftung erkannt wurden und jetzt von der Werbeindustrie quasi aufgenommen werden. Dass man sagt, okay, es geht jetzt gerade um gleichgeschlechtliche Ehe oder so, das ist ein Aufregerthema, da können wir...
Da springen wir mal auf.
Das ist ja krass.
Also man kann generell beobachten, wenn man mit Leuten im Internet zu diskutieren versucht, dass es da eigentlich als Ergebnis selten Überzeugen gibt, sondern immer nur entweder Bullying oder einer gibt halt auf und an keinen Bock mehr.
Was auch damit zu tun hat, dass es als schwächer angesehen wird, seine Meinung zu ändern, was ich ja auch persönlich extrem elend finde. Also wenn mich jemand überzeugt mit sachlichen Argumenten, dann nenne ich gerne meine Meinung. Aber irgendwie sind die allermeisten Leute dazu nicht mehr in der Lage, das nicht als dann hat der andere verloren zu interpretieren.
Das hat ja auch ein bisschen damit zu tun, wie es wird uns ja jeden Tag auch vorgelebt, nehmt ihr so eine Talkshow, da geht ja keiner hin. Also wenn ihr jetzt so eine Anne will oder jetzt macht das ja Günter Jauch, stellt ihr mal vor, da würde einer hingehen.
Und sagen, Sie haben völlig recht, ich mach das jetzt.
So habe ich das noch gar nicht gesehen. Mensch, das ist ja echt krass. Nee, da haben Sie recht.
Das machen wir morgen an, danke.
Das passiert halt nicht. Talkshows werden gewonnen und auch mit ganz klaren, rhetorischen Methoden und Mitteln. Und ja, teilweise schlägen unter der Gürtellinie. Es gibt Schlagabtausch, der dann irgendwie, das ist quasi fair, es ist eigentlich wie Boxen, so eine Talkshow. Es geht dabei darum, dem anderen irgendwie einen mitzugeben und am Ende stehen zu bleiben und einen guten Eindruck gemacht zu haben.
Na ja, gut, ich meine, Talkshows sind natürlich insofern vielleicht auch eine interessante Analogie, weil wenn man sich so Leute anguckt, die in Talkshows sitzen und dann trifft man die mal so im echten Leben, hat man dann mal so einen Eindruck, vor den Fernsehkameras kommen die so 20 Prozent dummer rüber, als sie eigentlich sind.
Es muss ja nicht immer schlecht sein, dass in der Talkshow die Menschen richtig sind. Nein, ganz ehrlich.
Manchmal ist es auch gar nicht so einfach, da 20 Prozent abzuziehen.
Man kann immer 20 Prozent abziehen. Der Punkt ist, du kannst in so einer Talkshow, warum sollten die Leute sich am Ende auf was einigen? Ich kann ja auch gut argumentieren, die Leute sollen ihre Standpunkte darstellen, möglichst überspitzt, damit der Zuschauer sieht, ah, das ist also das, was jetzt hier die Meinung dieser beiden Vertreter ihrer Zunft unterscheidet. Dann sitze ich zu Hause und kann mit einem der beiden mitfiebern und mich freuen, wenn er dem anderen irgendwie einen drückt. Oder man kann natürlich vielleicht auch tatsächlich zu Hause sitzen und über beide stark überspitzt formulierten Positionen nachdenken und sich am Ende tatsächlich seine eigene Meinung bilden. Das könnte ja echt sein. Also theoretisch könnte man argumentieren, dass das das ist, was bei so einer Sendung Günther Jauch rauskommt.
Also ich hab ja da mal mit einem der Talkshow-Hosts in Deutschland, ich nenne mal keine Namen, die relativ bekannt sind, drüber geredet. Exakt auch über dieses 20-Prozent-Phänomen. Und die Antwort war sehr frappierend. Die war nämlich so zum einen ja, also für die meisten Leute, die da hinkommen zu so einer Talkshow, ist es irgendwie die Situation, also Lichtkameras, kramhaftes Konzentrieren auf die Punkte, die sie machen wollen. Deswegen sie halt irgendwie dümmer rüberkommen, als sie eigentlich sind. Und für die anderen, also sprich den Moderator, den Moderatorinnen und die Profis, ist es Absicht oder nicht? Es ist Absicht, weil die sich halt immer vorher vorstellen, wie die Hausfrau am Bügelbrett steht und mit ihrem eingeschränkten Aufmerksamkeitspotenzial und vielleicht nicht gänzlich ausgeprägter Bildung und Intelligenz, da halt dann den Versuch zu verstehen, worum es da geht. Ich denke, vielleicht haben wir so einen ähnlichen Effekt auch bei Kommentarfeldern.
Fefe, warum hast du eigentlich keine Kommentare in deinem Blog?
Da gibt es mehrere Gründe. Der erste war, ich habe keinen Bock gehabt, das zu programmieren. Der zweite war, ich habe mir angesehen damals, als ich meinen Blog aufgemacht habe, da gab es der Reihe nach irgendwelchen Ärger bei irgendwelchen anderen Leuten, weil irgendwelche duven Kommentare waren und da gab es dann Abmahnungen und dann gab es so eklige Gerichtsentscheide, dass eine Störerhaftung existiert bei dem Betreiber von dem Webforum, wenn er irgendwie Sachen da reinlässt, die anstößig sind und das ist alles ganz, ganz furchtbar gewesen. Ich dachte, eigentlich will ich das auch nicht. Und nach ein paar Jahren gab es dann so ein schönes Interview mit Stephen Fry. Und er hat gesagt, er liest ja das Internet immer so mit einer Hand vorm Auge, so vor der unteren Hälfte von dem Auge, weil er genau weiß, oben ist so der schöne Teil und unten ist so der Bodensatz, so was du auf keinen Fall sehen willst, weil es dir den Tag kaputt macht. Und er meint, das geht halt gar nicht. Am liebsten, wenn du das alles technisch wegfiltern. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, der hat eigentlich völlig recht. Eigentlich hat der völlig recht. Und dann habe ich auch nie Kommentare gemacht, außer einem als April-Scherz. Aber da auch so, dass man immer einen Cup-Jugger gekriegt hat, an dem man gescheitert ist. So mit irgendwie animiertes Gift. Nee, ach, ich habe da eigentlich, das ist eigentlich ganz lustig, ich habe einige schöne gehabt, so mit irgendwelchen Sci-Fi-Ruinen, die es also garantiert nicht in Unicode gibt. Und eins war aber auf Elbisch aus dem Herrn der Ringe. Und dann hat mir jemand tatsächlich ein Bug-Report geschickt, dass er das Elbisch eingegeben hat und nicht durchkam. Ja gut, aber grundsätzlich stehe ich da nach wie vor zu und ich bin auch froh, dass es da keine Foren gibt, weil dann müsste ich den ganzen Tag irgendwie, da könnte ich nachts nicht ruhig schlafen. Wer weiß, was die Leute da irgendeiner postet, irgendwie eine Todesdrohung gegen jemanden oder was weiß ich. Und dann bin ich da irgendwie am Ende angreifbar. Also das ist irgendwie, da könnte ich nicht mitschlafen.
Ich bin da ja eigentlich ein bisschen schmerzfreier.
Also man muss dazu sagen, Linus hat ja, um das uns zu sagen, für die Unangeweihten zu erklären, Linus hat ja genau das getan. Der hat nämlich sozusagen Kommentare für Fefes Blog gebaut.
Und das ist ja auch mal als Aprilscherz los oder so? Nee, zum Kongress war das, ne?
Zum Kongress. Also der Hintergrund zu der Re-Fefe-Seite war, dass wir bei Netzpolitik Org saßen und es war häufig so, dass wir da Kommentare hatten von Menschen, die dann mit sehr abstrusen Gedanken, Diskussionen entfachten und sich früher oder später dann irgendwann immer auf dich beriefen.
Ja super.
Dann haben wir überlegt, wie wäre das denn, wenn wir es schaffen, die irgendwie woanders hin zu kanalisieren? Und so kam dann irgendwann die Idee zu sagen, dann machen wir doch mal Rehe-Fefe auf und dann propagieren wir das, dass sie sich da austauschen können. Und für ein, ich weiß nicht, wie lange war das jetzt? 27C3? Also über drei Jahre habe ich das betrieben. Konnte auch immer ruhig schlafen.
Hat auch funktioniert, ne?
Hat funktioniert, hat super funktioniert. Also das Ding war, das hatte relativ viele Besucher und auch sehr, sehr viele Kommentare pro Tag.
Der Blitzableiter in der Netzpolitik.
Denke es war, also für Netzpolitik Org war es ein Blitzableiter. Jetzt, als ich es geschlossen habe, kamen sehr, sehr viele E-Mails von Menschen, die das auch als Blitzableiter für ihre eigene Tätigkeit gesehen haben. Also die insgesamt waren die Leute jetzt traurig und haben sich gefürchtet, wo denn jetzt die Rehfefeschar sich jetzt hinbegibt. Weil man muss ja dazu sagen, es ist da ja, glaube ich, nicht wirklich jemals so wirklich was geschrieben worden, was jemand weitergebracht hat. Wir haben es ja, ich habe da ja mal auf der Republika so einen kleinen Vortrag zugemacht. Da haben wir es ja wirklich versucht mit Analysen, da ich mir das zum ersten Mal wirklich angeschaut, da haben wir so zum Beispiel einfach geguckt, wie gut sich die Kommentare komprimieren lassen. Also was ist das Kompressionsverhältnis des Kommentars? Stell dich raus, du kannst ja tatsächlich dadurch erkennen, wie gehaltvoll der ist. Und der gehaltvollste Kommentar neben dann irgendwie so ein Binary-Dump, den jemand da reinkommentiert hat, oder eben so ein PDF oder sowas, war dann irgendwie tatsächlich einer, wo jemand einen Gedanken geäußert hat. Das war eine Ergänzung. Also es war tatsächlich...
Ihr habt den Gedanken gefunden?
Da war ein Gedanken. Und der gehaltloseste Kommentar war dann irgendwie, ja, ich weiß nicht, das ist sowas, wofür man abgemahnt wird, aber ich hab halt die Suchmaschine so optimiert, dass diese Seite nicht so gut gefunden wird, wenn zumindest diese Kommentare nicht gefunden werden. Und hab da eigentlich, glaub ich, nicht ein einziges Mal was gelöscht. Ich hab ja dann irgendwann die Troll-Drossel eingebaut.
Das können wir später noch mal sehen.
Kommen wir später noch zu.
Also vielleicht sollten wir kurz mal drüber reden, was sind denn das eigentlich so für Leute, die so Kommentare schreiben? Wir sollten doch vielleicht einfach mal einen heldenhaften Klassifizierungsversuch unternehmen.
Ja, naja, das kommt natürlich auch das Forum an, auf das man jetzt guckt. Eine Sache, die man beobachten kann, je spezieller das Forum ist, desto weniger betroffen sind die. Also wir machen nachher so einen ein bisschen historischen Überblick aufs Usenet. Der Academic Forum ist noch mal speziell, aber irgendein Experten-Spezial-Wissenschaftler-Forum ist wahrscheinlich weniger betroffen als ein Hartz-IV-Forum. Jetzt nicht, weil da irgendwie schlaure Leute rumhängen, sondern einfach weil das Thema spezieller ist und weil weniger Leute den Eindruck haben, so sind die jetzt als Publikum angesprochen und gehen da jetzt hin. Gibt es aber trotzdem grundsätzlich in allen Foren, die größte Teilnehmermenge sind die Lörker. Das sind Leute, die einfach rumhängen und lesen und nie irgendwas sagen. Außer so nach fünf Jahren oder so kommt dann ein...
Ich lese jetzt hier schon seit fünf Jahren.
Und das ist alles furchtbar und kreist auch immer zusammen. So das sind die Lörker.
Ja, genau. Obwohl die häufiger tatsächlich ja mal, also wenn sie dann nach fünf Jahren mal platzen, ja ja durchaus auch mal Beiträge abliefern. Das kommt ja echt vor. Dass sie dann halt so eine Metereinsicht in die Debatte haben, die man dann sonst irgendwie echt sich mühsam zusammenpuppeln muss.
Da das die größte Anzahl ist, ich finde das ja echt immer spannend. Man merkt das bei allem, was man veröffentlicht. Sei es ein Blogpost, sei es ein Podcast. Du hast dann irgendwann von mir aus sehr, sehr viele Kommentare. Also viele Kommentare, es geht dann vielleicht ab 50. Da denkt man an, okay, wird viel kommentiert. Dann können das auch mal 100 werden. Das ist dann echt viel. Und wenn man in diesen 100 Kommentaren sich auch Kritik sammelt oder als Mehrheit darstellt, die er als derjenige, der das Werk verfasst hat, dann wird man ja vielleicht auch mal so ein bisschen nervös. Und denkt dann so drüber nach. Jetzt kriege ich hier von 100 Leuten von dir vielleicht von 20 Identitäten einer Person gleichzeitig aufs Maul. Aber das Interessante ist, wenn du das dann ins Verhältnis sitzt, zu der Leserzahl, es ist verschwindend gering. Es ist tatsächlich so, sehr wenige Menschen, na ok, daraus kann ich nicht darauf schließen, wie viele Leute die Kommentare lesen, aber wenige Menschen kommentieren. Es sind natürlich in der Regel diejenigen, die sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen angesprochen fühlen und meinen, sie müssen irgendwelchen Widerspruch geben. Das heißt, es passiert eigentlich sehr selten, dass du Kommentare kriegst, wo du das findest, super.
Das ist übrigens eine sehr interessante Sache. Ich habe ja eine Kommentarfunktion, die ist nur nicht öffentlich, man kann mir eine Mail schicken. Und der Prozentsatz an negativen Meldungen bei Mails ist irgendwie 0,0% aber auf Refefe ist das Verhältnis von positiven Meldungen irgendwie 0,3%. Das heißt, man sieht relativ deutlich, wenn Leute inhaltlich was beizutragen haben, also wo der Sinn der Meldung nicht nur ist, zu sagen, ey du Idiot, ich weiß es besser als du, sondern wo es darum geht, die Diskussion weiterzubringen, die haben auch überhaupt kein Problem, damit es nicht öffentlich zu machen. Aber die Leute, die meckern wollen, um sich selbst mehr Status zu verpassen, die machen das gerne öffentlich.
Ich glaube, es könnte daran liegen, dass Menschen mit einem Hang zum Konstruktiven wissen, dass die Kommentarspeite nicht gelesen wird. Das kann ich lieber in einem Mail sagen.
Das gibt es ja lustigerweise nicht stimmt. Also jetzt bei Refe für Max stimmt es, aber allgemein ist es so, alle Journalisten, die ich kenne, lesen zwanghaft alle Kommentare unter ihren...
Ich nicht.
Na du hast ja auch keine wirkliche Kommentare auf den Zungen. Na bei der FATS ja, okay, aber...
Bei der FATS gibt es irgendwie die tonnenweise Kommentare. Interessanterweise sind die meisten Kommentare zu Themen, wo es mich echt überrascht. Also zum Beispiel, wo ich am allermeisten Flak bekommen habe, überhaupt, war bei meinem Fukushima-Artikel. So, wo ich mal grundsätzlich irgendwie erklärt habe, dass mit dieser Tonkraft gleich eine scheiß Idee ist.
Sag mal, woher weißt du das, wenn du es nicht gelesen hast?
Nee, da habe ich es tatsächlich gelesen, weil mich die Redaktion darauf hingewiesen hat, dass da eine ungewöhnliche Menge Kommentare einschlägt. So, und dann habe ich dann mal so ein bisschen die analysiert festgestellt, okay, so ungefähr ein Drittel war offensichtlich beauftragte Social-Media-Unternehmen der Atomindustrie, die halt da rumgewildert haben. Aber dann waren da offenbar auch noch so ein paar richtig Überzeugte. Also so ein paar so richtig so Leute, die so ins Mark getroffen sind, dass in ihrem heiligen konservativen Blatt jemand die Atomenergie anpinkelt. Vor allen Dingen habe ich es daran gemerkt, in demselben Stil gab es dann nicht nur Kommentare, sondern auch Briefe. Oh. Also richtig so Briefbrief so, ja. Wenn sie diesen Menschen mit Abokündigungsdrohungen. Ja klar. Aber das hat sich bei Zeitung die Metrik, ne? Natürlich. Ja, ja.
Aber wir wollten glaube ich in Klassifizierung weiterkommen. Wir sind über den Lurker bisher nicht hinausgekommen.
Dann haben wir noch den Noob.
Der zweite ist der Noob. Der kommt und stellt bescheuerte Fragen. Es gibt da aus seligen Usenet-Zeiten einen Konstrukt namens FAQ. Das sind die Frequently Asked Questions. Das ist einfach eine Liste von den häufigen Fragen und mit sinnvollen Antworten, damit man nicht jedes Mal bei Adam und Eva anfangen muss.
Es gibt spezifische Mailing-Listen und Usenet-Gruppen. Also bei, nehmen wir mal ein Extrembeispiel, sowas wie das Heiseforum oder Refefe, da gibt es ja keine FAQ. Obwohl, gut, bei dir gibt es eine FAQ.
Bei mir gibt es eine FAQ, bei Refefe gibt es auch eine. Die ist zwar eher so ein Feigenblatt, aber es gibt eine, ne?
Verstehe ich nicht, ist das nicht deine?
Klugweiß kann sein, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht, Refefe gibt es nicht mehr.
Ist ja auch egal. Aber es gibt es auch ein häufiges Konstrukt, um diese Newbs loszuwerden. Und es hilft überhaupt nicht.
Es gibt kein dokumentiertes Fall, dass da jemands in einem Video...
Ich habe tatsächlich schon mehrfach doofe Fragen nicht gestellt, weil ich erst mal die FAQ gelesen habe.
Das ist lustigerweise so eine Sache, die ich an der Stelle mal ansprechen will. Also das war so eine meiner Freizeitbeschäftigungen im Usenet, dass ich den Leuten erzählt habe, es gibt eine FAQ, lese die verdammt nochmal. Und dann kam eigentlich immer zurück, hey, du hast auch mal angefangen und da hast du bestimmt auch die FAQs nicht gelesen. Und das stimmt nicht.
Ich lese die.
Man liest die vorher, als es dann Deja-News gab, zwischen Google News und Total in Kern, aber da konnte man irgendwie so die ältesten Usenet-Postings raussuchen. Und das habe ich dann mal gemacht, um mal zu sehen, ob ich irgendwo Beweise für eine blöde Frage finde, die mit der FAQ hätte gestellt, beantwortet werden kann. Nein, man kann sich da viel Ärger ersparen. Ich habe mich irgendwann so über diese Leute geärgert, dass ich so ein Best-of auf meine Webseite gestellt habe vor vielen, vielen Jahren. Und da kam dann nach Jahren, so nach so was wie sieben oder acht Jahren, kam dann eine Mail von einem Typen, er versucht sich gerade zu bewerben, und die Leute haben den Namen gegugelt, genau, die sollen mal ihre Jugendsünden da entfernen. Und da habe ich mir so, Leute, denkt doch da vorher drüber nach. Das ist ja keine Magie hier.
Na ja gut, sieben, acht Jahre ist verjährt.
Vor sieben, acht Jahren weiß ich nie, was sie in irgendwelchen Foren geschrieben haben.
Sieben, acht Jahre ist verjärt.
Ja, natürlich ist es verjärt, aber das weiß ja auch der Typ, der das googelt.
Na, weiß ich nicht.
Bei Facebook sind die alten Sachen auch noch irgendwo in irgendwelchen Archiven. Das ist aktueller denn je, dieses Problem.
Da hat der auch digitale Radiogummi gefahren.
Ja, also, Newbs. Ja, dann Linus.
PHP Foren, erster Poster.
Genau.
Ja, die gab es bei Refefe immer.
Na, die gibt es auch sonst überall. Slashdot, glaube ich, Slashdot waren die ersten, wo es mir aufgefallen ist.
Was ist denn der Sinn davon eigentlich?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Nix.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Lustigerweise gibt es dann auch Leute, die zweiter posten, wenn ich so...
Ich habe in dem Refefe-Vortrag, also ich hatte ja immer das Veröffentlichungsdatum, das konnte man ja zurückrechnen aus deinem Timestamp, und dann den Eintrag in der Datenbank bei mir. Und ich glaube, der schnellste Kommentar bei Refefe war irgendwas von acht Sekunden. Inklusive Capture lösen, schreiben, Artikel lesen, Wahnsinn. Und es war nicht erster.
Naja, lesen ist glaube ich zu viel gesagt, oder? Doch. Was sich auf den Inhalt bezogen, echt?
Das haben die sich in der Regel sowieso nicht. Wenn, dann haben die sich auf einzelne Wörter bezogen. Ja, war klar. Erster Poster?
Dann zu Wikipedia-Experten. Also Leute, die den Artikel lesen und sagen, der Begriff heißt aber was anderes und dann irgendwie länglicher. Oder also Wikipedia ist jetzt der Überbegriff. Das gilt auch für Juristen.
Ja, und auch Leute, die tatsächlich kein eigenes Expertenwissen, zum Beispiel in so Foren zu dem Thema haben.
So die Jure, die e zitieren, aber im Grundgesetzparagrafen nur umsteht.
Aber tatsächlich keine eigene Ahnung zu dem Thema haben, sondern nur teilweise eben durch Wikipedia-Absätze pasten.
Was ja nicht schlimm wäre, wenn die passen würden, aber nicht mal das ist ja grundsätzlich der Fall.
Ja, und häufiger meine Wikipedia ist ja, da kommen wir später noch dazu, hat ja auch so ein gewisses Problem.
Auch ein Treuproblem.
Ja, und naja, nicht nur ein Treuproblem, aber dann gibt es natürlich noch die Regelfetischisten, das sind ja eigentlich so mein Liebsten. Also die fordern in allererster Linie erstmal eine klare Namenspflicht, das ist ganz wichtig.
Wir haben nachher so noch so eine Liste, was es da so in Klassikern gibt. Aber so die bekanntesten gehen auch aufs Usenet zurück. Also ursprünglich fing es ja an, so als eine Mailing-Liste mit Untertopics. Und dann wurde die zu groß und dann haben sie es gesplittet und dann haben sie es nochmal gesplittet. Und dann gab es eine Hierarchie. Und es wurden immer noch zu viele Leute. Und irgendwann fängt man dann an, sich so Heuristiken zurechtzulegen, welche man komplett ignoriert. Eine der frühen Heuristiken war, dass man sagt, im September lese ich keine Mail von Unis, weil da kommen die ganzen Neulingen zu den Unis. Und die haben alle keine Ahnung und posten nur Scheiße. Und so was wie Klar-Namenspflicht ist auch einfach der Versuch zu sagen, okay, das kann ich mir direkt sparen, den zu lesen. Oder ein bisschen später hat man dann gesagt, okay, aol.com kann weg. Und es hat sich dann aber verfeinert. Es gab so Sachen wie das McFarry-Limit. Da ging es dann darum, dass man unter seinen Artikeln eine Signature haben kann. Heute kennt man das nur noch mit diesen pseudo juristischen Disclaimern. Aber früher gab es da halt irgendwie witzige Sprüche und so. Die sind abgetrennt worden durch zwei Minuszeichen und ein Leerzeichen. Und dann das McFarry-Limit sagt, höchstens vier Zeilen danach. Was überhaupt keinen Sinn hat, da eine Begrenzung zu machen. Was soll das? Aber die Leute haben gesagt, okay, wenn er sich daran schon nicht hält. Und ich finde rückblickend, es gibt so eine schöne Geschichte. Ich glaube, es war Bon Jovi, also irgendeine von diesen Bands war das jedenfalls.
Mit den M&M's.
Mit den M&M's, genau. Die Geschichte erzählen wir mal kurz, weil die passt einfach an der Stelle schön. Die haben nämlich in ihrem Kleingedruckten stehen gehabt, wenn wir irgendwo auftreten, dann hat es da eine Schüssel mit M&M's zu stehen, aber ohne braune M&M's. Und der Hintergrund war nicht, dass die spleenig waren, sondern dass die irgendwo aufgetreten waren und festgestellt haben, der Veranstalter hat ihre Gewichtsangaben nicht gelesen.
Von dem Bühnequipment.
Dann ist ihnen der Bühnenboden eingebrochen in ihrem Konzert. Und das war richtig furchtbar, traumatisch. Und haben sie gesagt, okay, also, um dem vorzubeigen, machen wir jetzt diesen M&M. Und wenn wir dahin kommen und da sind braune M&M's drin, wissen wir, der hat den Scheiß nicht gelesen. Und dann trauen wir auch dem Rest nicht. Und so muss man auch diese Regelfetischisten verstehen an der Stelle, die einfach sagen, okay, wenn du da schon den normalen Namen nicht drin hast, sondern ein blödes Pseudonym, oder wenn du nicht richtig quotest, auch so ein Klassiker, Top-Posting war im Jusenland immer so das Feindbild, dann können wir dich sofort ignorieren, einfach aus formalen Gründen. Das ist ja bei Gericht auch so. Wenn du da nicht in der Lage bist, deine Anklage oder dein Problem ordentlich formal korrekt zu beschreiben, dann fliegst du halt raus.
Wenn hellen, war die Band.
Wenn hellen, war die Band, okay. Also eine schlaue Sache, finde ich. Tolle Geschichte auch.
Also so eine Art, wir machen das hier nur mit denen, die die Regeln kennen. Aber eigentlich definiert sich doch dann dieses Forum, in dem ich bin Teil des So und So Forums. Ich habe 5000 Beiträge schon geschrieben in irgendeiner Usenet-Gruppe. Das sind ja Dinge, die auf die Menschen dann ganze Identitäten begründen. Die brauchen ja auch immer wieder einen neuen Noob, der reinkommt, der gegen ihre Regeln verstößt, damit sie dann alle schreiben können. Du hast die FAQs nicht gelesen. Was ist das überhaupt für eine blöde Frage? Du musst den Reifen anders flicken, sonst platzt der Schlauch oder so.
Identität durch Abgrenzung.
Ja, aber die machen es ja trotzdem.
Keiner schafft es dir dann, die einfach wegzueignorieren. Was du gerade beschrieben hast, funktioniert ja bei den PHP-Formen nicht mehr.
Das stimmt, das ist ein Problem. Aber so rum würde ich das nicht sehen, denn gerade im Usenet gab es viele Leute, die als ihre Identität gesehen haben, dass sie in dieser Newsgroup über Wim abhängen und den Leuten Wim erklären. Und die investieren so viel Lebenszeit, dass sie einfach für sich selbst eine Metrik brauchen, um zu sagen, wenn du schon so wenig Vorarbeit investierst. Also das habe ich persönlich nicht erlebt, dass Leute gesagt haben, ich definiere mich darüber, dass ich die anderen abkanzeln kann, sondern das ist wirklich als Selbstverteidigungsmechanismus hat das angefangen. Ich will es nicht ausschließen, dass es in Webforen anders ist und später vielleicht auch im Usenet, aber das ist mir persönlich so nicht begegnet, dass Leute gesagt haben, jetzt kann ich hier wieder jemanden rausschmeißen. Weil das ja auch nicht funktioniert. Im Gegenteil, wenn du auf solche Leute antwortest, dann antworten die zurück und dann gibt es einen dritten. Das ist wie so ein Reply to Allstorm. Dann kommt noch einer, ey, könnt ihr das nicht woanders diskutieren? Das ist totaler Bullshit, hat noch nie geholfen, jemandem zu sagen, du bist doof, geh weg, ist bewirkt das Gegenteil. Leider gibt es halt auch Leute, die nicht merken, wenn du sie ignorierst und die einfach weiter posten. Dann ist das halt ein Problem.
Dann muss man sie halt weiter ignorieren. Ja, dann gibt es natürlich noch die Rechtschreib-Nazis, ne?
Ja, also das mach ich jetzt nicht. Du als Betroffener...
Also, das ist jetzt so der Klassiker-Ding, gibt's auf Twitter gerne mal, dass irgendwie Leute, wenn sie kein inhaltliches Argument haben, sich halt irgendwie an deiner Rechtschreibung hochziehen oder... Also hast du bestimmt auch, ne?
Natürlich. Also ich muss sagen, mein Blog sieht zwar aus, als wenn es irgendwie poliert wäre, wenn man da irgendwie sich die Softwareseite anguckt, aber es gibt halt kein... Die Infrastruktur ist nicht da, das ist nicht irgendwie massenkompatibel, sondern ich editiere da irgendwelche Files und schreibe da HTML rein und das ist nicht so, dass da irgendwie ein Rechtschreibscanner drin ist, der mich hinweist, wenn ich irgendwas falsch schreibe oder wenn Tech nicht zugeht. Deswegen passiert das regelmäßig, aber ich schreib auch gelegentlich Namen falsch, die ich eigentlich pasten könnte aus dem Artikel, aber ich schreib sie absichtlich falsch, um so diese Art von Kommentatoren zu pieksen, die dann kommen. Ja, gerade irgendwie vor zwei Tagen oder so gab es ein Artikel über, da war irgendwie ein meine Punchline war, Uli Hoeneß weiß jeder wer das ist, aber wer irgendwie der zuständige Minister für Sport ist, weiß keine Sau, was sich dann sehr schön ironisch bewahrtet hat, weil auch, wie ich glaubte, wer zuständig ist, war nicht für Sport zuständig. Also hab mich sozusagen selbst bestätigt, aber der Punkt war halt, Hoeneß war irgendwie die Punchline und den hab ich halt nicht mit OE, sondern mit OE geschrieben und dann gab es tatsächlich jemanden, der sich entblödet hat einfach. Der kann ja nicht mal Hoeneß richtig schreiben und mehr war über den ganzen Artikel, der Rest, weißt du, komplexe Gedankengänge, spielt alles keine Rolle, der hat Hoeneß falsch geschrieben.
Ja, Fefe, du hattest halt die Fußball-FHQ nicht gelesen.
Nein, es ging nicht um die FHQ. Ich freue mich, wenn es solche Leute gibt, weil die sich ja selbst öffentlich entleiben, aus meiner Sicht. Weil mehr musste zu dieser Person nicht wissen, als wenn der aus so einem Artikel, der hat Hoeneß falsch geschrieben, rauszieht und das ist alles, was er so als Quintessenz aus dem Artikel rauszieht. Das finde ich perfekt und wenn er das auch noch öffentlich macht, ja super, habe ich gewonnen, finde ich. Also das finde ich großartig.
Wobei natürlich so ein nitpicking findet man ja überall, ne?
Ja, ich kann sowas nicht leiden, weißt du, weil ich also ich nitpick zwar auch gern, will ich jetzt nicht leugnen.
Aber was andere Leute nitpicken, das geht ja mal gar nichts.
Nein, also ich finde nitpicken ist, es kommt oft an. Also wenn es eine amtliche Publikation ist, oder eine Aussage von Politiker, da finde ich dann nicht, dass man sich zurückhalten muss. Aber wenn jemand irgendeinen Gedankengang äußert, um dich zum Denken anzuregen oder zum Kommentieren anzuregen und der einzige Kommentar, der dir einfällt, ist hier ist aber die Kommersetzung falsch, tut mir leid, da habe ich also wenig Respekt für.
Tja.
Wir wollen aber nicht die Lektoren hier an der Stelle handpinkeln. Wir haben noch Niggemeiern als Speziales. Niggemeiern ist eine Unterart von Nitpicken.
Ich darf schon sagen, das ist echt was Eigenes.
Niggemeiern ist was Eigenes.
Wie geht Niggemeiern?
Niggemeier ist auch so ein Typ, der konsequent sich irgendwelche Publikationen raussucht von Leuten und dann versucht, die in Gänze als lächerlich zu erklären, indem er so zwei, drei Sachen raussucht, die falsch recherchiert waren. Das falsche Geburtsdatum von einem Politiker genannt. Ja, und der hält sich für einen Journalist. Also diese Art von normales Nitpicking ist ja normalerweise nicht irgendwie mit kommerziellen Hintergrund. Ja, aber Niggemeier betreibt das auf einer geradezu, ich will nicht sagen kommerziell, aber das ist ja quasi... Professionell. Genau, es ist eigentlich dieses Niggemeier und sein Bildblock sind eigentlich die Professionalisierung dieses Ansatzes, gesamte Äußerungen und Gedankengänge in Gänze wegzuwischen, indem man drei, vier Sachen findet, die man angreifen kann.
Hat die Bildzeitung ja tatsächlich mal verdient, dass da jemand hinsetzt und dann mal ihre Artikel durch Niggemeier hat?
Natürlich, aber es bringt einfach keine Erkenntnis.
Doch, ich finde, dass es schon Erkenntnis bringt. Also insbesondere beim Bildblock finde ich schon, dass es Erkenntnis bringt und zwar deswegen, weil da die Methodik klar wird, wie die arbeiten. Also wie die halt mit Fakten umgehen, wie die versuchen aus Bits und Pieces, Stories zu shapen, die halt ihren Vorstellungen ansprechen. Das finde ich schon durchaus verdienstvoll.
Kann wirklich irgendjemand behaupten, es nicht gewusst zu haben?
Ja, natürlich. Die, die das gelesen haben.
Aber die lesen ja auch nicht das Bildblock, oder?
Das ist genau das Problem, was ich nämlich sehe. Weil das Bildblock ist, ich lese das nicht, weil mir das viel zu müßig ist, mir jedes Mal anzuschauen, wo die Bild falsch recherchiert hat. Zu sagen so, ach herrje, guck mal da, da haben sie, äh, der Frau irgendwie falsch unterstellt.
Also ich mach's gelegentlich bei großen Stories. Also Stories, die halt über das normale Limit hinauskommen, die halt in einer sekundären Rezeption so wesentlich werden, dass man sie wahrnehmen muss. Da find ich das doch noch gerade sehr hilfreich, wenn dann das Bildblock dahingeht und die auseinander nitpickt.
Also ich finde Nitpicking auch in Ordnung, wenn es um die zentrale Prämisse des Artikels geht. Oder um eine zentrale Prämisse. Dann ist das legitim. Also das Bildblock war auch das erste Jahr oder so, war das schon nit und hab ich auch gerne mal gelesen. Aber das ist einfach nichts anderes. Es gibt da nichts Konstruktives, sondern es ist immer nur der Artikel war auch scheiße und der kann auch nicht recherchieren. Und es gibt so eine ganze Subart von Bloggern und auch Journalisten, die einfach das zu ihrer Arbeitsmethode gemacht haben.
Das ist halt dieses sogenannte Media-Watch-Blog, also das war so diese...
Ja, ja, genau.
Ich finde das auch nicht schlecht, dass sie das machen. Mein Problem ist irgendwie, so ein Artikel wie die Bildzeitung schreibt, selbst wenn der faktenbasiert ist und alles richtig recherchiert ist, ist das immer noch ein absoluter Angriff auf die kollektive Intelligenz der Leser, die da irgendwie mit so einem völlig danebenen Artikel, ob der jetzt noch auf Fakten basiert oder nicht, finde ich da eigentlich sekundär bei der Arbeitsweise der Bildzeitung. Das ist ja noch dazu nicht auf Fakten basiert, ist dann noch obendrein schlimm. Aber so diese hetzerische Schreibe, da finde ich teilweise echt, finde ich da so rhetorische Analysen sehr viel zielführender, um mal zu zeigen, so wie wird hier manipuliert. Nicht zu sagen, ja der ist gar nicht 30 Jahre da und da gewesen, sondern nur 27.
Wobei ich glaube, diese hetzerische Schreibe eben auch bei Niggemeier beobachten zu können, zunehmend. Ja, dass er einfach nicht nur das Ziel hat zu sagen, hör mal, hier hätte man besser recherchieren können, sondern es geht dann auch tatsächlich darum, den anderen bloßzustellen. Der hat aber versagt als Journalist. Ich will jetzt das nicht an Niggemeier festmachen, denn er ist nur ein prominentes Beispiel. Es gibt auch noch ganz andere Leute, die über die Hürden...
Also falls man sich fragt, warum wir zu lange auf Niggemeier rumreiten, das liegt einfach nur daran, wir haben ja eigentlich versucht, in die Sendung einzuladen und der drückt sich. Deswegen müssen wir jetzt ein bisschen auf die Hürbe reiten. Genau, vielleicht kommt ja noch was.
Das ist ja auch mal so eine Trollproblematik, oder?
Ja, also wir hätten auch mit ihm über Trolle geredet, so ist das nicht.
Eigentlich wollten wir mit ihm über Medien reden, aber wenn er nicht will, dann müssen wir halt ein bisschen hübsch hübschen.
Vielleicht kommt er ja jetzt.
Also er macht was, oder?
Wahrscheinlich wird er ein Artikel publizieren, was wir alles falsch recherchiert haben.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ja, dann gibt es die Berndts Lilos, das ist deine.
Doch, klar.
Wir haben extra einen Soziologen eingeladen. Psychologe.
Ich kann dieses Berndts Phänomen gar nicht so gut beschreiben tatsächlich. Also das sind sehr schmerzbefreite Netzbewohner, die sich daran erfreuen, egal was und egal wen, zu verspotten und ins Lächerliche zu ziehen, oder? Und ich finde das...
Mit einer durchaus großen Neigung zur Tollerei.
Ja.
Aber gewöhnlich bleiben sie unter sich, ne? Also es werden gerne mal Storys verbreitet von einem Bernd, der dann irgendwo anders getrollt hat und dann seine Trophäen vorführt. Aber es ist nicht so, dass die Bernds irgendwie en masse irgendein Forum stürmen.
Wir sollten aber nochmal kurz erklären, wo die eigentlich herkommen, ne? Also...
Okay, das kann ich glaube ich erklären.
Ja, genau.
Der Ursprung war doch in diesem 4Chen Imageboard, wo die, was heißt das, eine PHP Software ist, die seit ihren ersten Tagen, an dem sie geschrieben wurde, glaube ich nicht mehr nennenswert, weiterentwickelt wurde. Und in dem sich dann so lange Kommentarthreads entwickelt haben, in dem man jeweils Bilder auch mitgepostet hat. Und daher auch das Wort Imageboard. Das wiederum seinen Ursprung eigentlich hatte in diesen japanischen Imageboards. Aber das geht zu weit, weil da gab es noch keine Bernds. Und in den USA war die Voreinstellung für einen Namen, den man dort schrieb, anonymous. Das heißt, wenn man keinen angab, dann da anonymous.
Oder anon.
Genau, anon. Und da wurde dann häufig über das Tagesgeschehen reflektiert in Bildern.
Internetmemenbildern.
Moment, das alleinstellende Merkmal bei diesen Imageboards ist, dass die Threads expiren. Wenn irgendwie in den Tag keiner postet, ist der Thread weg mit allen geposteten Bildern. Was eben einerseits dazu führt, dass die sehr pointiert geführt werden, weil man einfach das Gefühl hat, wenn die Polizei jetzt hier kommen wollte, ist der Thread eh schon weg, wenn die dann hier sind. So, da können wir jetzt also... Außerdem steht da nicht mal ein Name dran, sondern alle heißen anonymous. Auf der anderen Seite heißt es eben auch, dass wir die ganzen schönen Sachen aus Fortschein eben nicht als Archiv haben.
Also ausserhalb man hat sie mal wegarchiviert.
Die Meme mussten von irgendwelchen anderen Leuten irgendwie raus extrahiert werden. Aber es heißt eben auch, dass es so einen gewissen Zusammenhalt gibt, nicht mit Shared Kompromat, wie üblich in solchen Foren, und auch nicht so, dass die Leute sich kennen, weil die halt alle auch gegenseitig nur Anon oder Bernd sind. Bernd ist also die deutsche Version. Die deutsche Version von Fortschein hat es eingeführt, da heißt es halt nicht Anon, sondern Bernd. Und es heißt eben auch, dass es dann Zusammenhalt gibt zwischen Leuten, die sich eigentlich gar nicht kennen. Diese ganze Anonymous-Bewegung ist im Wesentlichen eine ins analoge reale Leben überführte Version von Fortschein.
Also, die Bernds hängen da rum in ihrem Krautschan und diskutieren da ja auch irgendwie das Tagesgeschehen. Das ist immer, finde ich, in einem, also in einem richtig, teilweise, also, teilweise, in einem absolut verletzenden, in einer verletzenden Helme. Aber die schütten sie eigentlich über alle gleichmäßig und gerecht aus.
Und das ist... Insbesondere gegenseitig übereinander.
Gegenseitig übereinander. Natürlich haben die so ungefähr jede Form von verachtenswertem Ismus dort drin. Ja, also natürlich sind die Ausländer feindlich, natürlich sind die Frauen feindlich, dass du die ganze Zeit irgendwelche... das wirklich harte Kost, wenn du dir irgendwie krautschern durchliest.
Wenn der Staatsanwalt das sieht, kriegt er einen Anäurismus.
Da kriegst du echt Probleme. Aber ich finde das trotzdem sehr befreiend, weil man sieht, dass diese Menschen sich da eben austauschen und am Ende geht doch nichts kaputt. Also ich bin ja radikal und schmerzfrei bei dieser Meinungsfreiheitsfrage und finde das zwar, wie gesagt, teilweise bin ich da echt erstaunt, wie weit die es treiben und was für Bilder die da irgendwie haben. Da fragt man sich auch, wo die die her haben.
Gelegentlich gibt es schon mal so Ausnahmen, die dann ins reale Leben rüber spielen. Vor ein paar Jahren gab es irgendwie so ein Ding, da ist nach irgendeinem Schulamoklauf so ein gefotoshopptes Bild aufgetaucht, was dann angeblich von Krautschein kam.
Dass der Amoklauf da angekündigt wurde. Das ist halt derbe Humor. Das feiern die heute noch als ihren größten Erfolg.
Das war mit dem Geplikt grillen.
Das stimmt richtig.
Bernd geht morgen geplikt grillen. Ich sag's euch so. Das war halt ein Tag nach dem Amoklauf in winnenden geposteter Screenshot von einem angeblichen Thread, den es da gegeben hätte.
Den es aber nicht mehr gab, weil die alle rausgingen.
Das ist halt auch nicht mehr beweisen, dass es den nicht gab.
Und das feiern die heute noch als ihren größten Scoop. Das ist halt wirklich schmerzfreier Humor. Da läuft einer Amok und du machst da irgendwie einen Witz draus und freust dich, dass du irgendwie dein Imageboard in die Medien bringst.
Man könnte sagen, so ein bisschen diskordianische Züge haben die, ne?
Ja.
Schon sehr.
Interessant daran finde ich ja eigentlich auch, wie lange sich das so zu top hält. Also normalerweise sind ja solche Strukturen eher so ein bisschen labile, aber da ist es ja so, dass die doch recht, ja, langzeitstabil sind.
Ich würde auch durchaus mit Personalfluktuationen, aber das merkt man halt nicht, so wie man sie vorhin ansieht, weil die Witze dieselben bleiben. Die definieren sich halt tatsächlich komplett über ihre Taten und nicht über ihre Personen, was diese soziale Dynamik ändert gegenüber normalen Webforen, wo halt jeder seinen Namen hat und unter dem Post steht.
Stimmt. Du pflegst da ja nicht wirklich eine Identität, beziehungsweise alle pflegen eine. Es ist schon ganz interessant. Du hast da wenig zu verlieren. Du kannst ja auch mal Mist machen und wirst im Zweifel jetzt nicht das Problem herauf beschwören. Ich weiß, dass bei Krautschan einige Provider komplett...
Da wäre ich jetzt vorsichtig mit dir aufzuhören.
Nee, aber Krautschan ist wirklich, sage ich mal so, die Feuerprobe für deinen Glauben an die Meinungsfreiheit.
Das stimmt. Wenn du so einen Tag lang Krautschan lesen danach, dann weißt du, ob du wirklich für Meinungsfreiheit bist oder nicht.
Worum man sich dann echt Sorgen macht, also dadurch, dass diese Threats ja auch expiren, kannst du ja nicht nachlesen. Das heißt, die Leute müssen regelmäßig da dranhängen, damit sie auch nichts verpassen. Weil könnte ja was Witziges passieren im Krautschan. Und du hast quasi so einen Wettlauf gegen die Zeit, dass du einen Threat verlierst, den nicht mitbekommst. Und die Leute, die da dann sehr lange vorhängen, die mache ich mir dann schon auch ein bisschen Sorgen.
Also es gibt ja schon so eine Archivfunktion, aber halt nicht von der Zeit, sondern die Leute gehen dann ad hoc, machen Screenshot und tun den bei Imager hoch. Und die tauchen dann auch gelegentlich irgendwo anders auf. Also das ist schon so, da entwickelt sich so eine völlig, ich will nicht sagen neu, aber da entwickelt sich so eine eigene soziale Dynamik, die nicht unspannend ist.
Ich finde, die bringen teilweise großartige Sachen hervor, also wirklich sehr witzige Dinge, teilweise auch nicht. Großartig ist enorm unter der Gürtellinie.
Eigentlich alles.
Aber die legen auf jeden Fall in jede Wurde, die sie irgendwo sehen, einen salzigen Finger.
Kommen wir zurück zu den Netzbewohnern. Die treiben sich auch gerne in irgendwelchen Webforum rum. Man erkennt sie aber nicht.
Außer sie benutzen Pseudonyme, die so ein bisschen deutlicher sind. Genau.
Und wenn sich irgendjemand bei deinem Webforum als Bernd anmeldet oder als Bernadett, Bernd Lauerth ist er.
Bernd Lauerth, genau.
Dann weißt du, Krautchen ist beteiligt. Die nächste Kategorie sind Profitrolle.
Große Überschneidung zu den Bernds an einigen Stellen.
Das sind Leute, die nicht am Inhalt interessiert sind, sondern da geht es darum...
Lass mal noch mal Experten sprechen.
Alles, was ich über Trolle weiß, habe ich von dir gelernt.
Da geht es darum, ein möglichst harmloses Posting zu machen, was aber möglichst viele Leute provoziert, ein Follow-Up zu machen. Die großartigsten Trolle aller Zeiten sind völlig unbekannt, weil nach einem Tag von Shitstorm kann ja keiner mehr weiß, was eigentlich der Auslöser war. Alle sind der Meinung, der andere hat angefangen, aber eigentlich hat irgendein blöder Trolle einfach eine Frage gestellt, die alle gegeneinander aufgebracht hat. Und das ist durchaus eine Kunstform und eine Wissenschaft. Wenn man es schafft, man muss also messerscharf das Thema finden, wo alle glauben, es gibt Konsens, aber es gibt eigentlich keinen Konsens. Und da stellst du dann eine Frage, die so aussieht, als habe sie mit was anderem zu tun. Die muss natürlich komplett harmlos aussehen, aber die muss sich im Kern auf diesen Aspekt beziehen. Und das bringt dann die Leute gegeneinander auf. Und die Metrik an der Stelle ist, ob ein Webforum geschlossen werden musste, weil es einfach nur noch aus sich gegenseitig bekriegenden Fraktionen Bestand am Ende nachdem ein Troll aufgeschlagen ist.
Also ich glaube eigentlich wird sie als Troll provozieren und den Beteiligten möglichst ihren eigenen Widerspruch vor Augen führen, ohne dass du das als Vorwurf machst. Du willst eigentlich nur sie dahin führen, gib ihnen genug Seil, dass sie irgendwann an einen Punkt kommen, dass sie sich selbst in Frage stellen müssen, dass sie den Knick in ihrem eigenen Denken merken, den eigenen Widerspruch und dann werden sie halt aggressiv. Du möchtest die Leute entlarven. Du möchtest unschuldige blöde Fragen stellen, die die Leute dazu führt, dass sie sich selber entlarven. Dieser Spruch, gib ihnen genug Seil, dass...
Damit sie sich erhängen können, ja. Also die Königsklasse des Trolls braucht keine Follow-ups. Anfänger-Trolle bringen sich dann selbst, die erkennt man daran, dass sie sich selbst immer weiter in die Diskussion einbringen und irgendwie nachhaken müssen. Aber die Königsklasse des Trolls macht einen Nebensatz in einem Forum und danach muss das Forum geschlossen werden.
Also genau, das ist, glaube ich, echt das, man trollt gut, wenn man danach nichts mehr sagen muss, nichts mehr erklären muss, gar nichts mehr. Man lehnt sich zurück und schaut sich das Spektakel an. Kann man auf Twitter auch sehr gut machen.
Stimmt, Twitter ist hervorragend.
Twitter ist eigentlich hervorragend. Aber man kann sagen, grundsätzlich beim Trollen, wer den Follow-Up macht, den unnötigen Follow-Up hat verloren. Und das ist eine Sache, die eigentlich in allen Debatten gilt, finde ich. In Talkshows ist ja immer alles andersrum die Dynamik, dass jeder versucht, das letzte Wort zu haben. Bei Trollen ist es genau andersrum, dass du sagst, wer versucht, das letzte Wort zu haben, weil er meint, er muss nochmal was sagen, hat verloren.
Und das siehst du dann immer in so Kommentaren, wo dann die Leute sich da gegenseitig irgendwie anbrüllen, ja, in Großbestand oder so. Und zwischendurch dann irgendwie eine Don't feed the Troll, Don't feed the Troll.
Genau, ach, das ist immer so der, können wir es nicht alle lieb haben? So, ja, genau. Aber das gilt eigentlich generell bei Debatten, finde ich. Das kann man verallgemeinern, wenn in einer Debatte jemand immer noch mal was drauf sagen muss, weil er sonst das Gefühl hat, er hat nicht recht, dann hat er verloren. Also generell in der Diskussion.
Ich denke, dass die hier rausfallen, wir kommen da vielleicht gleich noch mal zu, also diese Ambiguitätstoleranz, die die Menschen irgendwie nicht aufbauen, ja zu sagen, so okay, da draußen sind Leute, es gibt diesen ganz, ganz, ganz großartigen XKCD, kommst du bitte ins Bett.
Somebody on the Internet is wrong.
Somebody is wrong on the Internet.
Ja, wie also der Mann offensichtlich in diesem Bild noch nachts schwitzen am Computer sitzt und jemand in die Tasten hackt, weil jemand im Internet etwas gesagt hat, was nicht stimmt. Ja, und das ist echt, das ist eine große Herausforderung für viele Netzbewohner.
Ja, nicht nur für Netzbewohner, das ist auch in, wenn irgendwie jemand eine Rede hält oder Fragen nimmt, ja, finde ich. Wenn dein Argument nicht so selbststehend ist, dass es hält, selbst wenn nach dir noch jemand was sagt, was es in Frage zu stellen versucht, dann war dein Argument scheiße und es wird nicht dadurch besser, dass du nochmal was sagst.
Das stimmt, aber es gibt ja schon bestimmte Kommunikationstechniken, auch ein gutes Argument möglichst kaputt zu machen. Und das beobachtet man ja sehr viel. Das ist, glaube ich, auch tatsächlich als jemand, der dann irgendwie solchen Angriffen ausgesetzt ist, eben auch selber mal zu sehen, okay, Füße stillhalten, ich kann es nicht mehr besser machen. Wenn man jetzt, also wie du gerade sagtest, man schreibt was Schönes dahinten, dann kriegt man einen...
Es gibt noch die Möglichkeit der Offensive, also insbesondere so, die wir im Newsnet gestehlt wurden, haben dann da meistens dann auch nicht so viel Lust, uns trollen zu lassen und in der Regel ist es halt so, dass die meisten Leute nicht so gut sind, dass sie dann die Finger stillhalten können.
Das Problem ist, wenn du dich in so was reinziehen lässt, wirst du in eine von denen bereits zitieren.
Du lässt dich nicht ins Argument reinziehen, sondern du drehst halt das um.
Was dann passiert ist, dass du am Ende, wie der Regelphätischist oder der Rechtschreibnazi aussiehst, wenn du anfängst an dem anderen irgendwelche Scheiße, wenn dein Argument, natürlich, aber das ist halt die Falle, in die die Leute reinlaufen. Ich würde sagen, der Kern ist der Unterschied zwischen überreden und überzeugen. Wenn dein Argument gut ist, überzeugt es die Leute unabhängig davon, ob danach noch jemand irgendwas sagt oder nicht. Wenn dein Argument nicht gut ist, dann musst du sie überreden, indem du einfach mehr redest als die anderen. Und das ist das, was Trolle ausnutzen.
Trolle erregen Rechtfertigungstrang. Und dem musst du widerstehen.
Genau. Eine der kleinsten Kategorien, die es gibt in Webforen, sind die Leute, die eigentlich interessiert was tun wollten.
Meint, wir hatten noch Beispiele hier bei den Trollen. Hatten wir. Die hatten noch den übereifrigen Gehorsam bei Regeln.
Ach ja, das war eine ganz schöne Geschichte. Die habe ich gestern im Flugzeug gehört. Die fand ich ganz interessant. Und zwar erzählte ein Polizist von seiner Zeit, als er noch ein Streifenpolizist war, da gab es wohl einen fürchterlichen Unfall, wo ein Polizist beim Rückwärts ausparken ein Kind hat zu schwerem Schaden kommen lassen. Und dann gab es eine Dienstanweisung vom Polizeidirektion oder vom Direktor, der sagte ab sofort im ganzen Bundesland, wenn irgendwo in ein Polizeiauto der Rückwärtsgang eingelegt wird, dann hat da hinten einer der Kollege zu stehen und einzuweisen, weil die ja sowieso nie allein in Auto gelassen werden. Und dieser Polizist hat sich dann gemeldet und hat dann einen Brief geschrieben an seinen Dienstherrn, hat gesagt, das finde er also ganz besonders gut, dass man sich jetzt endlich darum kümmert, das war immer ein großes Risiko. Und er möchte vorschlagen, dass man doch jetzt vor allem sich erstmal auf eine einheitliche Zeichensprache einigt, weil, wenn jetzt, wenn die Kollegen die wechseln, ja, und wenn dann der eine irgendwie sagt, nach rechts winken ist, Heck nach rechts, und der andere meint nach rechts winken ist, Lenkrad nach rechts oder nach links oder so, und wenn es dann da Missverständnisse entstehen, dann können ja Probleme entstehen, ja. Und dann hat er also einen Projektplan aufgesetzt, dass man jetzt am besten erstmal dann da die einen mit ein paar Psychologen zusammen sich auf die Handzeichen einigt, dann entsprechende Schulungen macht und hat dann da so einen sechsmonatigen Rollout definiert.
Wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt, gründe ein Arbeitskreis.
Genau. Und dann wurde er halt da hin bestellt und wurde gefragt, ob er den Chef jetzt hier verarschen möchte. Und dann hat er gesagt, es ist natürlich sein voller Ernst, ist er wieder gegangen, und eine Woche später war diese Diensteinweisung vom Tisch und wurde nicht mehr... Erzählte er ganz stolz. Ich fand die Geschichte sehr schön, ob sie jetzt weiß oder nicht, sei dahingestellt. Aber ich fand die Technik war da natürlich sehr schön erklärt. Ja, überhole den Gegner rechts.
Das ist halt quasi Überaffirmation.
Das kann leider komplett nach hinten losgehend.
Jetzt kann tatsächlich, also in Bürokratie muss man da echt auffassen. Da muss man auffassen. Also wenn die Bürokratie hinreichend ausgewachsen ist, dann kann das auch wirklich tatsächlich dann passieren.
Was ich halt immer wichtig finde, ist, versuche, also auch mal als Toll-Anleitung, versuche den Gegner mit seinen eigenen Regeln zu schlagen. Ja, also nicht irgendwie deine eigenen aufschwimmen. Da kommen wir zu anderen Problemen, die wir gleich behandeln. Aber versuche den Gegner mit seinen eigenen Regeln zu schlagen, seinen eigenen Widerspruch zu finden, seine eigenen Regeln zu überaffirmieren. Und da kommst du schon relativ weit mit.
Gut, dann hatten wir noch die ehrlich interessierten Leute. Die gibt es tatsächlich auch.
Das ist so eine Legende, die sich von Generation zu Generation fortsetzt. Angeblich gibt es im Internet auch ehrlich interessierte Mithelfer, die sich von dem ganzen Scheiß dann abgestoßen fühlen und abhauen. Das ist eigentlich die einzige Sache, die man von denen sieht. In Webforen, Leute, die sagen, hey.
Ja gut, in Webforen, das ist richtig. Aber zum Beispiel bei Kommentaren zu Artikeln ist es häufiger so, dass ich den Kommentare per Mail bekomme oder per Brief bekomme, die tatsächlich hilfreich sind.
Das gibt's ja. Also ich bin auch im Großen und Ganzen zufrieden mit dem Niveau an Einschriften, die ich kriege. Da sind natürlich auch nicht so tolle dabei. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, ja, ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass irgendwelche inhaltlichen Kommentare nicht unter den Tisch fallen, weil es bei mir kein Webforum gibt, wo man die lassen kann.
Nee, den Eindruck habe ich auch nicht. Also ich habe tatsächlich auch eher den Eindruck, dass die Leute dazu zu bringen, eine Mail zu schreiben, ist eigentlich besser. So weil das dazu führt, dass sie drüber nachdenken, weil sie im Zweifel sich noch mühsam eine andere Identität anlegen müssen, wenn sie das irgendwie pseudonym-anonym machen wollen. Und typischerweise reicht diese geringe Hürde halt auch schon aus, da ein bisschen mehr reinzubringen.
Aber spannenderweise, ich glaube, da haben wir später auch noch was zu, ist es so, dass es vorkommt, dass wenn man dann in den Foren korrigiert wird, also jetzt mal nehmen wir an, du hast ein Forum, und da postet jemand an der und der Stelle, das stimmt aber nicht ganz, und dann korrigiert man das, dass das dann als Schwäche ausgelegt wird. Du hast aber verloren, weil du dich hast korrigieren lassen.
Was eigentlich völliger Unsinn ist.
Was genau das Gegenteil der Wahrheit ist. Du willst ja deine Meinung ändern können. Das ist ja die Idee von Kommentaren. Dafür hat man sie doch, damit man darauf hingewiesen werden kann, wenn man was falsch gemacht hat. Das ist ja die zentrale Aufgabe davon, überhaupt Debatten zu führen.
Also zumindest war es ursprünglich mal die zentrale Aufgabe.
Ich merke, dass dieser konstruktive Kommentar, den bekomme ich jetzt in letzter Zeit sehr häufig, weil es geht bei mir einher mit dem Wechsel von irgendwie viel Schreiben zu viel Reden. Also von Bloggen zu Podcasten. Weil beim Podcasten kriegst du irgendwie viel, viel mehr konstruktives Feedback. Ich glaube das nicht daran, dass du... Also dieses Schreiben, das wird ja dann so mit der eigenen inneren Stimme vorgelesen. Zum Beispiel passiert mir sehr häufig, dass ich so einen ironischen Kommentar mache und die Leute da, also schriftlich, und die Leute da völlig drauf abgehen. Völlig irgendwie ausflippen, als hätte ich jetzt auf das Grab ihrer Mutter gepisst. Also das einem richtig übel nehmen. Und wenn man dann sagt, ja Kollege, ich kann jetzt hier nicht jedes Mal irgendwie Smilies machen, dann ne, nein, nein, bababababa. Aber wenn man so im Podcast, ja, da merke ich jetzt echt, meine Meinung hat sich ja nicht geändert. Ich vertrete ja nach wie vor, laber ich den gleichen Mist, ja. Aber die Leute sind freundlicher in ihren Kommentaren und die Quote konstruktiver Kommentare bei Podcasts empfinde ich als sehr, sehr viel höher, sehr, sehr viel höher. Bei netzpolitik.org habe ich die Kommentare nicht mehr gelesen.
Weil du halt den Subtext der Stimme dabei hast.
Genau, du hast diese Stimme, den Subkontext dabei. Wie ernst hat er das jetzt gemeint? Wie böse hat er das gemeint?
Ich glaube, das hat auch was mit der Länge des Podcasts zu tun. Wenn du genug von deiner Zeit committest, um dir so einen stundenlangen Podcast anzuhören, dann bist du auch von deiner Einstellung psychologisch soweit, dass du sagst, im Grunde bist du interessiert daran, was sie zu sagen haben. Und bei Kommentaren ist so der Running Gag, dass die meisten Leute den Artikel gar nicht gelesen haben, sondern sich über die Überschrift aufregen.
In der Tat. Maximal noch den Teaser.
Und daher ist das auch eine Kunstform, eine Überschrift so zu machen, dass sie ein schöner Troll ist. Das ist ja die Kernkompetenz der Überschriftenmacher bei Zeitungen. Ich hab hier nachher noch so einen Spruch gefunden, wenn die Überschrift als Frage formuliert ist, ist die Antwort grundsätzlich nein. Weil das ist einfach einer von den Tricks, wenn die fragen. Haben wir die Fähigkeit verloren, zu reflektieren, blabla? Irgendwie sowas. Oder können wir überhaupt noch davon ausgehen, dass, was auch immer, die Überschriften sind ja schon absichtlich auch so formuliert, dass sie Interesse anziehen. Und das ist bei den Guten. Naja, das ist kommuniziell imperativ bei Zeitungen.
Ja, aber gibt es auch...
Es gibt natürlich Leute, die es können und Leute, die es nicht können.
Na klar.
Aber grundsätzlich ja, generell. Das gibt einfach viele Leute. Es gab jetzt auch gerade so einen schönen April-Shirt von NPR, den wir hier noch verlinken. Die haben gesagt Überschrift Lesen Amerikaner noch. Und dann, wenn man da drauf geklickt hat, kam irgendwie so was. Ja, wir haben ja mal ein Experiment. Liken sie das doch auf Facebook, aber ohne das zu lesen, bitte. Ohne den Inhalt von unserem Artikel zu lesen. Und dann waren alle auf Facebook irgendwie eine endlose Latte an Leuten, die sich über die Überschrift aufgeregt haben. Ja, und haben also bestätigt, dass die Amerikaner nicht mehr lesen, weil sie einfach sich über die Überschrift aufgeregt haben, ohne den Inhalt zu rezipieren. Und das ist ein Problem, das hast du bei Podcast einfach weniger. Ich glaube, dass du die Leute loswirst und dass dadurch die, nicht dass du mehr konstruktive Sachen kriegst, aber du siehst sie halt, weil sie nicht mehr aus dem Ozean von Bullshit rausziehen müssen.
Stimmt aber nicht ganz. Also wenn du zum Beispiel an unsere Alternativlos-Folge mit Döpfner denkst, da haben sich die Leute einfach schon aufgeregt, bevor sie dich überhaupt nur gehört haben.
Ich glaube auch viele Leute haben es auch gar nicht gehört.
Also der schöne Effekt bei diesem NPR-Experiment war ja, der Titel war Why Doesn't America Read Anymore? Und dann standen auf Facebook dann irgendwie, ich lese jeden Tag, ich habe 100 Bücher irgendwo hingespendet. Warum macht NPR diese unzulässige Übergeneralisierung? Und also genau, sich über die Überschrift schon aufgeregt, das war dann ein unglaublich langer Thread. Und das war super, haben sie auch noch am ersten Appell gemacht. Großartig, großartig, irgendwie einen riesigen Facebook-Thread da ausgelöst. Das ist echt, das ist sehr gut.
Das ist ein brillanter Troll. Auch die Überschrift schon. Nicht nur ist es so, sondern warum ist es so? Das heißt, es ist schon impliziert, dass es so ist. So macht man Trolling.
Ja, das war sehr gut.
Hut ab NPR. Handwerklich sauber.
Die Leute, die ja darauf reinfallen, ist ja häufiger unsere letzte Kategorie, nämlich die Empörten. Also die sind ja doch immer also quasi das perfekte Trollfutter. Und da wir insbesondere auf Twitter und auf Facebook ja doch eine Menge davon haben, wollen wir uns diese Kategorie mal ein bisschen genauer angucken. Wie wird man eigentlich zum Empörer oder Empörten?
Was ist denn eigentlich ein Empörter?
Also ich finde, man muss ja grundsätzlich erstmal sagen, es gibt ja genug in dieser Welt, über das man empört sein kann. Ja, also ist ja jetzt nicht so, als wäre es......
als gäbe es einen Mangel....
als gäbe es einen Mangel an Dingen. Also wir haben ein unendliches Universum der Missstände. Aber wir haben nur begrenzte Empörungsressourcen. Ja, und das heißt, wir müssen uns irgendwie jeder so ein Problem aussuchen oder gar nicht. Ja, das sind diejenigen, die haben natürlich jede Chance vertanzt, ein Empörer zu werden, wenn sie sagen, ok, ich sehe das jetzt alles in Ordnung hier so, ich kann meine Familie ernähren und so, ich hab, es gibt hier kein Problem, welches mich großartig stört, ich bin ein heterosexueller weißer Mann, was soll ich mir mehr binden?
Die empören sich dann aber über Schiedsrichterentscheidungen im Fußball.
Ok, genau, wunderbar, die suchen sich aber das.
Naja, also ich war jetzt ein wichtiger Punkt, ne?
Aber das will ich jetzt echt mal, das will ich jetzt echt mal, ich würde jetzt mal den, wir bleiben mal beim legitimen Empören. Es gibt Homophobie, Sexismus, Rassismus, Kapitalismus, Atomkraft, es gibt in der Netzpolitik genug, über das man sich aufregen kann.
Das ist ja auch das Kernproblem von meinem Blog, muss ich sagen. Wenn ich anfange, mich über alles aufzuregen, was mich ärgert potentiell, dann komme ich dazu nichts anderem mehr.
Du musst dir dann jeden Tag oder auch für dein Leben irgendwie ein Problem aussuchen. Und jetzt haben diese Probleme untereinander auch noch Abhängigkeiten, also Kapitalismus und Umweltschutz, Kapitalismus und Benachteiligung der Frau. Es gibt biologische Umstände, die dann im Kapitalismus zu Nachteilen führen, denen Frauen in ihrer Job-Situation ausgesetzt sind. Und du musst dir irgendwo da drinnen einen Überblick verschaffen, was du jetzt als das Problem ansiehst, dass du behandeln möchtest. Oder was dich am meisten ärgert. Und dann sagst du, und dieses Problem, nehmen wir Umweltschutz, mangelnden Umweltschutz als Problem. Dieses Problem musst du dann bekämpfen. Und jetzt hast du zwei Möglichkeiten. Du kannst entweder sagen, du bearbeitest dieses eine Problem gezielt und pragmatisch. Du sagst, du konzentrierst dich nur darauf. Beispiel Netzneutralität. Es gab jetzt hier diese Europa- Abstimmung. Ich habe gesehen, Fefe, du hast die ein bisschen verpasst und erst mal nur die Hälfte geblockt.
Aber hinterher hat er geblockt, dass das Europaparlament für Netzpolitik gestimmt hat.
Ja, das ist ja alles gut, ja.
Reindeutig. Und es gab diese Abstimmung, sondern gibt es eine Lobby-Vereinigung, EDIRI, European Digital Rights, die haben sich hingesetzt und die haben pragmatisch darauf hingearbeitet, dass diese Entscheidung so stattfand. Das machen also pragmatisches Abarbeiten dieses Problems, ist also das, was so Lobbyisten und Aktivisten teilweise machen. Das Problem ist, dass sie während ihrer Arbeit an diesem Problem dann früher oder später gezwungen sind, unzulässige Abwägungen zu machen. Also sie müssen ihr Problem, was sie jetzt bearbeiten, teilweise gegen ein anderes, nicht dem entsprechendes oder nicht damit zu vergleichendes Problem abwägen.
In welcher Weise abwägen? Was irgendwie Energieeinsatz angeht oder Trade-offs machen?
Nee, das ist jetzt wichtiger.
Teilweise Energieeinsatz, aber in der Politik, in so Koalitionspolitik müssen vor allem Fraktionen dann zum Beispiel Netzpolitik, diese Kurhandel machen.
Na gut, aber diese Kurhandel haben ja eigentlich weniger mit den Empörten zu tun.
Ja, warte, ich komme zu den Empörten, komme ich ja gleich nochmal.
Also Kurhandel ist eigentlich Politik, also im klassischen Sinne.
Ja, aber das ist doch bei Empörten ein Problem. Dann kommt jemand und sagt, wie kannst du dich um die Rechte der Frau kümmern, wenn in Afrika kleine Kinder verhungern?
Genau.
Also sozusagen gegen eine Aufrechnung von Problemen.
Genau. Sie bleiben in dieser Welt, in diesem Umstand gefangen, dass es zu viele Probleme gibt und dass sie eigentlich die Grundursache nicht lösen. Also zum Beispiel...
Moment, oder ihr Problem zur Grundursache deklarieren, weil das ist ja sozusagen genau der eigentliche Schritt.
Das ist Option zwei. Ich würde es mal ganz kurz sagen, Beispiel Greenpeace. Greenpeace setzen, gehen hin und machen, im Prinzip nisten sie sich vollständig in diesem System Kapitalismus ein, um darin für den Umweltschutz zu kämpfen. Der Kapitalismus selber kennt aber keinen Umweltschutz. Du wirst dem Kapitalismus auch keinen Umweltschutz mehr beibringen können. Also es geht darum, Ressourcen auszuschöpfen. Das heißt, das Grundproblem, kann man argumentieren, ist nämlich der Kapitalismus, denn der macht die Umwelt kaputt. Und solange wir den Kapitalismus annehmen, werden wir dieses Umweltschutzproblem haben und wird Greenpeace das Problem haben, Fördergelder zu haben. Das heißt, die haben sich so ein ganz eigenes Ökosystem gebaut, indem sie als Organisation dann im Leben. Und deswegen müssen sich dann auch teilweise von einigen diesen Vorwurf des Zynismus gefallen lassen. Und die Alternative ist eben genau das, was du meinst. Du suchst dir das Grundproblem.
Nein, du suchst dir ein Grundproblem.
Nehme ich das. Das ist das Grundproblem in deiner Einschätzung danach.
Es gibt aber weiterhin eine unendliche Auswahl von Grundproblemen. Also ich meine, wenn du jetzt so die typischen Probleme nimmst, ob es der Kapitalismus ist oder Antisemitismus oder Benachteiligung der Frau oder der Umweltschutz ist oder der Kapitalismus an sich, so kannst du jedes dieser Dinge zum Grundproblem deklarieren und den Rest der Pyramide von daraus aufdröseln. Das ist völlig unproblematisch.
Also machen sie mal eine typische Handbewegung, wie ihre dann solange das und das nicht geklärt ist, das müssen wir uns mit Blabla gar nicht beschäftigen.
Genau, richtig.
Und das ist genau die andere Alternative, wie du damit umgehen kannst mit diesem Universum der Probleme, dass du versuchst, dir irgendwie einen Kausalzusammenhang zu identifizieren, zu interpretieren, zurechtzulegen und zu sagen, daran krankt die Welt, dieses ist das Problem, was wir lösen müssen. Und dann bist du ein Hammer, der überall nur noch Nägel zieht. Dann siehst du in jedem Satz den Sexismus, den Antisemitismus, den Kapitalismus, das Grundproblem, das es zu lösen gilt. Und siehst dich dann dem Problem ausgesetzt, dass die Leute dir nicht mehr Zynismus vorwerfen, weil du dich nur auf ein Problem konzentrierst, sondern sie werfen dir jetzt Sektiratum vor.
Oder Fundamentalismus.
Genau, und der Fundamentalismus.
Na ja, Fundamentalismus ist es ja. Das ist ja kein Vorwurf.
Das ist ja quasi die Definition von Fundamentalismus. Hängt jetzt natürlich von der Ausprägung, also zum einen der Auswahl des Grundproblems, zum anderen der Radikalität der Umsetzung des Angehens ab.
Und quasi Schritt zwei, du hast jetzt überlegt, was so dein Problem identifiziert und sagst, das ist jetzt hier.
Das bekämpfen wir jetzt.
Wobei ich ja da gerne noch mal einhaken will, weil die Frage ist ja nämlich, wie suchen sich denn Leute dieses Grundproblem? Und meine Erfahrung ist, dass bei vielen Leuten es so eine Phase im Leben gibt, wo sie auf der Suche nach ihrem Grundproblem sind. Und dann...
So die letzten Jahre in der Schule, die ersten Jahre in der Uni?
Ja, also wenn sie irgendwie ein soziales Gewissen haben und politisch aktiv sind oder irgendeine Art von, ja, sozusagen Herz haben, was irgendwie noch bewegt werden kann, dann suchen sie sich halt ein Problem. So und es kann halt irgendwie sein, dass die Schiedsrichter korrupt sind. Oder es kann halt irgendeiner der Ismen sein, die halt sie bewegen. Und häufiger genug ist es dann so, wenn sie dann Opfer von sowas werden, also wenn sie halt tatsächlich irgendwie Opfer von Sexismus werden zum Beispiel, dann ist vollkommen klar, dann haben sie ihr Grundproblem identifiziert. Ein Parallele dazu ist interessanterweise, in genau derselben Zeit, wenn die Leute so ein bisschen auf der Suche sind, wo sie jetzt ihre Energie reinstecken und wo sie versuchen, sinnerfülltes Handeln zu generieren, wo sie auch das Gefühl von Selbstwirksamkeit haben, also dass sie da was bewegen können, dass sie genau in dieser Zeit Leute, die zum Beispiel eher religiös angehaucht sind, also die halt eher denken, okay, möglicherweise ist unser Grundproblem, dass wir irgendwie das Christentum vergessen haben, werden dann tatsächlich von so christlichen Sekten eingefangen. Und die sind echt gut darin, Leute zu identifizieren, die genau auf dieser Suche sind. Und lustigerweise so die richtig guten Werber, zum Beispiel von so Tierschutzvereinen oder von irgendwie Amnesty International oder ähnlichen, die sind genauso gut darin, solche Leute zu erkennen. Und die kriegen dann halt eben nicht nur ein Abo oder ein Spendendings aufgedrückt auf der Straße, sondern die werden dann halt eben auf die Frage, was kann ich denn noch mehr tun? Also wenn die Leute fragen, was kann ich denn noch mehr tun, außer halt irgendwie nur Geld dazugeben für den Zweck, dann wird ihnen dabei geholfen, ihr Grundproblem zu finden.
Wie flexibel ist man denn mit dem Grundproblem? Also nehmen wir mal an, irgendeine junge Frau wird Tierschützerin und danach begegnet ihr das Problem des Sexismus. Schwingt die dann um, weil das sie persönlich betrifft?
Ja, je persönlicher es dich betrifft, desto schneller schwingst du um, glaube ich.
Ist das wirklich so oder sind die eigentlich eher unflexibel?
Also meine Erfahrung ist tatsächlich eher, dass gerade halt Sachen, die dich persönlich betriffen, wie Sexismus, führen dazu, dass du dein Grundproblem änderst.
Das ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung, ne? Also in der Psychologie sagt man, wenn man dann bei sowas, was sich ändert, sagt man dann häufig so einen 7-Jahres-Rhythmus. Und das ist auch echt ganz interessant, dass man das vielleicht auch bei sich selber beobachtet, dass man irgendwie so ein Thema, so irgendwie sich vielleicht so sieben Jahre dafür begeistern kann, dann vielleicht was anderes kommt. Also ich habe auch genau so die Erfahrung gemacht, dass mich bestimmte Missstände in dieser Welt dann irgendwie selber betroffen haben oder aus anderen Gründen betroffen gemacht haben. Und dass ich dann natürlich einen sehr großen Eifer drin entwickelt habe, mich für die einzusetzen. Und das ist auch überhaupt nicht schlecht, ja? Also das ist wichtig.
Niemand um die Probleme kümmert, ändert sich auch nichts, ne?
Genau.
Aber sagen wir mal, du hast jetzt dann, du hast ein Problem identifiziert und du fängst an, es zu bekämpfen. Wen greifst du denn als Gegner?
Genau. Das ist nämlich der Punkt. Was machst du jetzt mit deinem Problem? Du kannst jetzt, wir sind jetzt beim Kapitalismus als Grundproblem, um jetzt diesen Baum mal so durchzugehen. Wir sind beim Kapitalismus als Grundproblem. Jetzt müssen wir uns irgendwie den Gegner aussuchen, an dem wir uns jetzt abarbeiten und hoffentlich eine Änderung herbeiführen. Und da kannst du natürlich sagen, okay, du stürzt dich auf den Endgegner. Also Regierung, Konzern, Welt. Und da muss die Änderung passieren. Das ist klar. Ich meine, wenn es ein Wurzelproblem ist, was uns alle betrifft, was die gesamte Welt betrifft oder den gesamten zeitgenössischen Raum, in dem du dich da irgendwie gerade befindest, dann muss sich das auch global ändern. Also das Problem, was du dann hast, ist natürlich, dass deine Erfolgsaussicht erst mal als Einzelperson relativ gering ist und du eine große Gruppe brauchst, dann aber wieder mit diesen ganzen anderen Problemen konkurrierst, für die Menschen zu begeistern sind. Also, wie du gerade schon gesagt hast, du bist dann eventuell dazu geneigt, aus einer guten Motivation heraus im Prinzip Drückerbanden an den Alexanderplatz zu stellen, die die Leute irgendwie dazu überreden, 20 Euro monatlich für den Tierschutz auszugeben. Aber du hast ja eine gute Motivation. Du bedienst dich nur eines relativ fragwürdigen Mittels. Aber das rechtfertigt das ja wieder, weil du hast ja eine gute Motivation.
Also was ich glaube beobachten zu können, ist, dass Leute sich, wenn sie sich ein großes Ziel aussuchen, damit dann ein paar Jahre kämpfen, nichts erreichen und dann anfangen, sich leichte Ziele zu suchen. Was ich also gerade bei so auf dem Kongress glaubte, ich das beobachten zu können, dass Leute sagen, okay, ich will jetzt gegen, weiß ich, Sexismus vorgehen und dann greife ich aber nicht die Gesellschaft an, weil das so ein amorphes Ding ist, wo ich keinen Griffpunkt habe und ich greife auch nicht irgendwie die FDP-Politikern, die da in der Presse waren zu der Zeit, sondern ich greife die an, wo ich hingehen kann, wo ich weiß, die lassen mich rein. Da gehe ich hin und dann greife ich Leute an, von denen ich überhaupt nicht weiß, ob das überhaupt mein Ziel ist oder nicht, aber die kann ich immerhin anfassen. Und auch Leute, die, also ich will sagen, wenn so jemand bei der FDP aufschlägt, dann kommt halt die Security und schmeißt den raus. Aber wenn du beim Kongress ankommst, dann wirst du halt reingenommen, die Leute reden mit dir und das heißt aber, dass die Leute, die am Ende bearbeitet werden von diesen Leuten mit großen Zielen, sind eigentlich Leute, die zumindest anteilig eh auf ihrer Seite schon standen.
Das ist aber schon immer so gewesen.
Aber kommt das daher, dass die vorher ein großes Ziel hatten? Ist das überhaupt ein Zusammenhang oder konstruiere ich das jetzt gerade?
Ich denke, dass das schon so ein Trickle-down ist. So ein Suchen eines Zieles, was irgendwie Erfolgsaufsicht verspricht. Was unter anderem auch ein Mechanism ist, warum zum Beispiel in den Kirchen halt immer die Heretiker angegriffen wohnen, wo der Abstand zu dem, was man selber tut, möglichst minimal ist. Also ob die sich jetzt mit zwei Fingern oder mit drei Fingern bekreuzigen oder halt vorhin keine Fenster haben wollen, keine vorhin keine Fenster haben wollen und so weiter und so fort. Die aber eigentlich alle an den selben Gott glauben, die selbe Bibel lesen, den selben und so weiter und so fort. Die Leute, zu denen der Abstand möglichst klein ist, also wo sozusagen nur minimale Unterschiede sind, die werden am heftigsten bekämpft, weil die sind einem am ähnlichsten. Man kann sie eigentlich am besten verstehen und man hat das Gefühl, da kann man noch was bewegen. Und genauso ist es tatsächlich, denke ich mal, auch mit den, meine gerade in sozialen Bewegungen ist es ja schon immer so, dass die sozialen Bewegungen haben sich oder auch emanzipatorische Bewegungen haben sich immer dadurch selbst zerlegt, dass sie gesagt haben, okay, wir können halt den großen Kapitalismus nicht besiegen. Deswegen beschließen wir jetzt mal, wir müssen halt was an unserer Kommunikation tun, an unseren Worten tun, an der Art und Weise, wie wir zusammenleben und so weiter und so fort. Also dieses sozusagen dieses Runterkochen auf möglichst erst mal das kleine Problem, was irgendwie lösbar scheint, aber im Kern viel härter ist, als den Kapitalismus anzugehen.
Spannenderweise geht ja bei sowas dann auch, die üblicherweise so die Grundrechte der Bekämpften verloren, was ja argumentativ okay ist, wenn man sagt, ich kämpfe für die gute Sache und die da drüben sind die Bösen. Aber wenn man sich auf dem Weg so weit verlaufen hat, dass der Gegner, den man tatsächlich angreift, eben nicht der böse, irgendwie privilegierte, was weiß ich ist, sondern ein Typ, der eigentlich fast genauso ist wie ich. Ja, das führt dann dazu, dass man im Grunde die Rechte von den eigenen Mitstreitern am Ende verletzt. Und so gehen diese Pressure-Groups eigentlich häufig ein, ist mein Eindruck.
Genau, das ist der Effekt, der am Ende häufig eintritt. Vorher würde ich aber echt nur sagen, ich meine, es ist nicht nur psychologisch zu erklären, warum man sagt, man fängt im Kleinen an. Das ist ja auch als Strategie eine sinnvolle Erwägung, zu sagen, okay, wenn wir die ganze Welt verändern wollen, dann müssen wir erstmal unser Zusammenleben verändern, indem sich all diese schlechte dieser Welt manifestiert. Und dann sagen wir halt als Gruppe, okay, wenn wir sagen, wir sind gegen Kapitalismus hier, dann kaufen wir jetzt nicht mehr bei Walmart ein. Und jeder, der bei Walmart einkauft, das ist dann schon mal jemand, der hat die FAQs nicht gelesen. Und deswegen reden wir mit dem nicht.
Naja, aber das ist doch genau falsch.
Oder wir versuchen an, wir fangen an.
Du willst doch die Leute, die dir nahe stehen, nicht als Gegner nehmen, sondern als potenzielle Mitkämpfer. Die musst du positiv zugehen.
Das versuchen die ja auch.
Ja, aber das passiert ja gerade nicht. Also ist jedenfalls mein Eindruck. Ich erlebe so gut wie nie, dass irgendjemand versucht, mich mit inhaltlichen Argumenten zu überzeugen. Sondern es ist immer nur irgendwie, du hast hier was falsch gemacht, du hast da was falsch gemacht. Aus solchen Pressure Groups.
Nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel dieses Beispiel, als es diesen Schriftsteller-Aufruf gegen die NSA gab. Das war so das klassische Beispiel von, wie schaffen es emanzipatorische Bewegungen, Bündnisarbeit komplett zu verkacken. Es gab diesen Schriftsteller-Aufruf, der war halt ein bisschen naiv, der war halt so formuliert, dass sie noch Ami-Schriftsteller unterschreiben können oder britische Schriftsteller. Da hat die NSA nicht beim Namen genannt.
Ein Komiteeentwurf.
Ja, hatten Komiteeentwurf. So, aber halt war das was, wo eine Menge Leute, die halt viel, sagen wir mal, Anerkennung haben und die viel Aufmerksamkeitskapital haben, unterschrieben haben, was dazu führt, dass eine Menge Leute es gelesen und wahrgenommen haben. Und aus der Netz-Community kam so Mitpicking bis zum Ende.
Niggemeiern.
Genau so, weil irgendwie, er ist nicht genannt, irgendwie nicht zum Verschlüsseln aufgefordert, irgendwie sich bittend an die Regierung gewandt und was man sonst noch alles für Fehler machen konnte. So, anstatt zu sagen, okay, die sind auf unserer Seite super. Wir haben gerade mal die Chance, irgendwie mit den Leuten, die irgendwie von den denkenden Menschen auf diesem Planeten, nämlich diejenigen, die noch lesen, wahrgenommen werden, tatsächlich mal einen gemeinsamen Push zu machen und lassen es mal gerade mal ignorieren, dass die irgendwie Dinge noch nicht vielleicht so durchdrungen haben, nicht so radikal sind wie wir, was auch immer. Sonst stattdessen gab es halt so ein Blll, so. Und das ist halt so dieses klassische Nicht-Verstehen, dass man in solchen Momenten eben wieder zum großen Ziel zurückkehren muss, also tatsächlich das große Ziel wieder ins Auge fassen muss und sich mit so einem kleinen Gewusel halt irgendwie dann mal in dem Umlieg zurückhalten muss.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Zielkonflikt zwischen ich will Leute zu meiner Bewegung bringen und ich will meine Bewegung abgrenzen gegenüber Leuten, die auf der Gegenseite sind. Ich glaube, das ist so ein instinktives Problem, wenn du in so einer Gruppe drin bist, dass du zur Selbstdefinierung, zur Selbstklärung für dein eigenes Bild von dir selbst brauchst, dass du ein klares Verständnis hast, wer eigentlich in deiner Gruppe mitmacht und wer nicht.
Da kommt genau die poststrukturalistische Erklärung zum Tragen.
Okay, jetzt brauche ich noch ein Bier. Wie das fängt mit Poststrukturalismus.
Muss, muss, muss. Also das, warum, wie du gerade gesagt hast, diese Gruppeneffekte, warum die Leute nicht miteinander reden können. Wollen wir jetzt Pause machen und ein Bier holen?
Ich finde, wir machen kurz noch Pause und holen ein Bier.
Okay, machen wir. Wir haben darüber gesprochen, wie die Menschen zu ihren Überzeugungen kommen und wie es kommt, dass sie dann nicht mehr miteinander reden.
Genau und dass die Welt ja doch gewissermaßen sinnentleert ist. Und dann sagtest du Poststrukturalismus.
Genau, die Welt ist radikalsinnentleert. Der Mensch sucht immer nach irgendwas, was ihm irgendwie eine Identität stiften kann, irgendein Glauben, irgendeine Form. Also auf irgendwas bricht es bei den Menschen immer runter. Religion hast du genannt. Das haben wir dann irgendwann überholt, dieses Konzept. Da kam dann die Aufklärung und dann wurde so nach und nach immer mehr alles zerpflückt an, was die Leute geglaubt haben. Also die Magie wurde abgeschafft, die Religion wurde abgeschafft und es wurde irgendwie gezeigt, okay, das hier alles funktioniert nach naturwissenschaftlichen Prinzipien und so. Und für das, was euch sinnstiftet, ist hier einfach kein Platz mehr mit dem, was wir jetzt rausgefunden haben, beziehungsweise es ist letztendlich arbitrier.
Beziehungsweise wissen wir auch gar nicht, ob es echt ist oder nicht.
Wir wissen nicht, ob es echt ist. Es kann auch alles nur eine Matrix sein. Es gibt kein Gott, es gibt keine Wahrheit. Ja, dann fingen die Philosophen an und haben festgestellt, dass wir irgendwie nicht objektiv wahrnehmen und dass wir sowieso erstmal ein erkenntnistheoretisches Problem haben, die Wahrheit überhaupt zu erkennen. Ja, also gibt es immer wieder erkenntnistheoretisch verschiedene Konzepte zu sagen, was ist jetzt Wahrheit? Ja, Wahrheit ist, wenn mehrere sagen, das war so, dann ist das im Zweifelsfall passiert. Dann hat man irgendwann gemerkt, dass das auch jetzt nicht unbedingt die reine Lehre ist. Und letztendlich hat man dann gesagt, wir müssen eigentlich immer alles in Frage stellen. Und wenn man das zu Ende denkt, dann müssen wir irgendwann auch in Frage stellen, wie wir überhaupt denken. Also wie kommen unsere Gedanken zustande? Und wie bauen wir uns überhaupt unsere Realität auf? Die ganze psychologische Schiene da drin. Und dann kam irgendwann die Frage nach, wie bilden wir überhaupt Realität ab? Nämlich in Sprache.
Also wie kommunizieren wir über Realität?
Genau, oder wie kommunizieren wir über Realität? Wie verarbeiten wir Realität in unserem Kopf? Also ich hab da die ganze Zeit so eine Stimme drin. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch ist.
Bei mir sind es mehrere.
Du hast nur eine?
Also bei mir sind es meistens mehrere.
Aber nur eine heißt Realität?
Nein. Also ich und ich und ich haben damit kein Problem.
Okay, aber ihr habt alle eine Sprache. Und in dieser Sprache...
Du hast nur eine Sprache?
Ich hab noch kein Konsens gefunden.
Also in unserer Sprache, in der wir denken, sprechen und kommunizieren, die baut sich auf aus Begriffen. Und jeder Begriff beinhaltet immer auch einen Ausschluss. Also du kannst keinen Begriff finden, der alles umfasst. Also bei Objekten ist das trivial. Also Tisch schließt schon mal Stuhl aus.
Universum.
Universum? Ja, aber das muss ja irgendwo nur verstanden werden.
Wobei man das Konzept des Trolligs noch mal beispielt und sein Maul hatte, scheiße.
Dann finde ein zweites Wort, mit dem du einen Satz bilden kannst. Bei einzelnen physikalischen Objekten ist das dann noch trivial. Aber bei Konzepten wird das Problem dann klar, dass nämlich jeder Begriff eben auch bedeutet, dass es ein Gegenteil zu ihm gibt. Das heißt, in unserer gesamten Sprache, in den Wörtern, die wir benutzen, spiegeln sich immer unsere Ausschlüsse wieder. Also die Fortgeschrittenen üben Kritik an den Begriff der Bürgerrechte, weil die Bürgerrechte gelten nicht für Nichtbürger. Ist ja schon mal ein Ausschluss, ist ja ein Bürgerismus. Und nein, tatsächlich Arbeitnehmer, Steuerzahler, Mann, Mensch, Demokratie, Rechtsstaat, das schließt immer auch sein Gegenteil aus. Und wenn jetzt mal sagst du, jeder Begriff, mit dem wir überhaupt denken, schließt automatisch immer auch sein Gegenteil aus. Das heißt, deine gesamte Wahrheit wird konstruiert in einem multidimensionalen Raum aus Abgrenzungen. Und das wird ein gesamtgesellschaftliches Konzept. Das, was du Realität nennst, ist ein endimensionaler Raum aus Abgrenzungen.
Und da kommt dann die Idee her, wenn wir die Sprache ändern, können wir die Realität ändern.
Genau, denn in diesen Abgrenzungen verbirgt sich die eigentliche Macht, die eigentliche Bestimmung der Gesellschaft. Das ist nicht, ob da jetzt einer bevorteiligt wird oder nicht. Es geht eigentlich schon darüber, wie in dem, wie du denkst, in den Begriffen manifestiert sich das Bestehende und die Trägheit der Gesellschaft gegen Änderungen und der gesamte Zynismus der Welt. Das ist alles in unserem Denken schon drin. Und das ist ja auch, finde ich, ein herer Ansatz, das dann zu reflektieren und zu sagen, okay, dann möchten wir einzelne Begriffe zum Beispiel angreifen und sagen, diese Begriffe gefallen uns nicht. Zum Beispiel gibt es dann verschiedene Möglichkeiten, also Schwulenbewegungen, die dann irgendwann angefangen haben zu sagen, okay, dieser Begriff Schwul, mit dem wir die ganze Zeit bedacht werden, den eignen wir jetzt uns selber an. Wir entkräften diesen Begriff. Es war ein jahrzehntelanger Prozess, in dem man es geschafft hat, so was hinzukriegen. Das einzelne Individuum, und das ist dieser Punkt, den du gerade beschrieben hast, Frank, wo man sagt, man erkennt dann irgendwo so ein Problem, wo diese gesamte Welt, die wir alle meinen zu teilen, oder von der uns vorgespielt wird, dass wir sie teilen, wo die halt eine Lüge ist, wo die Scheiße ist. Und das ist dann zum Beispiel, du bist eine Frau und du wirst benachteiligt und zwar relativ knallhart. Und da braucht man aus sich nichts vorzumachen. Und das ist ein existierendes Problem. Und du siehst, dass das Problem so fundamental ist, dass es eigentlich eine Lüge in dem gesamten Gesellschaftskonzept ist. Die ist natürlich gilt zu bekämpfen. Chancengleichheit, ja.
Ja, Moment, da stellt sich aber die Frage, das ist ja noch was anderes. Also ich finde, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen die Wörter, Grenzen aus, oder die Wörter sind eigentlich inklusionistisch. Wenn ich sowas habe wie, was weiß ich, Bürgergeld, da sind die Bürger, sind die Frauen ja mit drin. Aber trotzdem wird es nicht umgesetzt. Ich finde es ein Unterschied, ob ich das einfach vom Konzept her schon nicht habe, ob das eine strukturelle Benachteiligung ist, weil ich einfach, was weiß ich, Wahlrecht betrifft nur Männer. Wie jetzt mal historisch gesehen. Oder ob ich das schon in meinem Begriff nicht drin habe, weil es einfach überhaupt nicht in meinem Denkmodell vorkommt, dass irgendwie so und so. Also das ist schon noch ein Unterschied. Und ich möchte auch noch darauf hinweisen, dass das natürlich von beiden Seiten gemacht wird. Also ein häufiges Ding ist sowas zu sagen wie Chancengerechtigkeit ist so ein mal der Lieblingswörter, weil es einfach überhaupt keine Aussage hat. Für Gerechtigkeit heißt einfach bei jedem was anderes. Und die Chancengerecht zu verteilen heißt eben nicht, die gleich zu verteilen. Und es heißt auch nicht, dass wir tatsächlich gleich behandeln, sondern nur, dass wir jedem die gleiche Chance geben. Lotto ist zum Beispiel, jedem die gleiche Chance geben. Das ist nicht nur historisch gegeben, sondern es wird auch absichtlich herbeigeführt, dass ich Begriffe schaffe, die ausgrenzen, um das Denken einzuschränken, um einfach gewisse Optionen überhaupt nicht auf den Tisch zu nehmen.
Plus der Punkt ist, wobei er gerade die ganze Zeit redet, ist ja die Ansicht, dass die Begriffe das Problem sind.
Na, nicht unbedingt, sind Begriffe das Problem? In den Begriffen manifestiert sich das alles so ein bisschen.
Naja, nee, aber ich denke, dass Total Data eben genau nur eine dieser Grundproblem-Ansichten ist. Also es gibt ja eine ganze Menge Leute da draußen, die meinen, dass irgendwie die Sprache, die wir benutzen und wie wir sie benutzen und die Begriffe, die wir haben, dass die quasi ursächlich sind. Und was ich halt für zumindest irgendwie debattierbar halte, weil in der Regel ist es ja eben so dadurch, dass die Menschen ja Begriffe absichtlich setzen. Also wenn wir zum Beispiel mal unser Lieblingsbeispiel halt Initiative Neue Soziale Marktwirtschaft nehmen, die ja sehr gut darin sind, solche Begriffe absichtlich zu setzen, um unser Denken zu formen, dann ist für mich das Problem nicht die Begriffe, sondern das Problem sind die Leute, die sie manipulieren.
Das ist richtig. Ich würde aber diesen gesamten, also worauf ich eigentlich hinaus möchte, ist eher so dieses Identitätsfinden in dieser radikalen, sinnentleerten Welt. Und das musst du irgendwie mit Begriffen schaffen. Und du wirst irgendwann...
Ist das tatsächlich der Ausgangspunkt oder ist das eher so ein Rückdeuten?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, es ist eher ein Phänomen. Du bist in dieser Welt, alles macht keinen Sinn. Du brauchst aber einen, du willst einen haben. Du kommst mit dieser radikalen, sinnentleerten Welt nicht klar. Und am Ende musst du dir da drin, und da kommt nämlich dieser gesellschaftliche Teil dazu, du musst dir da drin Werte definieren. Du kannst sagen, Christentum ist jetzt mein Wert. Es gibt die Bibel, die sagt so, so, so und so. Und das ist jetzt ein Wert, der stiftet mir Identität, der ist für mich irgendwie eine Leitlinie, wo es langgeht.
Sind das wirklich die Begriffe oder ist das eine Gruppe, die ich mir aussuche?
Das sind dann Konzepte, aber die Konzepte sind ja trotzdem nur repräsentiert in Begriffen. Und das heißt, jedes einzelne Konzept geht über Ausgrenzung.
Ja, aber ist es wirklich so, dass sich jemand ein Konzept sucht, oder ist es nicht so, dass sich jemand eine Gruppe sucht, und dann das Konzept kommt nachträglich? Und weiterführend ist es nicht so, dass Leute gar nicht den Begriff finden, sondern dass ich nicht quasi loslaufe und sage, oh, das Konzept ist es. Und deswegen werde ich jetzt die Sprache erinnern und das Konzept irgendwie umzusetzen oder anzugreifen, sondern dass die Leute sagen, ich greife jetzt die Sprache an, weil das ein probates Mittel ist. Also ohne die Sinnentlehrtheit am Anfang, dass Leute einfach sagen, Sprache ist ein probates Mittel, um Änderungen in der Gesellschaft herbeizuführen.
Ich denke, man darf es nicht vermischen, weil zum einen ist es so, dass solche Gruppen immer zu Binnendialekten neigen. Das heißt also, du hast immer in solchen Gruppen als Identitätsstiftendes Mittel Sprache, das heißt Begrifflichkeiten, die draußen nicht verwendet werden und an denen du deinen Gegenüber erkennst. Jemand, der die falsche Sprache verwendet, denkt offenbar falsch. Es sind all diesen Gruppen immer so. Und doch ist so, also auch bei den Christen.
Das gibt es auch. Das gibt es auch einfach als Abgrenzungsmittel. Das muss nicht heißen, die denken falsch, sondern...
Nee, aber wie auch immer der Extremismus der Abgrenzung aussieht. Aber zumindest ist klar, dass Sprache ein Abgrenzungsmittel ist. Und dass in den allermeisten dieser Gruppen, also auch positiv oder negativ, die Erkenntnis, dass die anderen die Sprache falsch benutzen und eben genau das, was du sagst, halt dieses irgendwie Begriff prägen unser Denken und so weiter und so fort, dass die bei vielen dieser Leute Kern ist. Also dass das tatsächlich auch eine Sache ist, die sie absichtlich verwenden. Also gerade auch bei irgendwelchen Sekten zum Beispiel, die haben einen Jargon, den kannst du teilweise nicht mehr verstehen, weil sie sagen, die Begriffe der Welt da draußen sind mit Sünde besetzt zum Beispiel oder ähnliche Dinge. Oder halt eben bei Leuten, die dann halt extremen Generating betreiben, wurde halt einfach nicht mehr in der Lage, bis zu verstehen, wovon sie eigentlich gerade reden.
Na oder die Konzepte sind einfach neu, sagen wir mal Scientology.
Deswegen würde ich halt bestreiten, dass es so zentral ist, weil eigentlich ist es nämlich so, du siehst es überall dieses Phänomen, also dass Sprache halt so ein wesentlicher Teil des Kampfes wird, auf dem sich dann mehr oder minder zentriert wird.
Das kommt ja noch.
Aber eigentlich ist es nichts Besonderes.
Die These ist auch, dass das über den Begriff sogar hinausgeht. Nämlich, dass du eigentlich dann am Ende ein Glaubenssystem hast, was zwar an deine Begriffe oder was jetzt gebunden ist, aber in sicher dieser Ausschluss für jede Definition, für jeden Begriff, für alles Denken trotzdem da bleibt. Und das meine ich, da treten natürlich auch dann so verschiedene Weltanschauungen in Konkurrenz. Weil wenn ich jetzt sage, ich erkläre Christentum zu einem Wert. Christentum hat relativ viele positive Komponenten, hat ein paar negative und man kann sich dann jetzt hinstellen und sagen, okay, dem trete ich aber gegenüber mit einem anderen Konzept. Und dieses Konzept heißt, Marktliberalismus hat auch zum Ziel, dass es allen gut geht. Vorgeblich. Alle haben immer ein gutes Ziel innerhalb ihres Denkonzeptes. Und die Frage ist, wenn jedes einzelne Denken und jedes einzelne Prinzip und jeder einzelne Begriff immer einen Ausschluss beinhaltet, wie willst du dann überhaupt noch rechtfertigen, welches das bessere Konzept von beiden ist, welches dasjenige ist, das dem anderen überlegen ist. Das ist am Ende, wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass wir sowieso in einer sinnentleerten Welt wohnen, gar nicht möglich. Wir müssen es am Ende dann auf Grundwerte runterbrechen und sagen, Marktliberalismus ist besser als Christentum, weil Demokratie und Rechtsstaat sind gut und wünschenswert, weil. Aber es gibt am Ende keine zentrale. Das ist nicht weil, sondern das ist einfach die Grundvoraussetzung, das wird nicht mehr in Frage gestellt. Das kannst du nicht mehr in Frage stellen, das kannst du nicht mehr rechtfertigen, das ist eine rein ästhetische Abwägung.
Naja, der Punkt ist, dass es nicht nur eine rein ästhetische Abwägung, weil typischerweise zeichnen sich ja alle Gruppen, die die Welt verändern wollen, also egal ob religiöse oder politische Gruppen oder immer zur putterischen Bewegung, dadurch aus, dass sie gewisse Dogmen haben. Also sie haben halt alle, Dogmen mögen für viele Leute als zu harte Worte empfunden werden, aber letzten Endes geht es halt darum, dass es Werte sind, die als unverhandelbar, definiert sind.
Richtig, genau.
Und wo man sagt, okay, hier geht es nicht weiter, hier können wir keine Kompromisse machen, hier ist nicht, also gibt es keinen Handlungsspielraum. Und typischerweise zeichnet es sich dann so aus, dass die Leute an der Basis, dass sie weiter unten die Leute sind, also in der Hierarchie einer solchen Gruppe, desto wichtiger sind ihnen diese Werte und die weiter oben die Leute sind, also in der Spitze der Pyramide, wenn sie halt anfangen mit anderen Gruppen interagieren zu müssen, also wenn sie Führungspersonal sind, desto zynischer und relativierender werden die dann. Desto mehr gibt es Handlungsspielräume, weil die haben halt auch ein bisschen mehr von der Welt gesehen manchmal. Die wissen halt, dass man Kompromisse machen muss, um halt irgendwie seine Macht zu erhalten. Und die sind auch in der Lage zu verstehen, dass das, was sie da gerade spielen, also dass dieses Gruppenmanagement auch nur eine von vielen ist. Also gerade wenn man sich jetzt zum Beispiel diese typischerweise, wie gesagt immer gerne wieder so religiöse Amisekten, weil da kann man so schön, da sieht man, also ich will jetzt nicht direkt vergleichen mit immer zyperdorchischen Bewegungen, aber man sieht halt die gleichen Mechanismen sehr schön kristallisiert. Man hat halt genau Führungspersonal, was an irgendeinem Punkt extrem zynisch geworden ist und angefangen hat, sich mit goldenen Wasserhennen und Badewannen zu versorgen und gegen die Schwulen zu wettern und selber schwul zu sein. Das ist ja ein häufiges Phänomen. Jetzt war, wie war das gerade mit dem Westboro Church, der auf dem Totenbett zugegeben hat?
Das war ein Fake.
Das war ein Fake?
Das war ein schöner Fake, okay.
Also immerhin war es so gut, dass ich da rein gesäuert bin.
Es war so gut, dass alle sofort glauben wollten. Ich glaube, ein kurzer Zwischenruf. Wir haben hier gerade, glaube ich, die Naturwissenschaften rausgeworfen. Also stellt euch vor, das Universum ist ein Vektorraum und wir reden hier gerade über die Basis. Nach welcher Basis wir hier die Sachen haben. Und wie in der Mathematik ist es auch in der Soziologie so, dass wir anhand der Basis die anderen Sachen abbilden und bewerten. Das heißt, wenn jemand anderes mit einem Wert kommt, dann bewerten wir den nicht neutral von außen, sondern in unserem Bezugssystem. Und wenn jetzt eine Freikirche kommt und mein Bezugssystem ist Rechtsstaat, dann sind diese Werte einfach möglicherweise gar nicht abbildbar in meiner Basis. Und das ist das Problem, dass die Leute dann aneinander vorbei reden, weil einfach die Worte und das System, was sie aufgebaut haben, auf ihren Grundvektoren aus der Basis, dass die einfach nicht abbildbar sind.
Mit denen kannst du nicht mehr kommunizieren, das geht einfach nicht mehr.
Du kannst schon kommunizieren, aber du kannst ihre Werte nicht abbilden in deinem Wertesystem.
Du kannst es einfach nicht abbilden, was die wirklich da machen. Und das sieht man auch sehr schön, warum wir hier in unserer Demokratie, in unserem Parlament, so ein Gesamtspektrum haben. Das ist so das Gesamtspektrum unserer Gesellschaft, das ist in diesem Parlament. Naja, aber die können alle gut miteinander harmonieren.
Als Approximierung.
Genau, aber keine dieser Parteien fordert eine grundsätzliche Änderung des Bestehenden, bis auf eine. Und man sieht, von die wird von allen gleichermaßen abgelehnt. Also die Linkspartei geht rein und sagt, wir stellen bestimmte fundamentale Vereinbarungen, die dieses Haus hier bestimmen, einfach mal in Frage. Und dann siehst du, dass sich alle hinstellen, von Sozialdemokraten bis zu der FDP und sagen, mit den Schmuddelkindern können wir nicht spielen.
Die sich sonst auf nichts außer Dietenerhöhungen einigen können.
Also da haben wir zumindest mal einen Grundlingenwert.
Genau, das ist ein universeller Wert, ist die Dietenerhöhung.
Ist also Menschenrechte schwierig, so Bürgerrechte ganz problematisch, aber Dietenerhöhung geht immer.
Was ich finde, was wichtig ist festzuhalten, ist so, also wir begründen unsere Werte mit Begriffen, also mit Ausschluss. Letztendlich sind alle Werte abitär. Es ist eine ästhetische Wahl, die da irgendwie stattfindet und es beinhaltet immer einen Ausschluss. In einem Gesellschaftssystem, und das denke ich zeigt auch die Geschichte der Menschheit, gilt so diese Regel, alles kann, nichts muss. Wir haben alle Formen von Gesellschaftssystemen irgendwie schon gesehen?
Nee, haben wir noch nicht.
Hoffentlich nicht?
Nee, also das würde ich mal bestreiten. Also wir haben zum Beispiel noch keinen echten Kommunismus gesehen.
Ach Gott, ich glaube, ich war auch dahin.
Der ärzt auf mich.
Ja, ist richtig, ich hab übertrieben, ich ziehe den Satz zurück. Aber in diesem ganzen Vektorraum, wie Fefe den gerade so viel besser beschrieben hat, als ich es die ganze Zeit versuche, darin suchen wir uns irgendwo unsere Identität. Und teilweise bauen wir uns vielleicht einen ganz anderen Vektorraum auf oder wir sagen, wir möchten den bestehenden Vektorraum. Da suchen wir uns unsere Ecke und an der wollen wir fallen.
Lass uns doch mal darüber reden, was sind da dann die Optionen, die man da hat? Also man kann jetzt sagen wir mal hingehen und sagen, okay, diese Begriffe sind das Problem. Also wir können jetzt zwar den Kapitalismus nicht angehen, aber wir können zumindest dafür sorgen, dass wir, nehmen wir mal an, geschlechtergerechte Sprache haben oder irgendwie nicht rassistische Sprache haben oder was auch immer oder halt nicht mehr Arbeitnehmer sagen, weil es halt einfach auch ein kaputter Begriff ist. So und meine wir machen sowas ja gelegentlich auch so. Wir spielen ja manchmal auch mit solchen Sachen. Also zum Beispiel halt beim Thema Wahlcomputer versus Wahlmaschine, wo wir halt konsequent Wahlcomputer gesagt haben, weil es halt technisch richtig ist und halt eben genau diesen mechanistischen, da kann schon nichts schief gehen, Gedanken herausnimmt. Was mich aber an diesen Leuten immer so erstaunt ist, dass sie glauben, dass darin eigentlich, ja sozusagen das Seelenheil liegt. Also dass man damit eigentlich alles geändert bekommt. Also ich habe glaube ich noch nie so viel Ärger bekommen auf Twitter, wie in dem Moment, wo ich danach gefragt habe, ob es Browserplugin gibt, was mir dieses Generalizing rausrendert aus dem Browser. Weil ich hatte da irgendwie so einen längeren Text von so einer linken Initiative, der wirklich inhaltlich echt spannend war. Ich konnte ihn aber nicht lesen, der war halt irgendwie ultra gegendert und da war einfach irgendwie, also inhaltliche Kommunikation war da halt als Begriffe nicht mehr möglich quasi.
Das hat ja streckenweise Methode, dass die Texte absichtlich unläserdicht werden.
Das soll so sein.
Also dass nicht einheitlich gegendert wird, ist jetzt das neueste. Du möchtest nicht einheitlich gendern, weil dann könnte sich der Mensch ja daran gewöhnen und im Kopf könnte der oder die Leserinnen das rausrendern. Und das Neue ist halt dann immer unterschiedlich zu gendern. Inzwischen sind wir so weit, dass der Grabenkampf nicht mehr darüber geht, ob gegendert wird, sondern geht jetzt darüber, wie gegendert wird.
Das heißt, wie wir vorhin auch schon angesprochen haben, kämpfen sich jetzt zwei im Grunde auf der gleichen Seite stehende Flügel derselben Bewegung darüber, ob da jetzt ein großes I in die Mitte kommt, oder ein Unterstrich oder ein Sternchen.
Mit zwei Fingern oder drei Fingern bekreuzigen oder links oder rechts rum.
Wer möchte die Multi-Python-Analogie bringen?
Ich wollte gerne noch eine andere Sache bringen.
Ich wollte meinen Gedanken zu Ende bringen, aber ich bringe jetzt mal die Multi-Python-Analogie.
Es kämpft die jüdische Volks voll gegen die Volks von Judea.
Aber der Gedanke, den ich zu Ende bringen wollte, war dieses Aufhängen an den Begriffen, also ausgehend von den Begriffe von Unser Denken und so weiter und so fort, ist ja aus meiner Sicht ein Rückzug. Weil man sagt eigentlich, dass in dem Augenblick, okay, ich kann das Grundproblem nicht angehen, was auch immer das Grundproblem ist, was man sich ausgesucht hat, sondern man kämpft sich halt an der permanenten Aufregung über Worte und Begriffe ab, die man irgendwie scheiße findet und vielleicht sogar mit gutem Recht scheiße findet und versucht sich dann halt an barockverschnörkelten Gegenbegrifflichkeiten, die aber, wenn man sich's mal überlegt, wenn man das ernsthaft betreiben will, dann muss man das Spiel so spielen, wie die Initiative Neue Soziale Marktwirtschaft. Das heißt also Black Propaganda, das heißt also Worte so wählen, dass sie sofort eingängig sind, sofort in den Alltag eingehen, sofort benutzt werden. In dem Augenblick spielt man das politische Spiel noch mit. Man kann diese Methode möglicherweise scheiße finden, sei eben unbenommen so. Das ist eine Sache, wo man drüber diskutieren kann, ob es ein legitimes politisches Mittel ist. Aber in dem Augenblick, wo man sich extra Mühe gibt, dass die eigenen Begrifflichkeiten politisch vollständig unwirksam sind, weil niemand diese Texte lesen möchte, in dem Augenblick hat man sich eigentlich komplett ins Abseits gestellt.
Genau, man beschneidet sich da selber in seinen Möglichkeiten. Der Höhepunkt, Fefe hatte das ja auch verblockt, ist dann dieses Studieren.
Stimme erklär, das bitte noch mal.
Moment, ich möchte jetzt mal eine kleine Fundamentalkritik anbringen, die mir gerade an der Stelle auffällt und die, glaube ich, passt, weil wir hier stehen haben als Beispiel, Begriffsumdeutung. Schwul haben wir schon erwähnt. Und Nigga. Nigga ist stark abfällig, kommt von Neger und Neger kommt von einem ausländischen Wort für Schwarz. Ein anderes Wort, was vorher benutzt worden ist, ist Moor. Moor ist auch stark abwertend und kommt auch von Schwarz in einer anderen Sprache. Und heute sagen wir, oder jetzt auch nicht mehr, aber danach kam, man hat gesagt, die Schwarzen. Und das gilt jetzt auch als abwertend und es heißt aber auch dasselbe. Das heißt, wenn wir anfangen, über die Sprache die Gesellschaft ändern zu wollen, gibt es keinen historisch besonders überzeugenden Trackrecord dafür. Es kam auf dem Kongress so ein Vortrag über Sprachänderungen, der ein wesentlicher Pfaden durch den Vortrag war, die Begrifflichkeit für Frauen, wie die sich immer geändert hat. Und dass wir heute Dame sagen, Mädchen ist auch eine im Grunde negative Form und kommt von Markt. Also die Begriffsänderungen, die es so gab, haben nie langfristig verhindern können, dass irgendeine negative Konnotation weggeht, sondern man hat nur das Problem verschoben.
Der These würde ich wahrscheinlich folgen, wenn man sich die Situation der Afroamerikaner in den USA heute anschaut. Schönes Beispiel hier, kürzlich zu mir gefunden, die Initiative Anrede Mann. Also da wird gesagt, man möge doch bitte dann in seinen Briefen schreiben, nicht sehr geehrter Herr so und so, sondern sehr geehrter Mann. Sehr geehrter Mann, Schulz.
Weil Herr aufwertend ist, aber Frau nicht.
Genau, weil Herr aufwertend ist und Frau nicht. Und dann soll man irgendwie eben darunter dann den Stern, die Initiative für sprachliche Geiststellung, verwendet seit 2012 die Anrede Mann entsprechend der Anrede Frau. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ernsthaft, ob damit jemandem gedient ist. Die können das versuchen. Aber du hast schon recht, ich meine an der Situation...
Das wirkt, wie man so ein bisschen verzweifelt, ne? So als wenn wir können das eigentliche Problem nicht angehen.
Genau, vor allen Dingen, wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel Energie da reinfließt. Die Frage letzten Endes, wie man Ungerechtigkeiten angeht und wie man tatsächlich im Alltag real von der Diskriminierung angeht, tritt dahinter immer häufiger zurück. Also, was ich halt sehe, ist, dass die Leute sich da aufrauchen und viel Energie reinstecken, Leute zu bekämpfen und irgendwie anzupöbeln. Gerade in sozialen Medien, die eigentlich im Prinzip ihre Ansicht sind und die eigentlich im Prinzip keinen großartigen Dissens über die Lage und die Situation haben und die eigentlich auch nur nach, sagen wir mal, rein praktikablen und normal möglichen Methoden suchen, die Situation zum Positiven zu verändern und die damit halt einfach vergretzternd vor den Kopf stoßen.
Also ich habe letztens in einer Situation waren wir bemüht, einen Text zu verfassen. Das war auch eine Gruppierung, die sich im Zweifelsfall links empfindet und es ging dann erstmal natürlich um dieses wie wird jetzt gegendert und so weiter. Dann war das schon mal die erste Stunde der Diskussion um und als wir dann endlich irgendwann an so einem Punkt waren, dann wurde mir dann halt tatsächlich, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin Vegetarier, wurde mir dann der Vorwurf des Spezieszismus gemacht.
Was ist denn das?
Spezieszismus, ne? Menschenzentrisch. Wir inkludieren die Tiere nicht. Ja. Das ist dann dieser Versuch, irgendwie zum Universum zu kommen, was du gerade versucht hast, Fefe. Aber ist ja schön so, ich meine, der CCC setzt sich ja seit jeher für die intergalaktische Toleranz ein.
Genau.
Aber das verstehen die Menschen wenigstens noch. Genau, wir hatten ja diesen Text da, der Höhepunkt bisher, als Beispiel dafür, dass man sich eben in seiner eigenen Wirksamkeit beschneidet. Das ist denke ich auch immer das, wo man sich als soziale Bewegung irgendwie dran am Ende bewerten lassen muss oder sich selber bewerten sollte, ist, was ist mein Wirkungsgrad? Was erreiche ich? Wen erreiche ich? Passiert etwas, ja?
Also die Abwägung ist halt immer zwischen, wie heilig ist man? Also wie doll kann man sich in seinem Wertesystem in Richtung Heiliger bewegen? Versus ändert man was in der Welt? Ich tendiere ja im Prinzip immer dazu, mich mit den Leuten zu solidarisieren, die Dinge in der Welt ändern wollen und weniger mit den Leuten die Heiligkeit da anstreben.
Ich glaube, dass die am Anfang alle die Welt ändern wollen, aber wenn es nicht klappt, fangen sie halt an, sich ein Rückzugsgebiet zu schaffen, indem sie sagen, ok, aber wenigstens in meinem Wertespektrum bin ich unangreifbar.
Ich denke auch, dass das schön ist, halt so, du bist halt dann immer noch der Linkste, ne? Also du bist immer noch der Gütigste, der Beste. Weißt du, wenn du den anderen schon Spezieszismus vorwerfen kannst, ja, dann zeigst du halt wirklich, dass du es ernst meinst, ja, und dass du nicht bereit bist, hier in dieser Kompromisse im Kauf zu nehmen.
Faule Kompromisse.
Das erinnert mich immer so ein bisschen so an die Sachen, wie sie heute im Osten gelaufen sind. Da gab es halt auch genau diesen Wettbewerb, wer denn jetzt irgendwie Röther ist.
Und die Rausche-Bart-Brigaden, wer den schönsten Marks-Bart hat.
Naja, es war also völlig absurd, aber das fand ich immer super.
Also aus dem Westen beobachtet, wenn man da die ganzen Widerstandskämpfer sah und alle mit Holzfäller bat. Super.
Aber diese Mechanismen bleiben halt immer dieselben. Also wenn man versucht, da möglichst dem Reinheitsgebot der eigenen Bewegung möglichst weit zu entsprechen, ist es zwar möglicherweise in der sozialen Gruppe einen Vorteil, weil man ja sozusagen sich immer darauf berufen kann, den moralischen High Ground zu haben. Führt dann aber natürlich dazu, dass man sich halt von dem Rest der Menschheit und deren Major Consensus Narrative natürlich irgendwie mit relativ hoher Beschleunigung entfernt.
Ja und dann sammelst du natürlich, also wenn du dann erstmal so weit bist, dann sammelst du halt immer nur mehr Gleichdenkende um dich. Entfernst dich immer mehr, siehst auch immer mehr Böses in der Welt, immer mehr Schlechtes. Alle weisen nicht darauf hin. Ja und dann passiert es halt, wie gesagt, dann kommst du in so Situationen, dass du es für völlig sinnstiftend gut und geboten und irgendwie das ist jetzt genau das Richtige zu tun hältst, so ein Studierendext zu schreiben.
Drin müssen wir jetzt aber nochmal erklären, wo wir jetzt kommen.
Moment, ich möchte einen Einwurf machen.
Nein, wir müssen jetzt aber wirklich langsam mal erklären.
Einen Einwurf möchte ich noch machen. Ich bin mir nämlich nicht sicher, ob wir hier Ursache und Wirkung verwechseln. Denn ich glaube, dass die, vielleicht möchte ich zumindest die These aufstellen, dass eine Auswirkung davon ist, dass man heute eben nicht mehr vernünftig debattiert, sondern es reicht, wenn man jemandem Inkonsistenz nachweisen kann. Heute wird einfach so viel Atom in dem argumentiert, dass es reicht, wenn du, also schreibst mir mal an, du schreibst irgendwie ein 20-seitiges Traktat, was erzählt, wie man den Kapitalismus besiegen kann.
Wenn du dich richtig gegendert hast, verloren.
Ja, nee, nicht nur das, sondern wenn dir jemand nachweisen kann, dass du irgendwann mal, was weiß ich, ich sage mal ein blödes Beispiel, du hast irgendwie Steuern gezahlt, die Leute wissen es, dann kommt irgendein Arschloch und sagt, hör mal, dieser ganze Text ist nicht glaubwürdig, denn du hast beim System mitgemacht. Also auf dem Niveau wird einfach heute argumentiert. Es wird nicht der Inhalt angegriffen, sondern es wird immer versucht, weil es einfacher ist, dem Autor von dem Text Inkonsistenzen nahe zu weisen. Und ich glaube, dass dieser Versuch, wenigstens im eigenen Wertesystem, sich unangreifbar zu machen, auch eine Reaktion darauf ist.
Naja, ich meine, das bringt uns ja zu diesem aktuellen Beispiel mit dem Mozilla-CEO.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal den Text davon von.
Oh nee, lass uns lieber das Beispiel von dem...
Wir machen erst mal den Mozilla-CEO.
Nee, nein, lass uns das Beispiel von den Studierenden nehmen. Das ist alles gleiche Fällung.
Okay, also los, erzähl.
Also, das ist ein kleines Erlebnis, was man da an der HU gefeiert hat. Da waren also größere Gruppe der Erziehungswissenschaften-Studierenden und da gab es dann Leute drunter, die sich beschwert haben, dass im Rahmen dieses Erziehungswissenschaften-Studiums Texte von Immanuel Kant behandelt wurden. Und Immanuel Kant war ein ausländerfeindlicher Mensch, ein Rassist. Neben, dass er irgendwie der sinnstiftende Philosoph der gesamten Aufklärung des Abendlandes war, war er auch ein Rassist.
Wir müssen vielleicht sagen, es geht um eine Vorlesung Erziehungswissenschaften im ersten Semester und die ging nicht um Kant, sondern an einem Termin dieser Vorlesung, die semesterlang irgendwie vor sich hin läuft, ging es am Rande auch um Kant. Also es war jetzt nicht so, dass man gesagt hat, das ist der Kant-Professor, der hier endlos über Kant, sondern es war irgendwie Fußnote 13 auf Seite 25 war Kant sozusagen. Ich will jetzt übertreiben.
Es mag auch sein, dass es eine ganze Vorlesung behandelt wurde. Okay, weiter. Und dann wurde also Kant behandelt und das wurde als fundamental falsch verstanden von einigen Studierenden, die sich dann entschieden haben, sich dagegen zu wehren, dass diese falsche, unreine Lehre ihnen da vermittelt wird, weil sie eben die Ambiguitätstoleranz nicht aufbringen konnten, zu sagen okay, da wird jetzt eine These vertreten und die wird mir präsentiert zur Erweiterung meines Wissens, nicht zur Indoktrination. Das ist glaube ich der Unterschied, den da einige Menschen dann noch nicht so ganz mitbekommen haben. Und dann eskalierte diese Situation, dass also die angefangen haben, diese Vorlesung zu stören. Und es fand dann seinen Höhepunkt. Der Professor, ich meine, so ein Professor macht eine Vorlesung, hat sich da was bei gedacht und reagierte wohl offensichtlich nicht besonders einfühlsam auf diesen Protest, der sich dann langsam formierte in seiner Vorlesung. Und es gipfelte dann mit einem Polizeieinsatz am Ende des Semesters. Und zwischendurch gab es dann noch irgendwie Forendiskussionen im Moodle-Forum. Sie erkennen hier ein Muster, wo dann irgendwelche Aufrufe verfasst wurden. Das war ein Vorfall, der da über das Semester die gesamte Studierendengruppe befasste. Und dann gab es am Ende des Semesters in der Fragestunde, 10. Februar, irgendwie letzte Vorlesung, könnte alle noch mal Frage stellen, bevor ihr nächste Woche die Klausur schreibt. Ja, das ist immer, da kommen dann alle. Und weil man dann natürlich erhofft, Andeutungen zu bekommen, was denn in der Klausur gefragt ist und was nicht. Und dann haben die wohl angefangen, den Professor wegzuklatschen. Jedes Mal, wenn der was gesagt hat, haben die dann halt angefangen zu jubeln und wollten damit zum Ausdruck bringen, dass dieser Mensch ja keine Kritik duldet, deswegen klatschen sie ihn halt weg. Und dann hat ein Student, der sich dann irgendwie ein paar Minuten angeschaut hat, dann die Bullen gerufen und hat gesagt, also, ich, Entschuldigung, ich hab hier Dinge zu tun. Ich hab hier studiengebühren bezahlt, ich möchte hier ein bisschen was haben. Und dann gab es also einen Polizeieinsatz und ein riesiges Theater, riesiges Theater darum. Und dann fingen dann auf dem Verteiler HU an, Studis oder alle Studierenden der HU, gibt es da irgendwie so einen Verteiler, fingen dann da irgendwie so längere Traktate an.
Was ja immer ein Fehler ist, wenn wir das mal kurz einwerfen dürfen, einen Verteiler an alle zu haben, ist immer ein Fehler, das wird immer nach hinten losgehen. Irgendwann postet da einer was hin, vielleicht versehentlich, dann gibt es ein Reply to all, hey, wieso schickst du mir das? Und dann bricht irgendwie der Mailverkehr für eine Woche zusammen, weil die Server platzen. Hast du eine ungefähre Ahnung, wie viele Leute da drauf sind? So 30.000 irgendwie?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, das sind die gesamten Studierenden der HU. Also richtig viele. Ja, ich war ja selber mal HU-Studierender. Wenn du dann nicht mehr Immatrikulist bist, fliegst du irgendwann auch raus aus dem Verteiler. Aber das müssen irgendwas so über 15 auf jeden Fall sein. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele. 15.000. Und an sie ging dann irgendwie...
Längliche Traktate.
Längliche Traktate über die faschistischen Professoren, die irgendwie hier keine anderen Meinungen dulden. Während der Professor einfach nur gesagt hat, bitte lassen sie mich jetzt hier den Inhalt dieser Vorlesung vermitteln und dann gehen sie in ihre Übung oder in ihren Lernkreis oder in ihre vorlesungsbegleitenden Tutorien. Und da können sie dann eine Rassismusdiskussion führen. Aber vielleicht können wir uns kurz über die Punkte einig werden, die dieser Mann gesagt hat, die mit Rassismus überhaupt nichts zu tun haben. Ja, also der hat sich halt Gedanken gemacht, hat halt auch auch rassistische Äußerungen geschrieben. Und die reichten dann eben für diese Personen aus, das Gesamtwerk dieser Person zu disqualifizieren. Ja, das ist ja jetzt modern geworden, das so zu machen. Das lesen wir nicht mehr. Kant ist jetzt out, lange Jahre war er in, aber das kann man jetzt nicht mehr lesen. Und dann meldeten sich eben andere Studierende zu Wort auf diesen Verteiler, denen dann eben offensichtlich auch nicht ganz klar war, wie viele Leute da mitlesen. Das Ganze landete auf Pastebin. Und dann meldete sich der RefRat. Das ist das, was an allen anderen Universitäten Asta heißt. Mit einem Text, der wurde also von der RefRat-Adresse gesendet an diesen HU-Verteiler.
Und der war so toll, dass ich den erst von Satire gehalten hab.
Ja, war mir auch nicht ganz klar. Das Problem ist, man konnte den halt auch schwer lesen.
Aber der war so lang, dass du irgendwann den Andruck hattest, ne, das ist keine Satire, weil Satirika nennt sich nicht so viel. Satirika hat Leute zu erreichen, der macht sich Gedanken darum, wie viel er jetzt davon bringen kann, bevor die Leute weglaufen.
Also dieser Text muss man dazu sagen, ist halt in einer Art und Weise gegendert, die mir vorher so auch noch nicht begegnet war. Ich hab nun schon einiges von so Zeug gelesen. Also der muss ganz weit vorne sein, in der Wissenschaft des korrekten Genderns.
Oder wir sind ganz weit hinten.
Ja, wir sind sowieso ganz weit hinten.
Du ohnehin.
Ey, pass auf.
Also guck mal, check mal deine Privilegien. Jedenfalls, die Art und Weise des Genderns war so, dass wir dachten, das kann eigentlich nicht sein. Also liest doch mal ein Repräsentat dieses Beispiels.
Das Schöne ist, also das sind so Sachen wie, dass sie ein Sternchen hinter wir machen, als Fußnote zu einer länglichen Fußnote, liest die mal vor.
Wir Sternchen haben uns Sternchen für die X-Form entschieden, um alle anzusprechen, ohne Positionierung auszuschließen. Das X steht für die Durchkreuzung gegenderter Personenvorstellung. Das war das X und das wir Sternchen schreiben, unser Sternchen Personal und unsere Sternchen Possessivpronomen mit einem Sternchen, weil wir Sternchen zum Ausdruck bringen möchten, dass wir Sternchen unterschiedliche Menschen mit unterschiedlichen Meinungen sind, als Gruppe jedoch immer konsensuell entscheiden. Und diese Gruppe, und das finde ich so köstlich, die nennt sich Wissen gegen Ignoranz.
Was? Nein, das ist total von mir entgangen.
Den Teil hast du übersehen.
Ja, den habe ich echt übersehen.
Da schließt sich der Kreis zur Initiative Neue Soziale Marktwirtschaft.
Das ist ja echt Double-Speak, oder? Das können wir auch mal kurz erläutern.
Das ist ein richtiger Double-Speak.
Geil, oder?
Wie geil. Aber so geht dieser Text los. Das erste Wort ist irgendwie wir, und dann kommt die längliche Ausführung. Aber einzelne Abschnitte sind anders gegendert. Und ich dachte erst, naja, das haben halt andere Autoren geschrieben. Aber ich muss mich inzwischen aufklären lassen, dass man das heute so tut, damit nicht, wenn es gleichmäßig gegendert ist, man sich daran gewöhnt und nicht mehr darüber stolpert. Denn man soll ja stolpern, um die Denkanstöße loszutreten.
Oder sich einen Skript schrabt.
Ja, das geht nicht.
Das auffällige an diesem Text ist dann...
Kontarevolutionär.
Ja, ja, kontarevolutionär. Ich weiß.
Das auffällige, das hatte ich ja gerade schon in Fußnote 2 vorgelesen, ist, dass das Gendering in diesem Text eben gar nicht mehr gemacht wird, sondern da finden sich dann Sätze wie was wir Sternchen und die... Also wenn immer ich jetzt......mache, das ist XS. Also die XS, studier XS. Was wir Sternchen und die......studier, kritisieren, ist z.B. die Re-Produktion von problematischen Wörtern wie zwei B-Griffe, die mit W und S beginnen, die wir Sternchen aber nicht re-produzieren wollen, da diese kolonial-rassistisch und somit diskriminierend für Schwarze und People of Color und gleichzeitig privilegierend für weiße Menschen sind.
Aber die haben doch Schwarze geschrieben. Das dürfen sie doch gar nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich bin da nicht so ganz drin. Sowohl Kant und Humboldt als auch Rousseau. Alles eigentlich sehr hochgeschätzte Personen bisher. Benutzen diese Worte häufig und auch der Professor benutzte diese in der Vorlesung. Auf den Hinweis des rassistischen Hintergrunds, dieser W-Unterstrichorte, antwortete dieser mit Bagatellisierung und Verneinung des Sachverhalts. So, ich war nicht in dieser Vorlesung. Und es mag ja sogar sein, dass das jetzt ein fürchterlicher Faschist war, der da seit Jahren an der Humboldt-Universität rassistische Lehren vertritt. Ich würde glauben, dass das ist auch das, wofür ich eigentlich plädiere, dass diese Studierenden sich mit der Verfassung dieses Textes jetzt nicht wirklich in Gefallen getan haben. Also, sie haben... Das Problem ist, ich meine, man muss sich halt daran messen lassen, was man bewirkt. Und ich glaube, dass man jetzt sich mit da wirklich so weit außerhalb des Vektoraumes der meisten Menschen befindet.
Also, was man dazu aber noch sagen muss, ist, dass die Art und Weise, die sie da benutzt haben, ist ja von einer universitären Institution.
Ja, es gibt tatsächlich ein Paper, was unter anderem...
Es gibt einen Leitfaden.
Genau, einen Leitfaden.
Genau.
Erstellt von einer Arbeitsgruppe unter anderem an der Humboldt-Uni, wie man seinen Text korrekt gendern soll und worauf man zu achten hat. Und dem hat es tatsächlich genügt. Also, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie... Die Studenten haben da einen Trip gehabt, sondern die haben das korrekt umgesetzt. Was bei Refefe in den Kommentaren zu der Bezeichnung Kevin-Uni für die HU geführt hat, finde ich absolut geil.
Jetzt hat sie zugegeben, dass du die Kommentare liest.
Naja, gelingt nicht.
Manchmal.
Hey, weißt du, wenn du so eine Meldung hast, dann weißt du, was du liest. Da hab ich dann auch mal reingeguckt.
Naja, und was mir jetzt hier so wichtig ist an dieser Sache, ich kann den Sachverhalt nicht bewerten. Wie gesagt, vielleicht war die Situation da wirklich in Farm und vielleicht musste man sich da an der Stelle wirklich ärgern.
Na, es gab zwei Follow-Ups von Studenten, die auch auf Pace-Ping gelandet sind, die das eher gegenteilig dargestellt haben.
Genau, die haben es gegenteilig dargestellt, also kann ich nicht sagen, wer jetzt von beiden Gruppen da jetzt Recht hatte. Das Entscheidende ist, dass diese Studierenden jetzt diesen Text verfassen, die Kritik an dieser Schreibweise halt als Kritik an ihrem Antisexismus wahrnehmen. Das heißt, wir lachen uns über ihr Mittel kaputt, aber natürlich nicht über ihr Ziel.
Gut, also das kommt jetzt darauf an, ich lache mich auch darüber tot, kann es nicht lernen zu wollen, weil...
Na ja, okay, kann es nicht lernen zu wollen, das ist wirklich laufend. Aber dieses mit dem XS, ne? Also sie verfolgen ja eigentlich ein Heeresziel, die Auflösung der Bedeutung des Geschlechtes in unserer Gesellschaft. So, das ist sicherlich gut für Männer, ist es schlecht, wenn das passiert, für Frauen ist es gut, aber für die Gesamtgesellschaft wäre es ein positiver Effekt, je weniger Unterschied das Geschlecht macht, in egal welcher Lebenssituation. Wenn ich jetzt diese Methode einsetze und wenn du einmal so weit bist, dass du dir so eine Sprache angeeignet hast, dann bist du nicht mehr bereit, eine Kritik an deiner Methode anzunehmen, weil du sie sofort als Angriff auf deinen Wert wahrnimmst. Und das ist das, warum ich glaube, dass nirgendwo mehr Diskussionen stattfinden können, nirgendwo mehr man sich gemeinsam zusammensetzt und auf ein Ziel hinarbeitet, weil man sich eben in linken Gruppen inzwischen eben gegenseitig Speziesismus vorwirft und irgendwie Studierenden schreibt.
Genau dasselbe ist übrigens auch am Ende der 68er-Bewegung passiert. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass genau derselbe Mechanismus benutzt wurde, dass also Randkonflikte zum Hauptkonflikt deklariert wurden und dass sozusagen die Kommunikation in den Gruppen, die Art und Weise, wie man spricht, die Art und Weise, wie man zu Konsens kommt und so weiter, dass die als viel wichtiger deklariert wurde, was dann halt dazu führte, dass diese Bewegung in sich kollabiert ist.
In die unterschiedlichen K-Gruppen dann in Westdeutschland.
Genau und diese Gefahr sehe ich jetzt gerade auch wieder, dass also tatsächlich es da keine Art von Konsens gibt, die...
Kein gemeinsames Sinnstiftendelement, was sie zusammen schreiben.
Genau, es gibt keine Möglichkeit mehr, gibt halt eine, also wenn wir da nicht gegen angehen, eine Kommunikation zu finden, die sich halt eben auf die Kernprobleme konzentriert. Oder wo man zumindest sagt, okay wir haben ein begrenztes Ziel, nehmen wir mal Bürgerrecht oder nehmen wir mal Netzpolitik oder nehmen wir mal Datenschutz. Wo wir sagen, okay wir mögen vielleicht unterschiedliche Ansichten über die angemessenen Mittel und Wege haben, wie man solche Probleme angeht. Aber vielleicht können wir uns hier gerade mal darauf einigen, dass wir irgendwie an dieser Stelle mal in einem Schlang ziehen.
Als Randbemerkung soll noch erwähnt, dass es Zersetzungshandbücher gibt von Geheimdiensten, die sich damit beschäftigen, wie man Gruppen zersetzt. Und die machen genau das.
Da war gerade diese grandiose Folie in dieser MFive-Geschichte, die sollten wir verlinken.
Also es ist auch dokumentiert, dass um peinliche Verschwörungstheoretiker loszuwerden, man andere Verschwörungstheoretiker in das Narrativ aufnimmt, die offensichtlich schwachsinnig sind und damit das ganze Feld diskreditiert. Und genau diese Gefahr selbst erzeugt, also das ist jetzt die Annahme, man weiß es nicht, vielleicht sind das ja auch Agitatoren von auswärts, die diese Gruppen zu zerstören versuchen, aber genau dieser Mechanismus, der wird auch aktiv von zerstörerischen Elementen angewendet, um Gruppen kaputt zu machen. Und das tun jetzt einige Gruppen sich selbst schon an. Oder zumindest, ich weiß nicht ob es zwangsläufig ist, aber man kann es eigentlich immer wieder beobachten.
Also nachdem wir es jetzt gelernt haben darüber, wie viel Kohle die Briten investiert haben, um an Mimus zu infiltrieren, würde ich da echt nicht mehr ausschließen, dass sie oder was die Umweltgruppen angeht oder wo die Agenten, die sie halt in die Tierschutzbewegung reingeschickt haben und so weiter, würde ich überhaupt nicht mehr ausschließen, dass das nicht tatsächlich eine absichtlich geträgerte Angelegenheit ist. Also je mehr interne Konflikte man in solchen Gruppen hat, indem man halt solche Randprobleme in den Vordergrund stellt, wie zum Beispiel, wie rum gendern wir jetzt gerade, desto mehr Spaltpotenzial hast du und dann musst du halt nur drauf warten, dass einer dieser Risse dann irgendwann tatsächlich zum Bruch führt.
Einen Punkt, den ich hier noch aufgeschrieben hatte, das ist auch eine Eigenschaft der jeweiligen Gruppierungen. Wie viel Zusammenhalt gibt es innerhalb der Gruppierungen? Und ich glaube beobachten zu können, also als Vergleich habe ich jetzt den CCC, aber das gilt auch für andere Vereine, wenn man als Mitglied eines Vereines wie des CCCs sieht, dass irgendeine Zeitung schreibt, der CCC sagt, irgendwie Antiviren sind sicher oder irgendeine andere völlig hanebüchene, schwachsinnige Äußerung, die mit den CCC-Zielen und Kernaussagen nichts zu tun hat, dann überlegt man sich, wie kann ich das reparieren? Wie kann ich den CCC hier schützen? Und das sehe ich selten. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt an mir liegt oder an den Empörungsgruppierungen, die ich da beobachtet habe. Das sehe ich selten in diesen Gruppierungen, sondern da ist es so eine Art Tiger-Käfig, wo die alle gegeneinander kämpfen. Und wenn da einer was Beklopptes sagt, dann kommen nicht die anderen und springen eben zur Seite, sondern die fallen dann gegenseitig übereinander her. Und da gibt es dann Spaltung. Und diese Energie, die in traditionellen Vereinen, wie dem CCC dafür aufgebracht wird, Konsens zu schaffen, die müssen halt dann diese Pressure Group-Gruppierungen nicht aufwenden, weil sie einfach den Aufwand nicht auf sich nehmen. Und das ist ein handfester Nachteil von traditionellen Gruppierungen, wenn die von solchen Leuten angegriffen werden.
Nein, das hat diese Empörungswellen-Geschichte.
Genau, das ist eine Empörungswellen-Geschichte. Es gibt da auch verschiedene Taktiken, die daraus hervorgehen. Ja, zum Beispiel, dass man einfach so viele in kurzer Abfolge so viele verschiedene Kritikpunkte vorbringt, dass die Gegenseite überhaupt nicht die Zeit hat, die alle der Reihe nach zu entkräftigen. Das ist ein echtes Problem für Leute, die von solchen Vereinigungen angegriffen werden.
Wir können doch jetzt noch mal diesen Mozilla-Beispiel nehmen, weil ich finde das durchaus ein ganz entertaining als aktuellen Fall. Also, wer es noch nicht bekommen hat, der Mozilla CEO, von dem kam raus, dass er für eine Proposition, also einen Gesetzesentwurf in Kalifornien, gespendet hat.
Ja, Moment, da müssen wir ein bisschen zurückgehen. Also, der hat privat nicht als Mozilla CEO gespendet. Vor vielen Jahren, ich glaube acht Jahre, oder wann war das, ist eine Weile her. Und das ist rausgekommen, nicht weil er das öffentlich gemacht hat, sondern weil es einen, gibt es einen Register, was man einsehen kann. Ja, und da steht drin, er hat gespendet und da ist ein Feld, was da drin steht, wo arbeitet denn der? Und da steht dann eben Mozilla Foundation. So, und der Typ ist jetzt vor ein paar Tagen zum CEO gemacht worden. Intern gab es Streit darüber, ob der CEO sein sollte oder nicht, aus diversen Gründen. Auch dieses Ding, aber das war nur eine von mehreren Gründen, warum intern gestritten wurde. Es gibt da einen Gegenkandidaten und so ein Grabenkampf. Jedenfalls ist er trotzdem zum CEO gemacht worden und daraufhin ging so eine Schmutzkampagne los.
Ich muss nur kurz sagen, wo für die Proposition war, oder?
Die Proposition, da ging es darum, die Homo-Ehe nicht als Ehe zu deklarieren in Kalifornien. Ja, das war so eine homophobe Proposition. Die Proposition selber hat in Kalifornien gewonnen, ist dann aber von einem Gericht zerlegt worden. Also das heißt, unterm Strich haben sie nicht durchgekommen.
Sie wollten die Homo-Ehe verbieten?
Also es zeichnete sich ab, dass es in verschiedenen Staaten Legalisierung von Homo-Ehe gibt, und um das zu verhindern, haben so ein paar Neandertaler diese Proposition 8 losgetreten, die reinschreiben sollte im Bundesland Kalifornien, gilt die Ehe nur zwischen Mann und Frau. Also da hat er 1000 Dollar gespendet.
Genau, aber was man dazu sagen muss, er hat halt auch noch für andere Merkwurden gespendet, also der hat halt auch noch für Pat Brooklyn hin gespendet, war es auch so einer von diesen.
Ja, der ist jetzt kein sympathischer Mann.
Genau, also wir können mal zusammenfassen, es ist kein so sympathischer Mann, er hat offensichtlich politische und moralische Ansichten, die eher, sagen wir mal, inkompatibel sind mit dem Bild, was Mozilla als Firma nach außen vermittelt. So und...
Na nicht nur nach außen, auch intern. Man muss sagen, Silicon Valley ist so, ich will nicht sagen, Neo-Hippietum, aber das ist ein sehr inklusionistisches Völkchen da.
Fast symbolisch, symbolisch.
Ja, also die legen großen Wert darauf, dass keiner dabei erwischt wird, irgendjemanden auszugrenzen und wenn es doch jemand tut, gibt es immer einen gewaltigen Shitstorm. Das heißt auch beim Mozilla eine Arbeitsatmosphäre, die sehr inklusionistisch ist, überhaupt nicht homophob, da wird auch niemand irgendwie benachteiligt. Es gibt auch keine Transphobie und die Brandon Eich heißt der, der ist überhaupt erst seit ein paar Tagen CEO gewesen. Da rollte dieser Shitstorm an, er hat überhaupt nicht Gelegenheit gehabt, irgendjemand zu diskriminieren. Vorher war er da so eine Art graue Eminenz, der ist nämlich seit den Netscape-Tagen dabei, dessen Wort hätte schon Gewicht gehabt. Also wenn er irgendwie versucht hätte, irgendwelche Homosexuellen zu unterdrücken, hätte er es tun können, gibt es aber keine dokumentierte Evidenz darüber. Der Punkt ist, es gab jetzt halt einen Twitter Shitstorm dazu, der dazu geführt hat, dass der am Ende zurückgetreten ist.
Dann nicht nur Twitter Shitstorm, es war auch so...
Das ging dann durch die Medien, weil die Medien rekrutieren ja ihre Nachrichten inzwischen von Twitter.
Und halt ein wesentlicher Punkt war, dass OkCupid, nämlich ein großes Datingportal, Firefox-User, eine Nachricht eingeblendet hat, so übrigens der CEO von Mozilla, ist ein homophober Arsch. Wechsel doch mal den Browser.
Sind sogar, glaube ich, die größte Dating-Community, oder?
Zumindest die Wesentliche, die irgendwie alle Leute benutzen.
Das haben irgendwie Millionen von Leuten gesehen.
Mein Punkt dabei ist, ich finde das ja gar nicht mal schlecht, weil letzten Endes, dass solchen Leuten auf die Finger geklopft wird, weil letzten Endes ist es ja so, dass wenn es Veränderungen geben soll, und also soziale Veränderung findet halt nur mal nur durch sozialen Druck statt, und eines der wenigen Mittel, was irgendwie man da hat, also bei politischen Mitteln ist halt tatsächlich, ja, neben sozialem Druck, also Medien und so weiter ist halt Boykott. Und das Argument, dass wenn die Leute da keine Konsequenzen haben, also in ihrem sozialen Umfeld, dann spenden sie halt weiter für irgendwie solchen homophoben Scheiß. Und insofern finde ich, zumindest irgendwie kann man überlegen, ob das nicht ein valides politisches Mittel ist, sozusagen so einen Druck auszuüben, um, gut, ich meine, das mag jetzt vielleicht in dem Einzelfall halt ein armer Opfer sein, dass der Mann das ungerecht finden kann ich mir vorstellen, aber möglicherweise ist der politisch legitim als Mittel der Aktivität zu sagen, okay, wenn man solchen Zwecken halt das Geld abkramen will, dann muss man es halt ungemütlich machen, für sie zu spenden.
Ja, aber diesem Typ ist halt tatsächlich nicht nachgewiesen worden, dass er auch nur einem Fall, der öffentlich dokumentiert ist, irgendjemand tatsächlich desinminiert ist. Er hat dafür gespendet, aber er hat jetzt nicht dem Kuckucksklankohle gegeben, sondern das war...
Ja, Pat Buchanan ist knapp davor.
Pat Buchanan ist ziemlich übel, das hab ich jetzt auch noch nicht gehört, aber diese Proposition 8 ist Teil der demokratischen Meinungsbildung. So läuft das in Amerika.
Also ich weiß nicht, also ich...
Ich finde die auch scheiße und ich finde es nicht gut, dass der CEO geworden ist, aber wenn du wartest bis so jemand CEO ist und ihn dann schaffst wegen seiner Homophobie, dann ist das ein Berufsverbot. Der kann nie wieder irgendwo arbeiten. Und das finde ich zu weit. So wichtig ist die Homophobie nicht, dass man dafür Leute ein Berufsverbot erteilen muss.
Na ja, aber ich glaube, es gibt genügend irgendwie Firmen, Amilad, die Rüstungs- und Industrie, Silicon Valley ist groß genug, dass er bestimmt Arbeit findet, um es mal zynisch zu formulieren.
Glaube ich nicht im Silicon Valley, der musste woanders hingehen, dann irgendwie in New York oder so. Und auch da ist es schwierig. Die ganzen Hightech-Zentren sind alle nicht in republikaner Bundesländern, in Amerika. Also das ist ein so hartes Mittel, dass man das aus meiner Sicht nur bringen kann, wenn der irgendwie eine Vergewaltigung oder so gemacht hat. Oder er ist erwischt worden. Irgendwas hat irgendwie ein Kind ermordet oder weiß ich.
Aber weil er nicht einmal muss, muss er aber mehr als den Kopf lassen.
Der kümmert sich der Staat rum.
Nein, das meine ich. Das ist einfach, wenn du findest, so jemand darf nicht CEO sein, was ich übrigens auch finde, dann verhinderst du das vorher und machst nicht nachher so eine Charakterassistierung. Weil der ist jetzt durch, der Typ, ne?
Ne, bloß, ich meine, nehmen wir mal ein anderes Beispiel. Das Gerücht darüber, dass irgendwie die...
Um das mal in Redaktion zu setzen, wie viel hat der denn gespendet? 1000 Dollar? Was macht der so ein Gehalt? Das hast du hier, glaube ich, mal ausgesucht, oder?
Ja, gut, das war irrelevant. Also es ist völlig irrelevant, wie viel er gespendet hat, weil irgendwie alleine andere Leute bei Mozilla haben mehr gespendet gegen die Proposition Aid. Also finanzielle Probleme ist sozusagen nicht da.
Nein, der hat jetzt auch nicht substanziell gespendet. Der hätte irgendwie 100.000 Spenden gönnen und hat...
Aber der interessante Punkt dabei ist halt, also wenn du soziale Veränderungen erreichen willst, dann musst du bestimmte Handlungen unmöglich machen. Also dann musst du halt einfach dafür sorgen, dass bestimmte Dinge nicht gehen, indem sie sozial einfach geächtet werden. So und in Deutschland gibt es ein verwandtes Beispiel, nämlich das Gerücht darüber, dass Müllermilch...
Das ist ja Edati oder?
Nein, wir lassen uns mal ein anderes Beispiel was diese Spendengeschichte nimmt. Das Gerücht darüber, dass Müllermilch an die NPD spendet, was offensichtlich nicht wahr war, sondern das war so eine Zeitungsende. Das war in den 80ern, in den 1894er war das glaube ich so ein großes Ding. Da ging es darum, dass es einen Boykott gegen Müllermilch gibt bei den Linken, weil Müllermilch an die NPD gespendet hat. Es stellte sich am Ende raus, war eine Zeitungsende, da gab es ein Magazin, der Wiener hieß das glaube ich, die sind rumgegangen und haben versucht, Geld für eine neue rechte Partei einzutreiben, als Fake, um zu gucken, welcher Unternehmer halt irgendwie Geld spendet und der Besitzer von Müllermilch war einer der wenigen, die nicht gleich gesagt hatten, lasst mal lieber, sondern die zum Gespräch eingeladen. Daraus entstand dann so ein Gerücht, Müllermilch wurde halt für die NPD spendet. Der Effekt davon war aber, also das ist der Effekt davon, dass es auch nur dieses Gerücht eines Boykots gab und der Boykott hatte keinerlei nennenswerte Auswirkungen. Der Umsatz von Müllermilch war unbeeinträchtigt, führte aber dazu, dass tatsächlich kein Unternehmen in Deutschland ernsthaft in Erwägung gezogen hat, für die NPD zu spenden. Diese Mechanismus hat dazu geführt, dass die NPD jetzt pleite ist, unter anderem. Also neben deren Misswirtschaft und so weiter und so fort. Also man sieht halt tatsächlich, dass Public Shaming und nichts anderes ist es ja, durchaus einen politischen Effekt haben kann.
Und das bestreitet glaube ich niemand.
Aber worüber man sich unterhalten muss, ist natürlich, ob der durch das Internet verstärkte Effekt von sowas angemessen ist. Und in diesem Fall bin ich da tatsächlich nicht entschieden. Und zwar aus dem einfachen Grund, weil ich sage, okay Homophobie ist für mich ein Verstoß gegen Artikel 1 Grundgesetz. Das halte ich nicht für eine Meinung, sondern das halte ich tatsächlich für irgendwie ernsthaftes Arschloch-Tum, was man irgendwie nicht dulden sollte. Und deswegen kann ich dir da nicht zustimmen, wenn du sagst, okay, das ist halt irgendwie übliche Meinungsbildung von Amiland, sondern das geht halt an die Menschenrechte. Da ist halt irgendwie ein bisschen Schluss.
Moment mal, im Moment wird dieses Menschenrecht für die homosexuelle Ehe ja noch in sehr vielen Ländern dieser Welt einfach pärdekret verletzt. Ja, also den Punkt möchte ich ja auch mal festhalten. Das heißt, es gibt sehr viele größere Probleme der Homophobie, auf die man sich stürzen kann.
Aber nicht mit drei Klicks.
Und wir reden hier auch nicht von Uganda, wo die Leute dann erschossen werden, wenn sie schwul sind oder als schwul gelten, sondern wir reden hier von Amerika. Da muss man die steuerliche Vergünstigung kriegen. Und im Wesentlichen, also abgesehen von den finanziellen Fragen, die kann man ja auch so wie Deutschland regeln, mit so einer irgendwie lame-ass Methode, dass man sagt, okay, das heißt nicht Ehe, aber es ist im Grunde Ehe, geht es doch um die Frage, ob Schwule gemobbt werden oder nicht, weil sie schwul sind. Und ich finde, wenn du dagegen vorgehst, indem du andere Leute mobbst, hast du alle moralische Highground verloren an der Stelle.
Was mich beschäftigt ist, der viel größere Skandal ist, wie wenig Schwule überhaupt in diese Position CEO jemals kommen. Oder wenn sie in der Situation sind, das dann verheimlichen müssen. Oder schau dir, du hast das Fußballbeispiel angefangen, schau dir den deutschen Fußball an. Wir haben sicherlich mehrere homosexuelle Fußballspieler in der Bundesliga, die heute noch in einem Klima leben, in dem sie das nicht zugeben können.
Fußball ist halt schon speziell. Aber wenn ich mir zum Beispiel die Business-Community angucke, Stichwort CEOs oder die Politik, ist es zumindest in Deutschland, da hast du da keine Nachteile mehr.
In den USA?
In den USA ist es etwas anders. In den USA ist es sicherlich anders, aber hängt auch sehr von den Bundesländern ab. Also in Kalifornien zum Beispiel ist es, glaube ich, eher nicht so ein Problem. In anderen Ländern, Texas zum Beispiel, ist es wahrscheinlich schwieriger. Genauso wie es in Deutschland wahrscheinlich, in Berlin genau gar kein Problem ist, in Bayern weiß man es nicht so genau. Aber letztendlich ist es halt die Frage, um die es sich dreht, ist also ist dieses politische Mittel, was da eingesetzt wurde, nämlich halt tatsächlich eine Enthüllung, z.B. eine Überrepräsentanz von einem privaten oder semi-privaten Datum zu benutzen, um einen politischen Punkt zu machen, war die gerechtfertigt. Die Diskussion ist ja alt, also zum Beispiel gibt es ja die, also gerade in der Schulen-Community gibt es schon lange diese, seit vielen Jahrzehnten diese Geschichte, ob Forced Outings von Leuten, die öffentlich als homophob auftreten, gerechtfertigt sind, ob das gerechtfertigend legitim ist. Und das ist quasi eine Invariance von dieser Debatte. Und letzten Endes kommen wir wieder dahin zurück, nämlich ist dein Mittel, was du verwendest, kompatibel mit deinem Ziel?
Naja, nicht nur das, es ist auch eine Frage vom Wertesystem. Ich betrachte das aus dem Wertesystem Rechtsstaat. Und ich sage, wenn du findest, Homophobie ist eine Grundrechtverletzung, dann muss ich das in den Gesetzen niederschlagen. Dann gehst du nicht los und machst diesen Mann da zum Opfer. Weil dann hast du einfach plus eins der Opfer. Du hast ja nicht das Problem verhindert. Wenn du meinst, Homophobie als Meinung ist schon schlecht. Also erstmal würde ich als, da bin ich libertär in der Einstellung, sage, wenn zu Hause jemand homophob ist, kann er das sein? Ja, wenn jemand öffentlich homophob ist. Das ist was anderes. Das kann man dem aber wohl nicht vorwerfen, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Na, wenn er Geld spendet für eine...
Hat er nicht öffentlich gemacht. Das ist dieses Register, was er öffentlich gemacht hat.
Irgendwie eine öffentliche Aktion mit einer Geldkommunikation.
Der ist nicht rumgelaufen mit irgendwie transparenten, raus mit den Schwulen und er hat keine...
Aber die Leute bezahlt, die das machen.
Ja, naja, aber das ist halt eine Frage, das ist nicht verboten. Der eigentliche Problem ist, dass es nicht verboten ist, nicht, dass der es gemacht hat. Wenn du dir einen rausgreifst und 1000 andere sind unbetroffen, das ist nicht in Ordnung, das ist einfach... Das finde ich genauso schlimm, als wenn du einen Schwulen rausgreifst und 1000 gehen lässt, weil du irgendwie ein homophober Texaner bist.
Also ich denke, das Kernproblem, was man sieht, ist irgendwie die verständliche Reaktion der Marginalisierten, die man auch immer wieder sieht, ist so, dass man sagt, wenn ich diskriminiert werde, dann sollen andere auch diskriminiert werden.
Das ist halt der menschliche Aspekt daran.
Das ist auch völlig okay, ich finde das völlig nachvollziehbar. Ich war zum Beispiel basserstauend, als ich in Südafrika durch die Townships gegangen bin und dachte so, naja, wenn du jetzt auf die Fresse kriegst, dann ist das eben mal so die Geschichte. Hast du es irgendwie dann doch auch verdient, ja? Und was passiert? Alle Menschen kommen freundlich auf mich zu, die Kinder wollen mit meiner Kamera spielen, ich denke, okay, die rennen jetzt damit weg, nein, sie lassen sich von mir erklären, wie man damit ein Foto macht, machen ein Foto mit mir zusammen, freuen sich und bedanken sich. Ich bin in keinem Ort der Welt so freundlich empfangen worden, wie in Südafrika, in Soweto, in einem Township, wo alle Weißen in Südafrika die Hände über dem Kopf zusammengeschlagen haben, dass ich überhaupt nicht in die Nähe traue. Und ich war sehr erstaunt, dass da jetzt nicht diese Menschen Rachgelüste haben. Und das war was, was mich enorm überzeugt hat, dass die, die waren froh, die haben sich gefreut. Und wenn ich sie darauf angesprochen habe, sag mal kurz, warum steckt ihr mich jetzt nicht ab? Oder hauen wir auf die Fresse?
Hast du mich gefragt?
Na klar, ist doch mein ernsthafter Punkt. Warum redest du überhaupt mit mir? Ich meine, ich bin doch absolut irgendwie, guck mich mal an. Ich bin so, und dann hat er gesagt, und da drückte sich die absolute moralische Überlegenheit dieser Menschen aus. Die also sagten, ich, aber ich bitte dich, wollen wir denn jetzt hier weiteren Hass sehen? Wir sind doch froh, dass wir denn endlich los sind. Und ich fand das großartig, war völlig durcheinander. Und bei denen war es Konsens. Jeder Weiße, der hier in unseren Township kommt, was sehr wenige sind, der wird hier freundlich mit aller Gastfreundschaft, die uns zur Verfügung steht, begrüßt. Dem wird alles erklärt, wonach er sich fragt, weil wir froh sind, dass dieser Mensch den weiten Weg hierher gegangen ist. Erst recht, wenn der vom anderen Kontinent kommt. Da war ich echt mal darüber erstaunt, weil ich diese Rachgelüste natürlich auch kenne und sage, warte mal ab.
Du hast es bei mir kommentiert, jetzt kommentiere ich bei dir.
Wenn der Linus ist und es erstmal Einzug erhält. Wer dann alles an der Wand steht. Und genau das nämlich nicht zu tun. Ich denke, da kann man natürlich auch sehr viel Größe drin zeigen. Ich bin zum Beispiel klammheimlicher und auch offener Freude darüber, dass dieser Typ acht Jahre später für diese Scheißaktion, die ein winziger Fliegenschiss in seinem langen Leben war, der man hat viel gemacht, ist absolut unrelated, ist cruel and unusual punishment für eine kleine Wahlkampfspende, die der aus der Portokasse geleistet hat. Trotzdem finde ich es natürlich klammheimlich total lustig und freue mich auch darüber, dass der da diese Quittung bekommen hat. Aber moralisch kann ich nicht unterstützen, dass das so passiert ist. Denn das Problem ist ein anderes, das Problem findet woanders statt. Und deswegen finde ich das eigentlich so, habe ich da so diese Fackel-Mob-Assoziationen und mir ist da nicht wohl bei, dass das geschehen ist. Deswegen, deswegen, Moment, das muss ich jetzt ganz kurz sagen, bevor jetzt wieder losgeht hier, ich habe gestern schon auf Twitter gehabt, deswegen möchte ich dieses Mittel dann doch kritisieren, während ich das Ziel, was alle verfolgen, und den Glauben und diesen Wert mit den Menschen vollends teile.
Naja, genau da sind wir halt bei der Frage, welche politischen oder auch nicht politischen Mittel sind denn gerechtfertigt, um ein Ziel zu erreichen?
Na Moment, du kannst auch noch das praktisch argumentieren.
Lass mich mal den Gedanken zu hinterbringen. Also was ist eigentlich der gerechtfertigte Satz an Mitteln, der uns in bestimmten Fällen zur Verfügung steht? Und wir versuchen ja immer, eine moralische Abwägung zu treffen. Und auf der Basis der Werte, die wir hochhalten. Und also man kann da halt irgendwie in die absoluten Extreme geraten. Also wenn man sich halt irgendwie anguckt, halt irgendwie 68er Bewegung versus RF, die halt ja quasi auch einen Dissens über die Mittel hatten, die halt notwendig sind, um halt diesen Kapitalismus zu beenden. Und wo am Ende der Dissens über diese Mittel und auch die Instrumentalisierung, dieses Dissens über die Mittel dazu geführt hat, oder damit dazu beigetragen hat, dass diese Bewegung halt am Ende eher nur marginale Wirksamkeit hatte. Und die Frage, die sich uns jetzt stellt mit dem Internet und wo wir auch zu dieser Sendung gekommen sind, nämlich mit den Trollen und der Empörerie und so weiter und so fort ist, ist dann, diese Mittel, die da verwendet werden in der politischen Auseinandersetzung oder in der sozialen Auseinandersetzung, sind die denn sowohl geeignet als auch gerechtfertigt für das, was halt irgendwie in dem konkreten Fall passiert. Und die Antwort liegt halt tatsächlich wiederum in dem Wertesystem, was wir da zugrunde legen. Also nämlich, ob wir sagen, okay, der war ein hinreichend großes Arschloch, dass wir in Kauf nehmen, halt eine moralisch minderwertige Handlung zu begehen, nämlich den halt irgendwie mit Daten aus seiner Vergangenheit zu belästigen und ihn um seinen Job zu bringen, um ein politisches Ziel zu erreichen. Oder sagen wir, okay, nee, das war eigentlich so ein Mittel, was nicht hätte angewendet werden sollen. Und ich glaube, auch da werden wir wieder genau an diesen Punkt landen, dass dadurch, dass wir keine wirklichen Debatten mehr führen, also keine Debatten, die irgendein Ziel, ein Outcome haben, wird dieses Problem nicht weggehen. Also ich vermute mal, dass einer der wesentlichen Differenzierungsmachungen innerhalb der sozialen Bewegung der Zukunft sein wird, dass man sich von vorneherein explizit darüber einigt, was die legitimen Mittel sind.
Das kann man glaube ich so allgemein nicht sagen.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich bin mit diesen legitimen Mitteln.
Lass mich mal ein ganz krasses Beispiel bringen, um das auf den Punkt zu bringen. Nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg die Nazis umbringen oder lebenslange Haft?
Ging ja leider beides nicht, ging ja beides nicht. Die mussten ja irgendwie die Eliten erhalten. Die hatten jetzt einfach ihre Eliten.
Ich meine jetzt wirklich die krassen Täter, so Leute wie, die haben ja ein paar Leute hingerichtet. Oder haben es versucht und haben sich dann irgendwie mit Selbstmord entzogen. Aber wenn du nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg als Staat Israel jemanden wie Eichmann fängst und du bist überzeugt davon, das ist ein Täter, der ist einer der Hauptschuldigen am Holocaust, bringst du den dann um? Oder sagst du, es ist wurscht, wie viel er getan hat, wir wollen auf dem moralischen Highground bleiben, wir sind anders, ja, also kann man ja sonst wie argumentieren, aber wir machen jedenfalls keine Todesurteile. Ist die Überzeugung dafür, dass du keinen Todesurteil machst, so groß, dass du selbst so jemanden nicht umbringst? Und das ist eben die fundamentale Frage, natürlich auf viel kleinerem Niveau, bei Fragen wie dem Brandon Eich. Und ich finde, das ist nicht nur moralisches, sondern auch taktisches Argument. Denn wenn man anfängt, Mobbing mit Mobbing zu bekämpfen, oder wenn man sich in seinen Mitteln auf das Niveau des Täters herablässt, allgemein gesprochen, den man bekämpft, dann verspielt man dabei die moralischen Gründe, dass andere einem folgen. Und das ist eigentlich, finde ich, dass der Typ einen in die Fresse verdient hat, dass er jetzt nicht eine Quittung kriegt für sein Verhalten. Keine Frage. Ich bin auch der Meinung, er hätte nicht CEO werden sollen, um ein Zeichen zu setzen. Aber wenn man den rausmobbt aus seinem Job, ohne dass er jetzt irgendwas Konkretes getan hat, ohne dass er tatsächlich eher Musilla hat schlecht aussehen lassen. Oder ein Boykott-Aufruf gegen den Browser, der ja nun auch nur peripher mit der Foundation was zu tun hat. Es gibt ja auch andere Leute, die da ein Museum entwickeln. Das ist nicht nur schlecht und unmoralisch aus meiner Sicht, sondern das nimmt mir auch die Argumente aus der Hand, warum ich diesen Leuten in Zukunft folgen soll.
Mir ist in einem Gespräch heute eine interessante Parallele eingefallen. Zum Glück musste ich jetzt deine Frage mit dem Todes- oder Lebenslang-Urteil nicht beantworten. Das hätte ich auch nicht gekonnt. Ein Fall, der ja vor ein paar Wochen sehr die Empörung beschäftigt hat, war dieser Auftritt von Anne Helm in Dresden.
Ja, falls er sie mal nicht mitgekriegt hat, das war der Piraten-Skandal.
Fanks Bomber Harris sich auf den Oberkörper geschrieben hat und sich damit hat fotografieren und in den Medien abdrucken lassen. Das war dann eben natürlich für die einen eine Verhöhnung der Opfer des Bombenangriffs auf Dresden. Aus ihrer Perspektive natürlich eine ins rechte Lichtrückung dieses Angriffs, dass nämlich eben Dresden nicht eine unschuldige Stadt war. Ich würde sagen, insgesamt könnte man sagen, eine relativ einfallslose und in ihrer Position als Listen-Kandidatin der Piratenpartei auch für das Europaparlament eine nicht besonders taktisch kluge Aktion, aber letztendlich eine legitime Aktion. Also kann sie ja machen, Nacktprotest ist doch völlig in Ordnung. Und diese These dazu vertreten ist auch völlig okay. Sie hat damit dann sehr überzogene und sehr schreckliche Reaktionen erhalten, die allerdings auch leider absehbar waren. Ja, das muss ich vorsichtig sagen.
Na, die kam auch teilweise daher, dass eben das unter dem Label Femen lief erst mal und dass sie nicht...
Ach, das weiß ich nicht. Ich denke mal, sie wird auch genug Feinde in sie...
Es gab irgendwie eine Woche oder so, wo sie einfach nicht dazu gestanden hat, dass sie das war.
Das, denke ich, ist nicht der Kern der Sache. Die Sache nahm mir ihren Lauf. Die Sache ist, sie hat da offensichtlich mit einem Feuer gespielt. Da verbrennt man sich auch mal die Finger. Und das ist aber auch der Mut, den wir brauchen, dass Menschen halt hingehen und sagen, ich gehe jetzt hier mal ein Risiko ein, ich übertrete jetzt diese Grenze. Ich will jetzt nicht Anne Helm mit Rosa Parks vergleichen. Aber man muss auch einfach mal bereit sein, sich die Finger zu verbrennen. Das Problem ist, es ist keinem geholfen, wenn dann das ganze Haus abbrennt und irgendwie die Leute massenhaft aus dieser Piratenpartei austreten, weil ihnen das jetzt irgendwie dann doch zu peinlich wird. Aber das Entscheidende war, dass ich nämlich heute jemanden auf Twitter gefragt habe, der dann irgendwie anfing, diesen Brandon Eichfall mit dem Nazi-Aufmarsch in Dresden zu vergleichen, auch etwas länger brauchte, um da hinterher zu hinken hinter diesem Vergleich. Aber das Entscheidende ist, finden wir das in Ordnung, was Anne Helm passiert ist in Reaktion auf diese Aktion, dass sie da irgendwie was getan hat, für irgendwas eingestanden ist, an das sie glaubt hat, eine Aktion gebracht hat, die jetzt nicht besonders klug war und das sehr, sehr teuer bezahlt hat, ja mit einer Bloßstellung in den Medien, mit persönlichen Bedrohungen, die ihr dann da zuteil wurden. Also weiß ich, Udo Vetter ist noch glaube ich dann in Reaktion darauf, aus der Piratenpartei ausgetreten, ja ein renommierter Mann, der dann da irgendwie noch einen größeren Schaden auf diese Partei bringt, durch seinen öffentlich erklärten Austritt und so weiter. Da ist jetzt wirklich viel Porzellan zerschlagen worden und ihr eigenes natürlich auch.
Ich würde gar nicht an der Piratenpartei das festmachen.
Nein, überhaupt nicht, aber ihr schickt es halt.
Ja, aber das größere Problem finde ich, dass du mit so einer Aktion Leute, die unentschieden sind oder in der Mitte stehen, den Nazis in die Hände treibst. Wenn du sagst hier, hallo Bomber Harris, dann führt das zu einer Schockreaktion bei den Leuten. Das ist ja gewollt. Aber das heißt eben auch, dass die ihre Positionen evaluieren und dann besteht eben die Gefahr, dass du den Nazis in die Hände treibst, die die ganze Zeit erzählen, hör mal hier Völkermord in Dresden, wir sind hier die Opfer.
Das meine ich mit der Infektion.
Das ist nicht echt das Problem, ja. Aber ich denke mal, das muss man in Kauf nehmen, wenn man politisch aktiv ist, dass sowas nach hinten losgeht und dass man krasse Folgen...
Nein, der Punkt ist halt...
Dann muss man auch sagen, ok, dann kann Brandon Icke die unangenehme Folge auch in Kauf nehmen, für seine Überzeugung eingestanden zu sein, dass Homosexle nicht heiraten dürfen und jetzt muss er die Suppe auslöffeln. Wenn er das öffentlich getan hätte. Und mit Anne Helmann natürlich alle zurecht Mitleid. Mit Brandon Icke nicht. Und das ist genau das...
Ne, doch, doch, doch. Da gibt es auch viele Leute, die Mitleid mitnehmen, besonders in den USA. Das ist nicht so clear-cut, wie es hier rüberkommt im Twitter. Also es gibt durchaus viele Stimmen, die sagen, das hätte man nicht machen sollen, ja, ihnen das so rauszueckelen. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer in der Mehrheit ist, aber...
Ja, zum Beispiel bis hin zu Slate und so anderen Artikeln, wo die einfach mal Listen von anderen Firmen, die da gesponsert haben und so weitergebracht haben und nach dem Motto, so wollte er die jetzt auch alle angehen und so. Die Frage dieser Anaheim-Aktion, also was du so schön als unklug oder nicht besonders klug umschreibst, ist für mich aber auch eine Frage dessen, wenn man mit seiner politischen Aktion Leute und seine Freunde in die Situation bringt, sich solidarisch zeigen zu müssen, weil der Mob losläuft und die Aktion selber aber eigentlich ganz schön Panne war. Oder man sich mit der Aktion, also ich zum Beispiel kann damit inhaltlich überhaupt gar nichts anfangen. Dazu weiß ich zu viel darüber, wie der Zweite Weltkrieg abgelaufen ist. Trotzdem fehlt natürlich nicht gut, wenn irgendwie Nazis anfangen, an dahin zu bedrohen. So das ist nur eine Frage, denn wie dann wiederum einfach die sekundäre und terziäre Folgen von so einer Aktion, wenn man nicht besonders lange drüber nachdenkt, dazu führen, dass die eigentliche politische Message halt überhaupt nicht mehr im Raum steht. Also dass es halt überhaupt nicht mehr darum geht, was sie eigentlich politisch erreichen wollte. Also wenn ich mit ihr dann nicht übereinstimme, kann ich erkennen, dass das politisch zumindest legitime Ansicht ist, die sie da äußert. Genau dieses Muster sehen wir überall wieder. Also es hat genau das, was wir überall haben, dass also dann tatsächlich der, also genau wie Politiker nicht über den eigentlichen Skandal stolpern, sondern über ihren Umgang damit, so immer, in jedem Einzelfall.
Also Moment, Moment, hier gehen wir gerade ein bisschen weit. Also wenn ich sage, sie muss auch die Konsequenzen tragen, meine ich nicht, dass sie sich von Nazis bedrohen lassen muss. Ja, das ist noch mal ein Ding, was ich vielleicht ausdrücklich noch mal sagen will, dass unser Staat nicht verhindern kann, dass man in solchen Fällen von Nazis gemobbt wird. Das ist ein echtes Problem, was unabhängig vom Anaheem-Pfahl mal gelöst werden muss. Aber was ich sagen wollte ist, wenn du so eine Aktion machst, musst du damit leben, dass andere Leute damit nicht einverstanden sind und irgendwie dann Kontra geben. Nicht, dass du mit Gewalt bedroht wirst.
Der interessante Punkt ist ja eben, dass diese Erwartung, dass unsere Helden heilige sind.
Ist das ein deutsches Problem eigentlich oder generell?
Das ist generell.
Frank, jetzt sagst du wieder Helden. Jetzt haben wir wieder eine Helden-Debatte.
Lass uns nicht Helden sagen, lass uns die Protagonisten sagen. Lass uns einfach nur Protagonisten sagen, damit wir irgendwie neutral bleiben. Die haben wir immer mehr. Wir haben halt bei Politikern diesen Anspruch, dass die markelos sind. Wollt. Ja, zumindest gibt es diesen Anspruch. Du hast den vielleicht nicht, weil du zynisch bist, aber allgemein ist tatsächlich der...
Ich erwarte nur von Fußballern, dass sie moralisch reinkranken und ihre Steuern zeigen.
Von Fußballmanagern.
Genau, von Fußballmanagern.
Bei Fußballern können wir mal Ausnahmen machen. Aber diese Erwartung, dass die Leute quasi, sobald sie ein bisschen prominenter sind, ein bisschen mehr zu sagen haben, dass sie unbescholten Heilige sind und keine Fehler machen, führt dazu, dass es immer wieder Distractions gibt. Dass ihre eigentlichen politischen Aussagen, ihre eigentlichen politischen Ziele nicht mehr im Zentrum der Debatte stehen, sondern es in jedem Fall immer Ablenkungsmöglichkeiten gibt. Also ein bisschen zu WikiLeaks und irgendwie allem, was damit zusammenhing, wo sich die ganze Debatte von dem, was Assange eigentlich wollte, hin, natürlich nur auf sein Privatleben fokussierte, wie es auch bei Snowden probiert haben, wo sie versucht haben, irgendwas zu finden, um ihm am Zeug zu flicken und echt verzweifelt waren, das zwar nicht so viel war. Und es genauso bei allen anderen Leuten ist, die irgendwie ein bisschen mehr im Zentrum von solchen Ereignissen stehen, dass diese Erwartung auch innerhalb der Bewegung ist, dass die Protagonisten, die weiter vorne stehen, quasi makellos sind. Und ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Aber letztendlich ist diese brennende Eichgeschichte ja genau dasselbe. Das ist also gerade Mozilla halt eine Firma, weil ich auch verstehen kann. Also Mozilla, eine Firma, die halt nun wirklich, sei mal, das Gute auf dem Banner vor sich her trägt. Dass es schwierig ist, für so eine Firma zu tolerieren, dass ihr CEO nicht makellos ist, das kann ich nachvollziehen.
Ne, ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, weil dann musst du das auch bei allen anderen anwenden und musst sagen, der darf auch nicht irgendwie Programmierer sein hier. Entweder du findest, dass das moralisch anstößig ist und solche Leute bei dir nichts verloren haben oder nicht, aber sagen, der ist jetzt CEO, da gelten andere Maßstäbe, das finde ich scheiße. Außer es geht hier tatsächlich um öffentliche Aktionen, weil dann kann man argumentieren, der beschmutzt das Image von Mozilla.
Deswegen wollte ich den Brandon eigentlich nicht in der Sendung haben.
Wieso? Na ja, ich meine, das war noch nicht... Aber wir lassen es mal weiter umgehen.
Auf deine These, was ich glaube, wo das herkommt, ist nämlich genau, dass du dann in dieser Situation bist, wenn du wirklich was erreichen willst, musst du eigentlich zynisch handeln, aber dogmatische Leute hinter dir versammeln. Du musst irgendwie zynisch eine dogmatische Gruppe führen. Und was dann natürlich blöd ist, wenn du irgendwie deren eigenen Dogmen, für die du dann natürlich Symbol wirst, nicht genügt, denen nicht genügt. Und das ist dann da, wo dein Kopf unweigerlich rollt.
Wo wir genau diese Folie haben vom GCHQ, über wie man Gruppen zersetzt. Da haben sie genau diese schöne Kurve, wenn halt irgendwie Führungspersonal nicht den eigenen moralischen Ansprüchen genügt, dann haben sie halt da Ansatzpunkte.
Und deswegen sind Gruppen so effizient, wenn sie eben keine besonders konkreten moralischen Ansprüche haben, sondern so sehr diffus, ja, also sowas wie christdemokratisch zum Beispiel, ist super, ne? Kannst du gut machen, da sind wenig konkrete Verstöße und inzwischen ist die Welt sogar so weit, dass du dem Christdemokraten mehrfache Scheidungen durchgehen lässt. Durchgehen lässt und so, ne? Oder zum Beispiel Umgang mit der Schwulenehe, wie die CDU da großartig.
Oder wer Dienst oder so, ja.
Über Jahre so eine Entwicklung begleitet, dann irgendwann erkennt und sagt, okay, und jetzt ist die Gesellschaft so weit, dass wir diesen Wert nicht mehr vermitteln müssen. Jetzt können wir den fallen lassen, ja. Sehr interessant, wie du es halt schaffst, in dieser Welt zu agieren. Wir müssen ja nicht nur immer darüber reden, wie wir quasi als die Guten uns gegenseitig zerfleischen, sondern auch mal überlegen, wie es die Bösen schaffen, dass ihnen das nicht passiert.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Wobei, denen passiert es ja schon. Und dann wird halt irgendwie ein Bauer geopfert und dann ist wieder gut. Also ich finde, dass es eben nicht nur für die Dynamik innerhalb der Gruppe schädlich ist, weil du eben aufsplittest, sondern das nimmt auch...
Also was ist jetzt konkret?
Na, dass du auf Kritik nicht mehr mit Argumenten reagierst, sondern mit Dogmen.
Ja.
Ja, sondern das nur noch... Das nimmt mir auch die Möglichkeit, meinen eigenen Fehler zu sehen, wenn ich wirklich einen Fehler habe.
Weil du sozusagen...
Wenn ich mit dir debattiere und du kritisierst aber nicht meinen Inhalt, sondern Tippfehler oder dass ich deinen Dogmen nicht genüge, dann nimmst du mir auch die Möglichkeit, dir Recht zu geben. Und das ist eine Sache, die die glaube ich alle nicht verstehen, sonst würden sie es ja nicht tun.
Naja, du meinst, in dem Augenblick, wo das Argument nicht mehr ein Inhaltliches ist, sondern ein Dogmenverstoß, kannst du...
Kann ich nichts lernen aus deren Antwort.
Nein, und vor allen Dingen kannst du ihnen eigentlich auch nicht Recht geben. Weil der sozusagen...
Ja, na das ist ja... Das haben wir schon an dem Aspekt, haben wir angesprochen.
Ja, du wirst ja nicht mit einem inhaltlichen Argument sozusagen konfrontiert, sondern nur mit einem Dogmenverstoß-Argument, was heißt das?
Ja, aber den haben wir schon angesprochen, den Aspekt. Der ist auch wichtig. Aber ich finde eben auch wichtig, dass ich nicht lernen kann, wenn ich wirklich einen Fehler mache, wenn ich mit einer Gruppe rede und die hat Recht, was man ja nicht ausschließen kann, dass ich das nie lernen kann, weil sie mir das inhaltlich meinen Fehler nicht nennen, sondern nur mir den Dogmenverstoß vorhalten.
Ja, was natürlich eine Debatte wieder unmöglich macht an der Stelle. Wie war das denn der Abmahnung?
Die Abmahnung ist so großartig. Die müssen wir auf jeden Fall nochmal verlinken.
Ein Aspekt hat mir schon angesprochen, wenn man so eine Echogrammer bildet und auf Kritik von außen nur dogmatisch reagiert und nicht inhaltlich, dann erzeugt man eine Spaltung, eine Unnötigkeit. Aber es hat noch einen anderen Infekt, den ich auch noch mal explizit anreden will. Nehmen wir mal an, ich als Außenstehender rede mit einer Gruppierung und bringe ein inhaltliches Argument. Und das ist aber falsch. Nehmen wir an, es ist tatsächlich falsch und ich weiß es noch nicht. Dann funktioniert Debatte normalerweise so, dass ich eine inhaltliche Replik kriege, aus der ich lernen kann, warum das mein Argument falsch ist und warum es falsch ist. Wenn jetzt aber die Gruppierung, mit der ich rede, nur auf einer Dogment-Ebene antwortet oder mir irgendwie Tippfehler kritisiert und nicht inhaltlich, dann nimmt sie nicht nur sich die Möglichkeit, mich zu rekrutieren, sondern sie hat mir die Möglichkeit zu verstehen, warum ich falsch liege und warum ich mich ihnen anschließen sollte. Das ist also in jeder Hinsicht ein Eigentor, das zu tun.
Die Frage dabei ist natürlich nur, warum tun Leute das? Also warum argumentieren sie nicht mehr inhaltlich, sondern nur aus der Sicht ihrer Dogmen?
Ich glaube, das ist wie im Usename damals einfach so eine Zeitoptimierung. Nachdem du dich irgendwie mit dem Hundertsten inhaltlich unterhalten hast, sagst du, ach weißt du, der schreibt nicht mal seinen Namen richtig.
Na ja, ich meine, gut so wie es ist, als Ursprung der heutigen Debattenkultur im Internet hat ja so...
Es funktioniert erschreckend gut, darauf irgendwie die ganzen Fehlstände der Debattenkultur heute zu erzielen.
Ja, also eigentlich kann man alles daherleiten. Also eigentlich, also meine zentrale These dabei ist immer, dass das Internet ist eigentlich zu groß. Immer an den Punkten, wo richtig viele Leute versuchen, was zu einem Thema zu sagen, hört es halt auf. Ja, also ich meine, wahrscheinlich hast du mal eine Statistik darüber gemacht bei Refefe, wie sich die Kompressionsrate zur Menge der Kommentare unter einem Post bewegt.
Habe ich irgendwo die Grafik? Ja, ja, also ist natürlich klar, das nimmt ab. Also vor allem, du kannst ja auch das Delta nehmen. Also du guckst einfach, bringt der Kommentar noch was im Vergleich zum anderen.
Ja, also je mehr Leute da mitreden, desto geringer ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es halt irgendwie ein inhaltlicher, substanzieller Debattenbeitrag ist, so was eigentlich erstmal nicht intuitiv ist.
Also es gibt ein großartiges Law zu, nämlich Parkinsons Law of Triviality. Und der hat ein Gedankenexperiment, das ich mir vortragen möchte, weil es absolut großartig ist. Also es gibt einen Ausschuss in einer Kommune und die müssen über das Budget entscheiden. Und es gibt drei Sachen, die zu verhandeln sind. Das erste ist ein Atomreaktor, der soll irgendwie 10 Milliarden kosten. Das zweite ist ein Bike Shed, also ein Fahrradunterständer, der kostet 350 Dollar. Und das dritte war irgendwas für 5 Dollar, völlig unsichtbar. Spielt überhaupt keine Rolle. So und die Beobachtung an diesem Law ist, dass sie sagen, der Atomreaktor wird sofort durchgewunken, weil die Leute alle annehmen, hey, das ist kompliziert und technisch. Die Leute, die das vorschlagen, werden schon wissen, was sie tun. Aber bei dem 350 Dollar Fahrradunterstand-Ding reden alle mit, es zieht sich Tage, Wochen lang hin, die Debatte, weil jeder eine Meinung dazu hat, ob der jetzt grün gestrichen wird, ob gelb gestrichen wird. Und es dauert ewig, bis es dann Konsens gibt, weil einfach jeder sich gerne einbringen möchte, der in diesem Committee mitarbeitet. Und so führt es eben dazu, dass gerade über je trivialer das Ding ist, was da abgestimmt wird, desto mehr haben die Leute den Eindruck, da kann ich auch mitreden, ohne jetzt groß hier was kaputt zu machen, ohne mich als Vollidiot zu outen. Ja, wenn ich beim Atomreaktor was vorschlage und dann verstoße ich gegen Physikgesetze, das ist ja ein echtes Risiko, aber bei so einem Fahrradding, da kann ich auch mal meine Meinung anbringen.
Aber wenn man sich in seiner Kompetenz berührt fühlt.
Genau, und das heißt einfach, je trivialer das Thema ist, desto einfacher ist es, Leuten gemacht, sich selbst gegenüber zu rechtfertigen, warum sie da jetzt eine Position zu bekleiden sollen. Und das ist das Problem von einem Blog, was allgemein ist im Vergleich zu irgendeinem Wissenschaftler-Blog, was sich mit, was weiß ich, Zahlentheorie beschäftigt. Weil da gibt es einfach weniger Leute, die sich zutrauen, da was zu sagen. Und dementsprechend gibt es weniger Leute, die Scheiße erzählen.
Ja, das kann man, obwohl, naja, Gegenbeispiel wie gesagt, zum Beispiel mein Artikel über Tumenergie. Da waren offenbar, obwohl da waren eine Menge Leute, bei die mir so ergemittelt haben, so aus dem Bauch raus. Nach dem Motto ist ja doch das moderne Ding. Und wir haben eigentlich immer dran geglaubt. Also müssen wir jetzt auch dran glauben.
Naja, nach 20, 30 Jahren Indoktrination. Glaubst du das ja auch?
Ja, das war ja auch deutlich.
Du bist ja auch ein Heretiker.
Ja, deutlich. Noch so ein Phänomen, es ist ja so dieser hooligen Effekt, den wir auch im Usenet kennengelernt haben. Das eigentlich total umgängliche Leute. Ich will jetzt gerade mal niemand so scharf angucken hier. Im Usenet oder in entsprechenden Diskussions-Mailing-Listen, denn halt gerne mal wir den großen Flammenwerfer der Rhetorik auspacken. Mehr als Freizeitsport, so ähnlich wie sich andere Leute am Wochenende, obwohl sie eigentlich sonst ganz harmlose Versicherungsvertreter sind, mal mit anderen harmlosen Versicherungsvertretern prügeln und das dann als Hooliganism kennenlernen. Das sollte man auch nicht unterschätzen. Also, dass halt durchaus immer Leute dabei sind, die haben oben vergessen bei der Kategorisierung der Teilnehmer, die halt quasi den Flamewar als Mittel der Freizeitentspannung betrachten. Was eigentlich meistens dann irgendwie die Unterhaltsämmerin stratswerden.
Ja, also da muss man auch mit der emotionalen Distanz ran.
Nee, nee, nee, das darf nicht so aussehen, als wenn du da mit emotionaler Distanz ran gehst.
Nein, niemand darf in einem Flamewar den Anschein emotionaler Distanz vermitteln, aber ist klar.
Moment, wenn man das richtig macht, das ist eine potente Waffe.
Wir sprechen hier mit einem Experten. Also was wir noch erklären müssen, ist der Godwin für die Jüngeren.
Ja, Godwins Law sagt, in einer Diskussion wird früher oder später jemand jemand anderem vorwerfen, wie Hitler zu sein oder ihn mit Hitler vergleichen und derjenige hat dann verloren.
Ich glaube, mathematisch ausgedrückt, mit der Länge einer Diskussion nähert sich die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines Hitler-Vergleichs eins an, oder?
Ja, irgendwie sowas.
Das Erstaunliche, das dauert wirklich nicht lange.
Ja, und das ist einfach immer so, dass der, der es zuerst macht, verloren hat.
Ja, und das Rätsel ist zu Ende.
Nee, leider nicht. Das war früher so. Das war früher so, aber inzwischen ist es nicht mehr so. Sondern die Leute debottieren dann weiter.
Also im Usenet war es noch tatsächlich so, dass im Usenet...
Nee, nee, auch nicht. Da gab es dann jemanden, der sagt, ha ha, Gottwin, du hast verloren. Dann kommt jemand, ja Moment, Moment, ist aber tatsächlich so.
Also den Relativierungssratt stimmt richtig.
Im Großen und Ganzen ist dann vorbei. Inhaltlich ist auf jeden Fall vorbei.
Inhaltlich ist vorbei, genau.
Aber es gibt noch so Hausmeister.
Man kann den Sratt ignorieren, ja.
Ja, wir haben hier noch ein Best-of von typischen Streitthemen, die so bei Webforen oder im Usenet immer eine Rolle gespielt haben, sowas wie Klar-Namenspflicht oder Mailinglisten. Klar-Namenspflicht. Soll man jetzt verlangen, dass die Leute sich mit ihrem realen Namen einloggen oder ist ein Pseudonym okay? Dann, wenn man eine Signature am Ende hat, wie lang die sein darf, ob Smileys erlaubt sind, ob man irgendwie Farben vergeben darf, ob man Comic Sans verwenden darf, wie das mit der Rechtschreibung ist, Grammatik. Seit neuestem eben auch Homophobie, Tugend-Furore. Also es kommt natürlich auch auf diese zweite Gruppe an. Bei Hackern gibt es noch ein paar speziellere Sachen, wie ob man verschlüsseln soll oder nicht, was wo und wie lange von wem archiviert wird, Datenschutzkram, Anonymisierung, Deanonymisierung, Pseudonyme, bla bla bla, VI gegen EMAX, aber der Verein...
Reply to all versus reply to list, ob man Facebook nutzen soll.
Ob man Facebook, ob man überhaupt mitreden darf, solange man Facebook-Account hat, genau. Es fällt auf, dass nichts davon inhaltlich irgendetwas mit dem aktuellen Weltgeschehen zu tun hat. Das sind alles irgendwelche Metathemen, völlig belanglos, aber darüber wird endlos gestritten. Und es ist noch nie dokumentiert worden, dass es zu einem Ergebnis gekommen ist irgendwo.
Naja, zwischendurch gibt es immer mal wieder was. Also, also reply to ist auch noch ein sehr...
Ja, ja, haben wir schon alle angesprochen.
Großartig.
Ich bin ja ein großer Freund von reply to list, das macht die Listen so viel unterhaltsamer.
Wir müssen jetzt echt mal die Liste umkonfigurieren. Ist großartig. Ja, ist total toll.
Ich bin da im Moment der Vertreter von reply to list, einfach aus rein Popcorn-Grund. Das kann ich nicht in Grunde sein, nur reines Popcorn.
Ja, historischer Kontext oder man kann auch sagen, das Ergebnis davon ist, dass im Handy-Listen und Usenet-Forum ein todsicheres Mittel sind, um Kräfte, Energie, Mittel zu binden und Projekte zu verhindern, was man in großen Firmen mit der Rechtsabteilung regelt. Das regelt man in Vereinen und Non-Profits über Mailing-Listen und Webforen. Ja, ich hab hier noch so ein paar Taktiken.
Ah ja, genau, wir haben noch die Taktiken und die psychologischen Effekte.
Jetzt zählt der Fefe mal den Waffenschrank auf.
Das Schöne ist, dass es für einige von denen so schöne Namen gibt, gibt es zum Beispiel den Gish Gallop. Das ist ein Kreationist, nachdem diese Technik belandt ist. Und Gallop ist Gallopien. Da schießt man einfach so viele Argumente in schneller Abfolge ab, dass die Gegenseite nicht die Zeit hat, die alle zu entkräften. Gerne auch mit Variationen von demselben Argument mehrfach hintereinander. Das spielt keine Rolle, denn man muss einfach nur mehr Argumente bringen, als die Gegenseite entkräften kann. Das ist mal bei South Park im Rahmen von einer OJ Simpson Trial Verarschung benutzt worden und trägt seitdem auch den Namen Chewbacca die Fans. Großartig, also sowas. Ich sammel ja solche Namen. Und ein anderer Termin, über den ich mich tot gelacht habe, als ich ihn gestern gelesen habe, ist fractal wrongness, also fraktalfalsch sein. Man hat sofort ein Bild vor Augen. Es geht um jemanden, der so falsch ist, dass egal ist, aus wie viel Entfernung man es betrachtet, von ganz weit weg oder ob man nahe rangeht. Je näher man rangeht, desto mehr Facetten des Falschseins entdeckt man. Also es gibt da wunderbar soziologische Betrachtungen von Methoden und den Problemen, so wie noch. Dann natürlich, seit wir Wikipedia haben, ist jeder überall Universal-Experte. Man muss ja nur mal kurz klicken und referiert dann, ohne es wirklich verstanden zu haben. Ich will mich da auch nicht ausnehmen, also jedenfalls nicht komplett. Wir referieren ja auch gerne aus Wikipedia hier mal bei Alternativlos. Das ist nicht alles schlecht, aber es gibt eben so ein paar Aspekte daran, die das ein bisschen gefährlich machen. Der wichtigste ist der Dunning-Krüger-Effekt. Den trägt jetzt mal der Frank vor.
Der Dunning-Krüger-Effekt.
Kurz bei Wikipedia, Dankschlag.
Überschätzung der eigenen Kompetenz, oder?
Tatsächlich ist es so, wenn man eigentlich nicht so besonders viel weiß, aber...
Je mehr man weiß, desto weniger nimmt man an, es wirklich zu wissen.
Genau. Also je genauer man ein Thema eigentlich tatsächlich durchdrungen hat, desto mehr weiß man darüber, wie wenig man eigentlich weiß und welche Facetten dieses Themas einem noch unerschlossen bleiben oder wo es Unsicherheit und Unwissen gibt. Und je weniger man tatsächlich objektiv über ein Thema weiß, desto mehr glaubt man davon zu wissen, insbesondere wenn man den Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen hat.
Das Überflogen, im Allgemeinen Fall.
Genau, das ist halt so der Daning-Krüger-Effekt, der sich natürlich in solchen Debatten halt auch immer großartig äußert.
Und das nächste ist, da wusste ich gar nicht, dass du einen Namen vergibst. Ist auch ein ganz großer Artikel-Effekt.
Genau, und zwar ist der Effekt, wenn du einen Zeitungsartikel über ein Thema liest, von dem du wirklich Bescheid weißt. Also wo du denkst, okay, oder objektiv so ist, da kennst du dich wirklich aus. Und dann merkst du so, naja, also dieser Zeitungsartikel ist nur eine sehr merkwürdig verzerrte Annäherung an die tatsächlichen Wahrheiten und Geschehnisse, die also eher...
So Verwechseltursache und Wirkung auf dem Niveau. Die Überschrift stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Also es repräsentiert eigentlich alles falsch. Also ungefähr so... Es gibt halt nur so ungefähre Annäherungen an die Fakten. Also halt so der Radio-Irehren-Warn-Effekt. So grober Bullshit.
Und dann blättert man um und liest einen Artikel aus einem anderen Genre und vergisst sofort, dass man gerade gelernt hat, dass diese Zeitung Scheiße fabulisiert und geht davon aus, dass dieser andere Artikel komplett die Wahrheit ist.
Und benutzen in seinen Argumentationen.
Nennt sich Girl-Man-Amnesia.
Ja, was soll ich noch? Jetzt kommen wir zu dem schwierigen. Ganz tollen Begriff, auch ultra-crepidarian. Das ist aus Latein. Ich dachte dieses Wort, das müssen wir bringen. Also ultra heißt mehr als, sozusagen. Und crepidarian sind Sandalen. Also was gemeint ist, ist ein Schuster. Es gibt, was wir heute sagen, Schuster bleibt bei deinen Leisten. Den Spruch gab es auch in Brom bei den alten Lateinern. Und da hieß es halt Schuster bleibt unterhalb, also bleibt bei Sandalen nicht höher als die Sandalen. Und ein ultra-crepidarian ist jemand, der über die Sandalen hinausgeht. Also jemand, der von Sachen schreibt, von denen keine Ahnung hat. Und dieses Wort fand ich so geil, dass ich mir das jetzt einfach mal hier notiert habe in unserem Pad, damit wir das mal in unseren Wortschatz übernehmen können. Ja, es bildet sich üblicherweise auch so eine Wagenburg-Mentalität raus, wenn man anfängt, im Internet zu verhandeln mit irgendwelchen Gruppen, dass man den Eindruck gewinnt, man ist von Idioten umgeben, überall nur Vollidioten und wir müssen uns hier verteidigen, wir müssen uns zusammen raffen.
Klar, insbesondere wenn die dann halt nicht den richtigen Jargon sprechen oder halt irgendwie dem Dogmen böse Begriffe verwenden, keine Triggerwarnungen an ihre Blogposts machen und ähnliche Dinge tun. Ja, das geht ja gar nicht. Dann ist natürlich die Wagenburg die Rettung aus dem bösen Universum.
Es gibt ja noch so ein paar Zersetzungsdinger. Die Wortwahl übernehme ich jetzt hier an der Stelle aus einem Wiki von einer von diesen Gruppen. Und die haben den Begriff geprägt Oppression Olympics. Und das ist der Wettstreit in einer Diskussion zwischen, sagen wir, Genderisten und Transsexuellen. Da gibt es dann den Streit, der jetzt eigentlich mehr unterdrückt wird von der Gesellschaft. Und das ist eine Methode, um Debatten zu zersetzen und von dem eigentlichen Problem abzulenken. Fand ich auch den Begriff toll.
Ja, weil sich selbstwert gefühlt über diese Marginalisierung. Also wie gesagt, wir müssen uns ja auch alle, nicht nur brauchen wir irgendwas, woran wir glauben können, wir müssen ja auch noch immer alles noch was haben, was uns besonders macht, was uns auch persönlich besonders macht, warum ich überhaupt auf dieser Welt eine Daseinsberechtigung habe, warum ich besonders bin.
Und warum ich damit kämpfe. Warum kämpfe ich eigentlich bei der Gruppe mit, weil ich auch betroffen bin.
Und in dieser Gruppe möchte ich dann bitte noch der Betroffene sein, wenn du erst mal so weit bist, dass die Opferrolle eben auch Kern deiner Identitätsauffassung wird. Ich denke, da geht es dann auch wirklich in einen Bereich, wo ich mir nur wenige zielführende Auswege noch vorstellen kann. Jetzt weiß der, ist jetzt wieder das Beschen. Opfer darf man ja heute nicht mehr.
Opfer ist ja ein Schimpfwort inzwischen.
Opfer ist einerseits ein Schimpfwort und andererseits ist aber natürlich, was heute ja so vorwiegt, ist, dass, weil wir ja alle zu viele Privilegien haben und gar nicht die Opferperspektive mehr nachvollziehen können. Wir sind jetzt also hier ja auch. Hier sind drei heterosexuelle weiße Männer versammelt, die sich mit den Problemen marginalisierter auseinandersetzen, die sie selber am eigenen Leib nie erfahren haben. Und was da natürlich häufig, denke ich, auch zu Recht argumentiert ist, dass gesagt wird, nur das wirkliche Opfer, nur jemand, der wirklich unterprivilegiert ist und unter diesen Benachteiligungen zu leiten hat, kann beurteilen, ob da eine Diskriminierung stattfindet oder nicht. Also zum Beispiel Männer können sich hinstellen und sagen, bei uns können auch Frauen arbeiten, die hätten genauso die Beförderung bekommen können wie ich. Aber wenn du in die gesamte Gesellschaft schaust, siehst du, dass das eben nicht passiert. Und wenn du eine Frau bist, kannst du das wahrscheinlich auch fühlen und erfahren, wie du eben in der Gesellschaft unterdrückt wirst oder bestimmte Privilegien nicht hast. Und ich denke, dass die These im Allgemeinen auch richtig ist. Was wir aber beobachten ist das, oder was ich beobachte in Diskussionen, ist, dass von dem Allgemeinen Fall auf den Einzelfall gesetzt wird. Dass nämlich die betroffene Person im Einzelfall den Definitionsraum darüber hat, bin ich jetzt gerade Opfer oder nicht. Spielt sich zum Beispiel interessante Debatten bei Veranstaltungen, massene Veranstaltungen, sagen wir mal, du machst einen Kongress für Computer Interessierte.
Moment, es geht nicht darum, bin ich gerade Opfer, sondern bin ich allgemein Opfer, ist mein Eindruck. Es geht nicht darum, werde ich jetzt hier gerade diskriminiert, sondern es geht eher darum, kann ich allgemein von mir sagen, dass ich diskriminiert werde.
Das ist richtig. Was ich jetzt sagen möchte, geht darüber noch so ein bisschen hinaus. Dass es jetzt diese Aktion gibt, das Opfer hat Recht. Ja, also häufig bei so Fragen der sexuellen Belästigung von Frauen im Rahmen von Großveranstaltungen. Wenn die Frau sagt, ich fühle mich durch diesen Mann belästigt, dann hat die Frau Recht, weil sie ist das Opfer.
Das hast du aber falsch zusammengefasst. Es ist nicht das Opfer hat Recht, sondern ob es ein Opfer ist, hängt davon ab, ob es sich als Opfer fühlt. Was ja durchaus gerechtfertigt ist bei Sachen für Gewalt. Nein, nein, nein. Die Frage ist, Opfer ist ja an sich kein Weasel-Word, sondern Opfer heißt, da ist was passiert. Aber das lässt sich halt bei Tatbeständen wie sexueller Nötigung nicht unbedingt beweisen. Und daher gibt es aus der Frauenbewegung in diesem Konzept, Opfer ist nicht mehr eine rationale Sache, die du irgendwie beobachtest, sondern es reicht, wenn jemand sich als Opfer fühlt oder glaubt, belästigt worden zu sein, um tatsächlich ein Opfer zu sein.
Genau, und dann haben sie aber auch recht. Und wenn es einen Opfer gibt, gibt es auch einen Täter oder eine Täterin. Und denen ist dann eben entsprechend zu begegnen.
Nur, dass irgendwie mittlerweile halt wir an dem Punkt angelangt waren, wo das Opfersein sich darüber definierte, dass sie einen Vortrag ansehen mussten, der nicht properly gendert war.
Genau, aber das ist ja der Punkt. Das folgt ja daraus, dass Opfer jetzt eben keine wissenschaftlich beobachtbare Sache ist, sondern davon abhängt, wie sich das Opfer fühlt. Ob der den Eindruck hat, er ist das Opfer oder nicht.
Genau, und darauf möchte ich hinaus, dass Opfer kann quasi entscheiden, das Opfer hat immer recht. Das Opfer hat die Deutungshoheit über die Situation, wenn man sich dem anschließt. Und da gibt es einen schönen Vergleich, an den ich mich, ich weiß nicht von wem der genau stammt, müsste ich da nochmal raussuchen, vielleicht finden wir es in den Links, wo ein Schwarzer sagte, Rassismus ist, wenn ich in ein Restaurant gehe und der Kellner mich scheiße behandelt. Und ich nicht weiß, ob der mich scheiße behandelt, weil er einen scheiß Tag hat, oder ob der mich scheiße behandelt, weil er ein Rassist ist. Und wenn ich in ein Restaurant gehe und der Kellner mich freundlich bedient und ich nicht weiß, ob er mich freundlich behandelt, weil er ein Rassist ist und darüber hinwegtäuschen will und mich deswegen reverse besonders freundlich behandelt oder weil er einfach nur einen guten Tag hat. Und das ist glaube ich eine sehr gute Beschreibung eben zu sagen, wenn du wirklich, wenn die Diskriminierung über alles und du sie nicht mehr unterscheiden kannst. Das ist echt das, was Rassismus ausmacht und was das Dreckige an Rassismus ist. Spannend finde ich, dass dieser Vergleich, den dieser Mensch da gebracht hat, eben genau zeigt, warum du im Einzelfall dann eben nicht dem Urteil eines Einzelnen trauen darfst. Sondern warum wir uns schon vor längerer Zeit dazu entschieden haben, dass dann doch Gerichte über Straftatbestände, Urteile fällen und wir versuchen, uns irgendwie einer Objektivität anzunähern. Denn was wir haben, wenn wir einzelnen Gruppen, egal wer es ist, die Deutungshoheit über eine Situation geben, ist, dass das natürlich dann auch zu katastrophalen Fehlsituationen führt.
Es führt halt am Ende dazu, dass Leute sich anmaßen, zum Beispiel über Inhalte bestimmen zu können. Also ich meine, wir hatten halt die Situation, dass da tatsächlich Leute gab, die uns dazu zwingen wollten, Vorträge zu verhindern, wenn die halt nicht irgendwie ihren Vorstellungen von geschlechtsgerechter Sprache und Triggerwarnung entsprechen.
Die mal ein bisschen weiter zurück. Wir sind jetzt mal im Mittelalpen.
Da sind wir genau an dem Punkt, wo ich sagen muss, Entschuldigung, da sind wir halt einfach an einem Punkt, wo versucht wird, auf der Basis von, sagen wir mal, Partikularbefindlichkeiten, weil da ging es nicht um objektive Diskriminierung, sondern nur um unterschiedliche Ansicht über Begriffe, versucht wird, Zensur zu betreiben. Da ist für mich halt einfach Schicht im Schacht.
Ja, aber das kannst du ja nämlich gar nicht beurteilen, weil du bist ja ein heterosexueller Weisermann von...
Du hast ja deine Privilegierten nicht gecheckt.
Ich kann trotzdem sehen, was Zensur ist. Der Punkt ist, da sind wir bei den Werten. Da sind wir nämlich genau bei den Werten. Meinungsfreiheit und Menschenrechte sind halt die beiden Werte, die universell sind und wo wir auch als Hacker-Szene einen geringen Dissens darüber haben, was überwiegt.
Naja, das ist ja auch ein Menschenrecht, was die Opfer vorbringen.
Moment, der Punkt ist dabei, aber das ist tatsächlich die Frage, was ist uns wichtiger? Also wollen wir uns jetzt tatsächlich politisch unwirksam machen, indem wir uns diesen Partikularinteressen unterwerfen, diesem angenommenem Grundproblem, was für mich kein Grundproblem ist, sondern ein Partikularproblem? Oder wollen wir halt politisch wirksam bleiben? Ist für mich klar zu beantworten.
Das finde ich aber die falsche Argumentation, weil das eine taktische Argumentation ist und kein moralische. Ich finde, man muss auch auf moralischer Ebene sagen können, das hier wiegt mehr als das. Zensur ist eine größere Einschränkung, als dass jemand nicht-gegenderte Sprache kriegt. Wenn du sagst, wir machen das nur, weil der CCC besser arbeiten kann, wenn wir mehr erreichen, das finde ich nicht ausreichend, sondern man muss auch sagen, auch auf moralischer Ebene gibt es einen Argument dafür.
Der Punkt ist, wir können uns nicht hinstellen, dass wir diesen Vortrag zensiert haben. Quite simply. Wir nehmen Vorträge nicht an, aber tatsächlich, weil jemand sich bestimmten Maßstäben, die nicht universell eindeutig sind, nicht unterwirft, zu sagen, hier kannst du deinen Vortrag nicht halten, tut mir leid. Wenn es ein Nazi ist, hat er bei uns nichts zu suchen, da braucht man nicht überdiskutieren. Aber viel mehr ist dann halt eben doch nicht so.
Ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass unser Rechtssystem also funktioniert hat, dass wir gesagt haben, das Opfer hat recht. Das waren die Hexenverfolgung. Da hat das Opfer gesagt, der hat mich mit einem bösen Blick verzaubert und da musste man nicht beweisen, dass irgendwas stattgefunden hat und das war eben kein guter Weg.
Offensichtlich nicht.
Ja, Cotiers Reply ist der Fachbegriff dafür, dass man sagt, ja du hast dich aber hier nicht durch das Festmeter Literatur durchgelesen, du kannst bei uns nicht mitreden.
Ganz beliebt jetzt auch an Universitäten. Also dass dann irgendwie auch die Menschen, die dann eben in so einer Sektierer-Geisteshaltung sind, haben natürlich auch irgendwann keinen Bock mehr, ewig die gleichen Diskussionen zu führen.
Ist im Grunde wie unsere FAQ im Usenet. Wir haben gesagt, hey, mit dir red ich gar nicht, außer du hast hier unsere FAQ gelesen. Und genau sowas gibt es eben auch bei anderen Kopierungen.
Du hast sie nicht gelesen, du hast Bouddou nicht gelesen, wuppti du, du weißt ja gar nicht, was um so zu reden. Denk einfach mal nach, du kannst auf unserem Niveau ja gar nicht diskutieren.
So sieht es so aus. Was mir noch aufgefallen ist, was ich gerne noch ansprechen wollte, ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen darauf geachtet, wo denn diese Vorwürfe kommen und gegen wen sie kommen und von wem sie kommen, dass jemand seine Privilegien nicht gecheckt hat, in Sexismusdebatten. Und da ist mir aufgefallen, 80 Prozent von den Vorwürfen kam von Männern. Also weiße, hetero, privilegierte Männer brüllen sich gegenseitig an, sie hätten ihre Privilegien nicht gecheckt. Und das fand ich eine ausgesprochen interessante Einsicht an der Stelle. Dass hier selbst, wenn wir jetzt sagen, dass Opfer entscheidet selbst, ob es Opfer ist oder nicht, dass hier eben nicht die Opfer kommen und aus ihrer moralisch erklärbaren Haltung heraus, Opfer zu sein, sagen, ich kann dir jetzt vorschreiben, was du machst, sondern dass andere Leute, die mit Sicherheit kein Opfer sind, dann losrennen und andere privilegieren. Das ist so ein Zwischenschritt, den ich spannend finde.
Und dieses heißt, das Heilige als das Heiligste.
Genau, das heißt eben, dass auf Basis von einer reinen Dogmatik das stattfindet und nicht auf Basis von ich verpier tatsächlich, ich bin das Opfer, ich kann das jetzt machen.
Also ich finde halt dieses Privilegien checken ist genau das gleiche wie dieses Lies mal ein Buch oder dieses Buch oder jenes. Ich finde das so mit einem der unlautesten Moves, den ich in Diskussionen begegnen kann. Wie gesagt, ich bin ja absoluter Zyniker und bewerte jedes Mittel eigentlich nur nach seiner Effektivität. Und wenn ich dann irgendwie mal eine Kritik übe und mir dann einer kommt mit, ja, aber du als Privilegierter, check mal deine Privilegien.
Das ist so ein Mittelfingerargument.
Es ist einfach so, damit wird mir ja jede Möglichkeit des Nachdenkens abgesprochen.
Ich bin ja mittlerweile auf dem Punkt zu sagen, ich benutze halt meine Privilegien dazu, irgendwie tiefer und länger nachdenken zu können, weil ich zum Glück die Zeit und die Chance dazu habe. Und leite aus meinen Privilegien möglicherweise ab, dass ich das Thema tiefer durchdrungen habe als du. Was ein richtiges Scheißargument ist.
Aber dann machst du genau das Gleiche. Ich finde, man muss von dieser Ebene weg. Also es gibt natürlich auch dieses gesamte Empörerierphänomen, ist natürlich auch echt verstärkt durch Twitter. Das, was diese gesamten Gedanken und Weltkonstrukte, die die Menschen da haben und die auch alle echt wirkliche Probleme unserer Gesellschaft betreffen.
Das bestreite ich.
Okay, das bestreitest du ich, aber nicht. Lass mich ganz kurz...
Führt es zu Ende aus, dann bestreitest du es.
Ich versuche eben, den Satz zu Ende zu finden, ja? Also Sexismus ist ein offensichtliches Problem und viele andere Probleme, derer sich diese Menschen angenommen haben, sind auch welche, ja? Es mag sein, dass sie die in ihrer Bedeutung überschätzen oder dass ich sie in der Bedeutung unterschätze. Anerkennen werde ich in der Regel jedes einzelne ihrer Grundprobleme, dass sie meinen, das existiert. Also ich finde es nach wie vor unlauter, ja? Wenn ich dann sage, pass mal auf, wenn dein Problem dieses und jenes ist und das das Mittel ist, was du wählst. Und ich sage, das kritisiere ich. Also ein schönes Beispiel ist zum Beispiel Antifa. Geh's hin und sag so, dieses und jenes ist das Problem. Und um dieses zu bekämpfen, gehen wir jetzt hin und kandalieren. Ja, schmeißen Scheiben ein, kriegen am Ende von Bullen ein auf die Fresse und sagen, Polizeigewalt, Bullenstaat. So grob funktioniert dieses Konzept oder so grob funktioniert das Ritual, nicht das Konzept. Das Konzept ist nämlich ein anderes. Aber das Ritual, was stattfindet, ist immer dieses. Wenn ich dann hingehe und sage, ich weiß nicht, ob das, was jetzt hier passiert ist in dieser Demonstration und wenn ich das jetzt schaue, wie das in den Medien rezipiert und verarbeitet wird, weiß ich nicht, ob das zielführend war. Dann habe ich sofort eine ewige Legitimitätsdebatte an der Backe. Das ist aber legitim. Wir haben hier das Recht zur Gegenwehr und wir sind hier eine marginalisierte Gruppe und wenn uns niemand mehr zuhört, dann müssen wir uns mit Gewalt verteidigen. Das ist richtig.
Stimmt alles. Das ist nur dann richtig, wenn du dich nicht selber marginalisiert hast.
Und lass uns dein Argument zu Ende bringen.
Die Frage ist, der Punkt ist, sie möchte auf die Frage des Zielführends hinaus. Ja und ob die Antifa im Moment das Beste im PR-Bereich für sich rausholt, mag ich an zu zweifeln.
Du hast es vorhin so schön zusammengefasst, als wir drüben am Tisch da waren. Mach das doch nochmal. Die Ziele und die Mittel, die müssen verwechselt werden. Bericht es nochmal runter. Das war irgendwie so ein Zweisatzding, was einfach die gesamte Problematik auf den Punkt gebracht hat.
Wir müssen unsere Mittel einfach von den Zielen trennen. Ja, also wir haben Ziele, über die sind wir uns einig. Wir haben unterschiedliche Mittel und wir müssen oder wir favorisieren unterschiedliche Mittel und über diese Mittel müssen wir diskutieren können, ohne dass wir direkt meinen, dass der andere unsere Ziele in Frage stellt. Und das ist das, was uns die ganze Zeit im Weg steht. Wenn ich jetzt sage, oh, das ist aber jetzt ein bisschen hart, dass dieser Renten-Eig da zurücktreten musste und dann geht das direkt los. Ja, hier, lehne dich zurück in deiner Homophobie, du privilegierter, weißer Mann. Dann habe ich später gesagt, okay, ich würde jederzeit 1000 Euro an eine Anti-Ehe-Initiative spenden. Und dann ging es natürlich auch los, weil ich irgendwie dann die verheiratete. Was bist du denn für ein Degenerierter? Und dann habe ich dann mal darauf hingewiesen, dass ich mich als unverheirateter Single steuerlich massiv unterprivilegiert fühle. Und dann ging es natürlich rund, dass ich jetzt irgendwie den heiligen Akt der Eheschließung dann da irgendwie diskreditiere oder so. Na, aber das war übrigens sehr schönes treuen, wenn ich mich da mal selber loben würde.
Ja, ja, so muss ich auch sagen. Du hast wirklich jede einzelne Gruppe in der Reihe, die mich aufgebracht hat.
Also ich denke, das ist eigentlich nur ein ganz guter Abschluss. Ich denke, wir müssen wirklich darüber nachdenken, wie wir unsere Diskussion über die Mittel von den Diskussionen über unsere Ziele trennen. So weil wir müssen lernen, über beides zu debattieren und zwar tatsächlich mit einer Zielführung und auch anzuerkennen, dass wir einen Distanz haben. Also das ist halt irgendwie unterschiedliche Gruppen, die dieselben Ziele teilen, aber möglicherweise andere Mittel favorisieren und akzeptieren, dass sie von anderen Leuten, die ihre Ziele teilen, aber ihre Mittel scheiße finden, kritisiert werden und zwar möglicherweise auch zurecht kritisiert werden und darüber halt eben auch wirklich Debatten führen können, ohne dass man sich gleich vorwurft irgendwie zum anderen Camp zu gehören. So und weil letztendlich ist es genau das, wenn wir zurückgucken, was die sozialen und dem akzeptatorischen Bewegungen der Vergangenheit halt eben nicht geschafft haben. Also tatsächlich eben diese Diskussion nicht so zu führen, dass man dem anderen jeweils unterstellt, halt ein Agent des Feindes zu sein und irgendwie was auch immer oder halt irgendwie.
Das ist doch aber auch schon echt altes Konzept. Das ist jetzt nicht, nicht die Diskussion. Technologie gebunden.
Nee, aber tatsächlich ist es in gewisser Art und Weise schon technologie gebunden, weil natürlich die Geschwindigkeit viel größer geworden ist. Und dass wir eben nicht mehr in der Lage sind, bisher wieder rationale Debatten zu führen, die halt ein Outcome und ein Ziel haben, hat eben doch ganz viel damit zu tun, dass wir eben sofort alle Mittel, also was wir tun, ist, wenn wir in eine Debatte gehen, machen wir sofort den ganzen Waffenschrank auf. Also wir gehen ad hominem, wir werfen den Leuten vor, dass sie nicht demselben Ziel angehören. Wir packen das ganze flammende Schwert der Rhetorik aus, weil es uns irgendwie passt und so weiter und so fort. Mobilisieren die Fackelscharen, um per sozialen Druck Leute anzugreifen und so weiter und so fort. Es gibt halt eben keine Abstufung mehr. Es gibt halt keine bewusste Eskalation mehr, sondern es ist halt immer gleich so full blown. Und stattdessen sich mal darüber zu unterhalten, okay, für diese Kampagne ist vielleicht dieses Mittel eben nicht so der coole Weg gewesen, weil man hat halt irgendwie diese in die Nebenwirkung, aber wir teilen im Kern dieses Ziel. Und darüber halt auch einfach einen Dialog zu entwickeln zwischen den Gruppen und zwischen den Personen muss eigentlich das Ziel sein, weil sonst kommen wir nicht weiter. Sonst bleiben wir genau da stehen, wo wir jetzt sind. Nämlich halt, das Internet hat uns jegliche Möglichkeit zerstört, tatsächlich produktive politische Debatten zu führen.
Das ist nicht das Internet. Wir haben uns selbst zerstört. Wir nehmen nur das Internet als Vorwort.
Wir nehmen das Internet als Vorwort.
Lass mich noch kurz meine Fundamentalkritik anbringen, warum Twitter nicht schuld ist. Was selten ist, weil ansonsten finde ich Twitter an fast allem schuld. Aber daran ist Twitter meines Erachtens nicht schuld, denn......wären Sie nun Zeuge wie Fefe Twitter verteidigt... .von den gesamten Drecks-Tweets, die da so aufschlagen, die mir gewahr werden, was ja nur ein Bruchteil ist. Insofern wahrscheinlich gibt es hier wieder Sample-Size-Probleme. Aber so von den Debatten, die ich da sehe, ist es sehr selten, dass jemand auch nur in die Nähe der 140 Zeichen kommt. Sondern der Versuch wird gar nicht mehr unternommen, sein Argument überhaupt hinzuschreiben. Sondern die gesamte Kritik, die man so auf Twitter sieht, ist so atominem, fundamental links. Ach, der hat ja schon wieder irgendwas nicht verstanden. Oder so, hat der schon wieder Scheiße erzählt, habe ich gehört, so fertig, auf dem Niveau. Und das sind irgendwie 20, 30 Zeichen. Das sind nicht 140. Deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass das Twitter-Größendimit daran schuld ist, dass unsere Debatten hier...
Nee, aber Twitter ist daran schuld, in dem Sinne, weil es zu groß ist. Weil es tatsächlich irgendwie keine Limitierung der Größe der Debattengruppe enthält.
Ja, aber du siehst ja immer nur irgendwie so eine Handvoll von Leuten. Wobei, was mir in letzter Zeit aufgefallen ist, es gibt einen Trend zum Zweit-Account bei Twitter, um künstlich dafür zu sorgen, dass es größer aussieht, als er ist, der Dissens. Da gibt es dann nicht nur einen Typ, sondern zwei Typen, die dieselbe Meinung vortragen.
Ja, ein bisschen zu ganzen Bordnetzen auf Twitter.
Ja, aber gut, das habe ich jetzt so nicht so persönlich beobachten können. Aber das glaube ich denen natürlich.
Was war dieses Phänomen? Da gab es doch so einen Twitter-Account, eine Blog-Empfehlung oder so was.
Blog-Empfehlung, ja.
Dass wir jetzt so weit sind, nicht nur unter 140 Zeichen uns gegenseitig irgendwie.
Was ist das Kollektives Filter Bubble Management? Und zwar auf der Basis von sozialem Bullying. Also, dass man sagt, okay, dem folgst du also noch, aha. Also, das ist sozusagen allein das Wahrnehmen der Meinung des Gegners.
Ja, das ist ganz schlimm.
Ich beobachte das ja mit absoluter Begeisterung, wenn die Leute sich da gegenseitig vorwerfen.
Ja, der Punkt ist nur...
Also, ich lese Fefes Blog ja schon seit Jahren nicht mehr.
So ein Dutzende jedes Mal, so ja.
Aber genau dieses technische Mittel benutzen, um sozialen Druck aufzubauen, die Argumente des Gegenübers nicht mehr wahrzunehmen. Und das ist halt, was war das heute jetzt, dieser Chrome Plug-in, der irgendwie einen davor warnen soll, auf bestimmte Links zu klicken. Ja, ja. So ein Unsinn. Der führt halt einfach dazu, dass diese Echo-Kammer halt immer kleiner wird und dementsprechend auch der Argumentenraum und der Denkraum halt natürlich immer kleiner wird.
Mein Highlight war neulich bei Colbert, als sie den Twitter-Chef eingeladen haben, um den Colbert Repor Twitter-Account zu killen. Und haben sie ihn gefragt, was er sich eigentlich dabei gedacht hat, Twitter zu eröffnen. Und seine Antwort war World Wide Platform for Free Speech. Und auf kaum einer Plattform sind wir so von Free Speech entfernt, wie bei Twitter. Da geht es eigentlich nur noch darum, wer wen nicht mehr liest und wie du liest es noch. Also das finde ich sehr witzig, weil man da auch sieht, wie Dogmen-Räume miteinander kollidieren können.
Ich halte das aber tatsächlich eher so für einen momentan Nischen-Phänomen, dieses Block-Empfehlung und so weiter.
Hast du Leute geblockt?
Was?
Ja, drei ungefähr, die mich total nerven.
Ja, nee, nix Nischen-Phänomenen. Fast jeder, der einen Twitter-Account hat, blockt irgendwelche Leute.
Nein, aber diese Dynamik.
Aber dann ist es nicht mehr Free Speech, oder?
Nee, das ist ja Spam. Blocker als Spammer.
Na gut.
Das ist halt irgendwie digitim.
Und dann gibt es manchmal Leute, die sich dann irgendwie sehr arg an dir abarbeiten oder musst halt irgendwann mal demuten oder so. Dann kommen die halt mal so 14 Tage ins Abklingbecken und dann dürfen sie wieder oder so.
Ach nee, ich bin da radikal. Wer mich einmal nervt, nervt mich immer. Na gut. Damit sind wir, glaube ich, so einigermaßen am Ende oder haben wir noch was?
Das Thema, was du jetzt überspringen willst, ist Lösungsansätze.
Oh ja, stimmt.
Ich hab hier notiert, Tumbleweed und Crickets.
Stimmt, wir wollten tatsächlich irgendwie einen Lösungsansatz. Eine der Lösungsansätze, die du hattest bei Refefe, war die Trollsenke.
Die Trolldrossel.
Trolldrossel.
Bei Refefe war das relativ offenbar, dass allen, dass ich dann nicht zensiere, geschweige denn überhaupt erst lese, das Ding funktionierte dann irgendwie so vor sich hin, wurde natürlich auch sehr, sehr viel Mr. veröffentlicht. Und irgendwann wendeten sich dann Nutzer an mich über das Kontaktformular und sagten, sie hätten jetzt irgendwie hier einen Wunsch, da würden jetzt gerade einige Sachen überhand nehmen, die hätten mit Wildschweinen zu tun und ob man da nicht was machen könnte. Und dann habe ich irgendwie überlegt, wie kann man denn diesem Phänomen begegnen? Und da habe ich dann ein bisschen psychologisch mich der Sache angenähert. Und es gibt eben verschiedene Möglichkeiten, wie du relativ einfach Motivation abbauen kannst. Ja, und das ist eben nicht, was die meisten, was man immer denkt, dass es über Strafe ginge. Also so landläufig meint man immer, okay, Belohnung und Strafe wären so gleichwertige Verstärker einer positiv, einer negativ. Stellt sich aber raus.
Nee, Strafe ist eigentlich positiv, ne? Die Leute sind dann eher, jetzt erst recht.
Strafe ist negativer Verstärker, aber nicht so wirksam wie Belohnung. Und was du eigentlich machen möchtest, also was du eigentlich machen möchtest, wenn du Menschenverhalten abgewöhnen möchtest, ist es ignorieren, denn das Strafen muss auch konsequent erfolgen, damit das Verhalten weg bleibt. Das heißt, es gibt einen Unterschied zwischen Belohnung oder Strafe folgt immer oder es folgt manchmal. Folgt nur manchmal. Und deswegen ist eigentlich das Beste, was du machen kannst, das unerwünschte Verhalten ignorieren, also Konsequenzen loslassen. Das ist die beste Möglichkeit, es nicht mehr zu verstärken und damit die Motivation in deiner Zielperson abzubauen. Was man da machen kann, ist eine schöne Methode, ist Hell-Banning. Das heißt, die Personen schreiben ihren Kommentar, der erscheint auch, aber sie sind die Einzigen, die den sehen, weil sie einen Cookie haben. Und du den einfach für alle anderen Menschen ausblendest. Und dann sitzt dieser Troll da und schreibt sein Kram. Die Seite sieht völlig normal für ihn aus, sein Kommentar ist da. Es reagiert nur niemand drauf. Die anderen unterhalten sich weiter. Und zwar ohne Referenz auf diesen Kommentar. Das ist eine sehr gute Methode, die war mir aber zu kompliziert zu implementieren. Weil ich wollte, ja, wie gesagt, auf dieses Referee einen Tag verwendet und mit der Trolldrossel wurde es dann ein zweiter. Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, okay, ich mache jetzt Folgendes. Ich setze bestimmte Wörter auf eine Art Blacklist, möchte mich aber natürlich nicht der Zensur schuldig machen. Das heißt, wenn jemand wirklich einen Kommentar mit Hitler jetzt unbedingt loswerden will, dann stelle ich einfach nur sicher, dass er das wirklich möchte. Nämlich, ich sage einen Kommentar, mit diesem Wort hat eine sehr hohe Trollwahrscheinlichkeit und mit dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit wird diese Person an dem Captcha scheitern, und zwar egal, ob sie es richtig löst oder nicht. Die Leute haben also dann, wenn der Kommentar bestimmte Kriterien erfüllte, Probleme bekommen, das Captcha zu lösen. Und dann haben sie es nochmal versucht und nochmal versucht und nochmal versucht und wie es die Wahrscheinlichkeit will, haben sie es irgendwann geschafft, ihren Kommentar zu posten.
Aber nur die wirklich wollten.
Nur die wirklich wollten. Das war so ein bisschen noch mal Gelegenheit gegeben, nachzudenken, um zu formulieren oder so. Dann fingen sie irgendwann an, Wörter anders zu schreiben. Dann wurde Wildschwein halt mit AI geschrieben oder so. Und dann Leadspeak wurde dann gemacht. Dann musste ich mich nochmal kurz hinsetzen und so ein Leadspeak-Paser schreiben. Aber das hat eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert. Und es gab dann auch tatsächlich Leute, die dann mir berichteten, dass es irgendwie da besser liefe seitdem. Und ich glaube, dass es halt diese Frustration dann irgendwie so ein unterschwelliges Mittel war, den Leuten irgendwie auch den Spaß an der Plattform zu nehmen. Die haben wahrscheinlich gar nicht gemerkt, dass jetzt irgendwie das, was mit ihnen liegt, dass es an ihnen liegt, sondern einfach nur dieses Scheiß-Capture geht mir auf den Geist. Und es wurde mir berichtet, dass das eigentlich ein ganz probates Mittel war. Ich persönlich muss aber sagen, ich habe jetzt nicht festgestellt, dass ich da die Kommentarqualität nennens werde.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, der Eindruck hat sich nicht aufgedrängt.
Gut, was gibt es denn noch so an Lösungsmöglichkeiten?
Ja, ich habe noch mehr überlegt, dass man vielleicht dafür sorgen kann. Also basierend auf der Beobachtung, die ich vorhin geschildert habe, dass der Zusammenhalt innerhalb dieser Gruppen kleiner zu sein scheint als bei normalen Gruppen, dass man vielleicht dafür sorgt, dass die mehr Zusammenhalt haben. Und da gibt es halt so ein paar Sachen, die man machen kann, indem man zum Beispiel irgendwelche Rituale oder Hardship auf sich nehmen muss. Ja, aber irgendwie bei den Fraternities in Amerika, bei den Unis ist das immer so, dass die dann irgendwie nackt über den Dorfplatz laufen müssen und irgendwie irgendwelche bekloppten Mutproben. Der psychologische Effekt davon ist, dass man dann mehr die Gruppenzugehörigkeit bewertet, höher bewertet und dass man weniger gewillt ist, etwas gegen die Gruppe zu tun.
Was ändert das zum Positiven?
Na, was das zum Positiven ändert, ist, dass ich glaube einfach eins der Probleme, was den Rest verursacht, ist, dass die sich nicht als Gruppe sehen, sondern jeder ist ein Einzelkämpfer und versucht sich gegenüber den anderen in der Gruppe zu profilieren, als ich bin aber näher am dogmatischen Ideal dran, als ihr.
Das ändert aber mit Initiatonsritualen nichts.
Das ist die Frage, müssen wir mal pülen.
Historisch gibt es da nicht viel Evidenz für.
Na doch, also dass die funktionieren, das weiß man, dass diverse Geheimbünde...
Ja, ja, aber dass die tatsächlich dazu beitragen, dass diese Gruppen entspannter, schöner und politischer sind.
Nein, die sind nicht entspannter und schöner, aber immerhin sehen die sich als Gruppe. Und dann heißt es eben auch, dass man versucht...
Die legen mehr Wert auf diese Gruppe.
Die legen mehr Wert darauf, genau.
Innerhalb der Gruppe wahrscheinlich konstruktiver. Oder neigen vielleicht zu nahe.
Ja, und vielleicht kommst du dann innerhalb der Gruppe zu debatten und die zerfleuchen sich nicht mehr. Das ist halt die Frage.
Hab ich.
Ist jetzt auch nur eine Idee.
Große Zweifel dran.
Na ja, du bist ja auch ein Zyniker.
Äh ja.
Zyniker sind wir glaube ich alle drei. Ach was?
Wie jetzt? Wer hat denn das behauptet? Na gut.
Ja, das war's glaube ich schon, oder?
Wir machen mal Schluss. Bleiben bei dem...
Na, knapp fünf Stunden.
Wir bleiben mal bei dem Schlusswort, die Mittel von den Zielen trennen und darüber getrennt debattieren, ist glaube ich ein guter Ansatz, um mal voranzukommen. Ansonsten danken wir Linux sehr herzlich für seine interessanten Kommentare und die Arbeit mit Reef Hefe.
Jetzt wird mir dafür gedankt, am 1. April wurde ich noch abgemahnt.
Ja, na ja, du weißt doch, ob der Mandant erst nur seine Eingemeinen gleich nicht war. Und dann danken wir euch auch fürs Zuhören.
Weißt du, wenn du nicht mal ein Design kopiert hättest, dann würde ich dich ja nicht erinnern.
Da müssten wir jetzt echt nochmal wirklich Markus danken, weil der hat den Text komplett alleine formuliert, Markus Komper. Das war großartig. Vielen Dank.
Ganz großes Kino.
Ja, richtig. Ja, ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr auf den Flatter-Button drücken und die Sendung kommentieren. Und wenn ihr Lust habt, könnt ihr ausnahmsweise dieses Mal tatsächlich, also wirklich eine große Ausnahme, mal die Sendung kommentieren, weil Linus hat tatsächlich einen Reh Alternativlos gebaut, in dem ihr euch austoben könnt, unter Regeln und Bedingungen, die noch nicht vollständig öffentlich des Klos sind, die wir vielleicht in einer der nächsten Sendungen dann mal erklären.
Und die davon abhängig sind, ob ihr euch jetzt benehmt oder nicht.
Genau, die Frage, Teil welches psychologischen Extremenz ihr seid und ob ihr Teil der A- oder B-Gruppe seid, wird der Vater dann später. Ansonsten dann vielen Dank nochmal und bis zum nächsten Mal.